Ja, ich bin jetzt zufrieden.
Halt! Unterzeugen? Läuft die Aufnahme? Haben die schonest das mitkriegen?
Ich bin zufrieden. Ich bin zufrieden. Ich bin zufrieden.
Das ist einer dieser Momente.
Im Umgang mit Superlativem ist Vorsicht geboten, sie nutzen sich leicht ab. Aber heute Abend darf man einen riskieren, es ist ein historischer Tag.
Es war ein wunderbarer Abend, das uns bewältigen.
Und ich fühle mich so gut, dass ich meinen Schaum ausdrücke und jeder andere, der sich fühlen will, fühlt sich gut.
Ich denke, dass es wenige Punkte in der Weltgeschichte gibt, wo einen so etwas ausgelöst hat.
Herzlich willkommen bei Bum, zack, return.
Ein Moment des Innerhaltens und der, ja, wie soll ich sagen, Zeitenwende steht an. Präsidenten ziehen ihre Jackets aus. Ja, ich bin's. Tim, wo sonst ist keiner da?
Trauen uns alle nicht mehr.
Nein, Quatsch, nur Roddi ist nicht da, aber der Rest ist da. Clemens ist da. Hallo. Bist du laut genug?
Ich höre mich selber nicht, aber das kann ich selber steuern.
Steuere das doch mal, Alios.
Soll ich dir mal das iPad reichen?
Schönen Gute.
Huckel ist da.
Hallo. Ich bin aus dem Urlaub aus Sachsen wieder da.
Ja, super.
Du warst doch gar nicht weg.
War ich gar nicht weg. Ich hatte noch keine Zeit. Du warst etwas weg.
Du hast deine Prioritäten einfach nur falsch gesetzt.
Ne, so würd ich das nicht sagen.
Ja, und Dennis, wa? Ja, bist auch da.
Richtig geil.
Da sind wir. Und das Ganze heißt immer noch Mobimex und ja, 113. Ausgabe und es ist jetzt irgendwie alles, weiß nicht, man fühlt sich so ein bisschen wie überfahren, oder? Jetzt haben wir das letzte Mal schon so komplett ausgetobt mit diesen ganzen Themenlagen. Das eine oder andere Detail haben wir, glaube ich, auch übersehen. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, ob das alles zusammengeht.
Aber sag mal hier, ja, passend zum, hört man mich richtig?
Du musst dein Mikrofon so drehen, dass die Spitze auf dein Mund zeigt und nicht aufs Nasenloch.
Dann wähl ich doch gar nicht mehr, das ist doch ein Markenzeichen.
Dein Signature-Move.
Tantiemen von, von, von, von, welche Firma hat das gerade gekauft? Disney, von Disney, genau. Nee, du hast doch sag mal, hier diese Low-Pudelei auf dieses Mavericks, ja?
Ja. Ist alles nicht gerechtfertigt?
Weiß ich nicht, aber ich meine, du hast es, benutzt hast es ja noch nie, oder? Ich meine, außer dem Marketing-Zeug hast du noch nichts gesehen, oder?
Nee, der Schock kommt noch erst.
Ja, wollte ich meinen. Also die Renterei kommt später.
Aber...
Na heute nicht. Heute nicht. Tim hat ja vorhin schon eigentlich gesagt, er kann heute nicht mehr mehr renten.
Aber wir haben schon ein Developer-Bild in der Firma mal installiert, so zum Gucken. Und was man sagen kann, also egal, was man nicht sagen darf, egal, was man nicht sagen darf, egal! Also die Maps-App, die reißt alles raus. Also so auf so einem riesen Bildschirm, so diese Maps-App und dann birlt hier, wie heißt das, Flyover, was auch immer, da brauchst du nix mehr anderes, besser als Google Earth.
Also so eine große Eiffel Tower durch.
Ja, besser als Google Earth. Wir haben nix anderes gemacht. Ja, das war schon mal mein Wunsch. Aber auch ein Dicken Mac Pro.
Ich hab zu Hause auch ein Dicken Mac Pro, das war irgendwie flutschend nicht so richtig.
Na ja gut, aber ja.
Ja, weil es schick aussieht.
Aber so, ja das sieht schick aus, ne, was auch total wirklich toll ist, also das wir dann natürlich gleich nochmal ausprobiert haben, sind diese Fullscreens und so und wie sich das jetzt alles so verhält. Und auch da, das ist ja so ein riesen Stachel quasi hier so drin gewesen die ganze Zeit und man dachte aah, was macht dieser Stachel da? Aber raus hat man auch nicht gekriegt und der ist jetzt weg. Und ist auch gut verheilt und haben sie schon, das haben sie auch richtig, glaube ich, diesmal. Diesmal ist wirklich richtig.
Bei den Kommentaren der letzten Sendung hatte jemand ein Video verlinkt von so einem Engländer. Der mit seinen sechs Bildschirmen. Ja, der war nicht zufrieden, weil er einen Hintergrund hat, der über alle sechs Bildschirme geht und er jetzt nicht mehr die Bankengerichte zusammen zu pusteln.
Oha, kann er nicht mehr so schön pausen mit seinem riesen Hintergrundbild.
Das kann ich sogar nachvollziehen, aber das andere Ding, was er meinte, ist, dass man Fenster, also wenn man in diesen neuen Modus geht, dass man Fenster nicht mehr über zwei Bildschirme hinweg expandieren kann.
Das könnte, denke ich, noch ein Bugs sein. Wir reden ja immerhin über eine Beta. Das glaube ich nicht. Oder, das macht natürlich auch Sinn, weil wenn du jetzt den Hintergrund wechselst und dann hängt da mal noch so ein halbes Fenster, was zu einem ganz anderen Hintergrund gehört, ja. Aber es ist trotzdem ärgerlich, weil es gibt schon Leute, die das benutzen, ich benutze das auch gelegentlich. Dass da so Sachen rüber hängen.
Ja, aber ich muss auch sagen, ich benutze es. Also es gibt so Momente, wo es mal geil ist. Was weiß ich, wenn man mal so ein richtig fettes Excel-Sheet hat und so weiter. Und ich meine, wer jetzt sagen wir mal in dem Modus unbedingt jetzt arbeiten will, für den das auch wichtig ist, der hat ja den alten Modus noch. Also es ist ja nicht weg.
Es kann nicht sein, dass der aber bloß irgendwelche Präferenzes von hinten rum durch die Brust ins Auge umgeschaltet hat, und dass es dafür gar keinen offiziellen Schalter gibt. Gutmaßig jetzt mal. Weil das wäre das erste Mal, dass Apple das so macht. Das weiß ich nicht genau, aber in diesem Video war ja davon die Rede. Kann ja sein, dass er hinten irgendwelche Präferenzes von Hand umgeforscht hat. Weil vor allen Dingen auch mit ausloggen und einloggen und so.
Der Schalter könnte halt kommen, weiß ich nicht, ob der da ist.
Aber eigentlich hat es sich erst mal ganz gut angefühlt. Also auch dieses mit dem Dock drüben und Dock hier und Menübar da. Also wenn man es braucht, geht es so einem aus dem Weg. Es ist jetzt nicht mehr so, wie komme ich jetzt wieder ran? Wo ist dieser Scheißbutton da oben? Und weißt schon, es hat sich erst mal ganz gut angefühlt. Wir haben es jetzt auch nicht so ewig lange ausprobiert, aber es war schon mal die großen Schmerzen.
Da gibt es schon noch so ein paar Edge-Cases. Es gibt auch so ein paar Sachen, wo ich mir immer gedacht habe, das wäre mal schön, wenn das anders lief, wo ich aber nicht unbedingt die Erwartung habe. Also was ja auch so ein Ding ist, ist dieses, wenn der Bildschirm nicht da ist, also du schaltest ihn aus oder zu und dann ziehst ihn ab. Du hast jetzt, gehen wir mal von diesem sechser Setup aus, was er da hat, das ist jetzt vielleicht eher selten, aber das macht den Punkt jetzt etwas klarer. So, jetzt schaltest du den Bildschirm links oben ab und dann schaltest du den Bildschirm rechts oben ab und dann schaltest du den Bildschirm links oben wieder an. Landet der dann auch unter Garantie wieder an derselben Stelle, merkt er sich diese Positionen und die Reihenfolgen immer?
Das kann er jetzt schon. Die spannende Frage ist, was macht er mit dem Content, der da drauf ist?
Genau, schubst er ihn dann automatisch irgendwo hin und so.
Ich mach das häufiger. Ich wechsle mit meinem MacBook Pro immer zu verschiedenen Stellen und ich hab fast überall einen zweiten Bildschirm, aber mal steht der drüber, mal steht der rechts daneben, mal steht der links daneben und solange das OS X diese Dinge erkennen kann, also diese Bildschirme mit einer eindeutigen ID haben, das haben meine Dinger irgendwie offensichtlich alle und sie alle wieder so an, wo sie hingehören. Das kann ich jetzt schon und das auch nicht erst seit Mountain Lion.
Ich hatte...
Was man jetzt mal probieren müsste, ist, wenn man zwei exakt identische Bildschirmtypen nimmt, weil ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob er sich an dem Typ orientiert oder ob da über die Schnittstelle auch eine Serie nochmal mit rüberkommt, aber ich hab unterschiedliche Bildschirmtypen aus historischen Gründen und deswegen, egal, was ich da dran stecke, steht immer alles so, wie ich es letztes Mal verlassen habe. Und wie gesagt, meine zwei Bildschirme stehen unterschiedlich.
Also ich kriege das gerade nicht zusammen formuliert, aber ich habe schon mal so Situationen gehabt, dass dann irgendwie Bildschirme auf einmal woanders waren in der Reihenfolge und so.
Du machst ja auch so Faxen mit deiner Grafikkarten untentauschen in der Reihenfolge, oder PCI-Slots oder sowas, ne?
Jeden Tag dreimal.
Jeden Mal, wenn er an dem Ding leckt.
Ist ja bald vorbei mit den neuen Mac Pro.
Ja, aber lass uns mal, wenn wir sowieso schon mit OS X eingestiegen sind, vielleicht dabei auch bleiben. Was ich noch gehört habe ist, dass dieses Versions-Feature weg ist. Da hat wohl keiner so richtig speziell drauf geachtet, weil wahrscheinlich niemand das so verurteilt hat. Oder vermisst das oder sowas.
Was ist denn dieses Versions nochmal? Was kann denn das?
Naja, Versions ist, ich meine, und was mit Versions ja zusammenhängt, ist dieser Autosave-Mechanismus. Und wenn das jetzt nicht da ist, also das wäre mal ganz interessant, ob der Chat da auch nochmal irgendwelche unabhängigen Bestätigungen hat oder verweisen kann.
Ich kann mich gar nicht, also welche Apps benutzen das denn außer die Apple Apps?
Na, alle. TextEdit.
Nee, so Third-Party-Apps. Benutzen das irgendwelche Third-Party? Aber ich kann mich überhaupt nicht erinnern, dass ich irgendein Programm benutze, was Versions benutzt.
TextEdit.
Eben. Ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern, dass ich irgendein Programm benutze.
Das ist sehr interessant.
Das ist auch so ein bisschen vom Design her broken. Ich benutze das sehr häufig einfach so als Notizzettel. Jemand ruft dich an und sagt, ja, ich geb ihm mal eine Telefonnummer, dann mach ich halt einfach, gib mir mal so einen neuen Zettel. So und wenn ich das Programm umbringe, sind alle Zettel wieder da oder wenn ich meinen Rechner runterfahre oder so. Aber ansonsten sagt TextEdit, ich möchte das immer unbedingt irgendwo hin speichern. Wenn ich TextEdit normalerweise versuche zu beenden, dann sagt er, nein, das kann ich jetzt hier nicht beenden oder ich kann das ganze OSX nicht runterfahren, bevor du mir nicht gesagt hast, wo du deine ganzen 12, 13, 20 Zettel da irgendwie hin gespeichert haben willst. Die natürlich alle untitelt, keine Ahnung, bin jetzt beantitelt, 46 oder so.
Ja, so war es früher.
So, aber der Witz ist, wenn du das Ding umbringst, wenn du TextEdit einfach umbringst oder dein Rechner crashst, sind alle noch da. Also der macht irgendwie ein Autosave irgendwo hin, keine Ahnung wo, aber die Zettel sind immer noch da.
Hier ist unter Leiden, unter Mountain Line.
Ja, aber Kappa kein Mavericks. Als ich eben hergeradelt bin, habe ich an der Videothek, hier oben Greifswalder Straße habe ich gesehen, da hängt ein Plakat für ein Film, der heißt Mavericks. Ich habe schon gedacht, ich halte an, für euch auf jeden Fall, aber es ist ein komischer Gurkenfilm.
Also das, was du sagst, kann so nicht ganz stimmen, weil seit Leiden ist es ja eher so, dass wenn du eben ein leeres Dokument machst, dann kannst du eben TextEdit einfach quitten.
Du kannst nicht quitten, sag mal Quitt.
Dann hast du dein System aber noch in den alten Modus gestellt, dass es sich so verhält wie früher.
Ja, hier guck, mach ich TextEdit, gehen die alten auf, mach ein neues Fenster. Und wenn ich das jetzt wieder aufmache, dann muss ich mal gucken, dann ist es auch noch da.
Gibt es da ein Setting, wo man das machen kann?
Ja, es gibt das Setting. Hier in dem General Setting gibt es diesen schönen Restore. Das ist jetzt nur Line wohlgemerkt. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob sich das bei Mountain Lion irgendwie geändert hat.
Du bist jetzt voll hinterher.
Ich hab diese Restore Windows mal grundsätzlich abgewirkt, weil mich das nach dem Reboot immer so ein bisschen nervt. Deswegen kann es sein, dass das versehentlich dann mal raus abgewirkt habe, weil wie gesagt, an sich möchte ich das nur als Notizblock haben. Untitled 1 bis Untitled 4711 und auf und zu.
Dafür gibt es ja die Notiz ab.
Nee, die stinkt.
Ja, aber dafür gibt es die.
Ich benutze dafür TextMate mittlerweile. TextMate ist mein neues Textedit geworden.
Ich habe ja Bleistöfte bekommen letztens.
Deswegen sieht dein Macbook so komisch aus.
Die bastliche Version von Textmate.
Die alte, die ich mir irgendwann gekauft habe. So als Textedit ist das voll okay. So um als mal eben hier ein paar Anteile Documents und da irgendwas in die Zwischenablage und so.
Aber die hatte ja nicht dieses Autosave.
Ne, ne, eben genau. Deswegen, also ich benutze halt eigentlich keine Programme. So den Use-Case, den Clemens gerade mit Textedit beschreibt, dafür benutze ich Textmate. Das heißt, ich habe da nicht dieses Autosave-Feature. Wenn zu ist, ist weg. Und ich nicht gespeichert habe und ihm nicht gesagt hat, wo es hingeht.
Das macht man ja ganz oft Bill, ne?
Ja und irgendwie auch mein Wim, der kann auch kein Autosave.
Doch, da musst du nur Control, Alt, L, Q und 3.
Und iMovie, alles Mögliche.
Der Chat kommt jetzt gerade rein. Hier wird gerade getestet, Textedit, neues Fenster, Text rein, Quit. Textedit beendet sich einfach und ist wieder da. Also Autosave ist sozusagen noch vorhanden. Die Frage ist, ist das Versionsfeature noch vorhanden?
Man meint, A maverick supported versions laut A maverick's core technology overview PDF.
Ich kann aber der Kollege im Chat, der das gerade getestet hat, oben einfach mal auf das kleine Dreieck da oben auf der Titelseile von Textedit klicken, und gucken, ob er da irgendwelche Versionen findet.
Dann war das vielleicht keine richtige Information, die ich da bekommen habe.
Eigentlich geht es auch gar nicht, dass sie es einfach wieder rausschmeißen, weil die haben dann eine API bereitgestellt für ihre Developer, und dann fangen Leute an dagegen zu coden. Dann kann Apple das so auf die Schnelle nicht mehr.
Okay, also dann war das eine Fehlinformation.
The Lawn Mower doesn't care.
Das hätte mich auch überrascht.
Ganz so schlimm ist es nicht.
Ja, trotzdem ist das... Manchmal ist es halt irgendwie auch nicht das richtige Verhalten. Also der Klassiker für mich, ich hatte das hier auch schon mal beklagt, das ist, wenn du halt alte Dokumente öffnest. Und weißt du, manchmal macht man das so, dass man so, da hatte ich doch mal den Text, da hatte ich doch mal das Spreadsheet, in dem ich irgendwie was ausgerechnet hatte. Und dann fummelst du da so ein bisschen drin rum, um gerade mal für eine ähnliche Rechnung was Ähnliches zu simulieren. So, und dann ist das ja quasi schon gespeichert. Aber irgendwie ist man so ein bisschen...
Ja, du hast ein einfaches Nichts, weil dann sagt er, die ist ja älter als eine Woche oder zwei, und dann sagt er, die ist locker, du musst erst ein Duplikat machen.
Wenn du ein altes Dokument aufmachst, dann musst du das entweder anlocken oder ein Duplikat von erstellen. So schlau waren sie schon. Also ist nicht ganz kaputt.
Für uns alte Opas, die waren noch in Files denken, das sind natürlich alle so ein bisschen so ein Problem.
Aber bald hast du deine Numberspreadsheets in der Cloud, und dann ist ja alles super.
Aber noch was zu OSC, dann können wir mal über Iwork ran, weil das haben wir letztes Mal gar nicht tangiert.
Nee, OSC war die einzige News, die du eben hattest, stellten sich ja gerade als Fake News raus.
Ich hab auch dieses Dokument geschaut. Ich bin heute übrigens nicht wirklich zu nichts zu gebrauchen. Also ich bin nicht wirklich zu was zu gebrauchen.
Nicht mal zum Renten.
Wir kriegen die schon noch.
Ich bin doof. Ja, gab es sonst noch was zu OSC? Aber Hockel, du warst ja letztes Mal nicht da. Du musst ja im Prinzip noch mal deine Meinung etwas mehr kund tun. Ja, würde mich mal interessieren, was du so denkst.
Ich war ja dann an dem Tag noch in England, als diese Keynote kam. Da hab ich mir dann mühsam durch das schmalbandige Internet, was mir da zur Verfügung stand, über das...
Tempo ist nicht schnell genug, um das alles aufzuzeichnen. Deswegen müssen Sie das ein bisschen runterbremsen.
Hab ich mir dann über Nacht mühsam aus dem Netz gelutscht und dann am nächsten Tag geschaut und dachte mir jetzt... Also... Ich hatte Schlimmeres befürchtet. Wir haben ja schon mal drüber gesprochen. Und dann dachten wir so, oh Gott, wenn wir jetzt so weitermachen mit dieser Verheiratung von iOS und MacOS und irgendwie dann verschwinden die Files und so weiter. Und die ganz große Verheiratung ist ja glücklicherweise ausgeblieben. Von daher war ich schon zufrieden, als ich feststellte, das sieht noch aus wie ein Desktop-Betriebssystem.
Ja, mehr sogar noch. Das ist im Vergleich zum Mountainline.
So, Finder-Taps, ja gut. Jetzt nicht so großartig. Also ich fand es ganz nett, dass er das mit den Multi-Table-Displays jetzt doch nochmal ernst genommen haben. Und ja, was war denn da noch? Irgendwie Maps halt, ja super. Jawohl, es könnte ganz nett sein, aber ich sehe mich noch nicht Tags benutzen. Also im Wesentlichen war ich eigentlich ganz froh, dass sich jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel geändert hat, ganz ehrlich so.
Das mit den Tags finde ich übrigens gut. Und ich bin ehrlich gesagt ganz schön überrascht, wie tief sie das eingebaut haben.
Ich bin da auch erstmal noch nicht, ich bin nicht skeptisch, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass ich es am Ende nicht benutze, aber da lasse ich mich mal überraschen. Also da habe ich noch nicht so eine ganz feste Meinung. Weil bisher kam es mir ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so oft vor, dass ich dieses Tags-Feature wirklich...
Ich auch.
Ich benutze die Farben andauernd.
Aber die Farben haben halt keinerlei Semantik außer Farben. Und das heißt, du musst dir die Semantik für jeden Ordner immer wieder neu dazudenken und es geht halt nicht über die Farben. Ja, du darfst die beschriften, aber du kannst halt, das ist halt dieses alte Ding, es ist halt Kategorie und nicht Tag. Tag kannst du halt mehrere von haben, Kategorie nur eine. Das heißt, das Ding ist halt blau oder grün, aber es kann halt nicht blau-grün sein. Und mit Tags geht es halt jetzt beides. Und das ist schon ein ganz erheblicher Unterschied zu dem, wie es eben vorher funktioniert hat, weil jetzt kannst du eben Dinge auch, sagen wir mal, schon per Folder-Ablage einem Primärprojekt zuordnen, aber trotzdem die Datei als auch zu etwas anderem zugehörig markieren.
Also, ich meine, da wo ich Tags benutze, das sind zwei Sachen im Wesentlichen. Musik, ganz klar, da ist schon der Scope relativ eng, sozusagen, und das zweite, wo ich das ganz viel benutze, ist bei Bookmarks. Also immer wenn ich so einen Bookmark irgendwo in so einem Service speichere, dann gebe ich halt immer diese Tags und dann ist dieses Feature halt auch wirklich nach so, ja, irgendwas mit JavaScript und dann kannst du nochmal so, oder dann kannst du die irgendwie anders umgruppieren und so weiter. Aber ob ich das mit Files halt so wirklich machen will, das weiss ich noch nicht so. Aber ja, wie gesagt, ich lass mich mal überraschen. Was gab's denn noch? Ach so, eine Sache, wo ich auch so ein bisschen skeptisch bin, ist dieses Compressed Memory. Ob's das jetzt wirklich...
Hast du eigentlich unsere Sendung gehört? Da waren wir eigentlich sehr optimistisch.
Ja, überhaupt Kompressionen...
Ich hab zuhause probiert, mal ein bisschen meinen Rechner dazu zu kriegen, dass er mal ein bisschen compressed. Aber ich hab da leider 16 Gigs drin und hab das nicht geschafft.
Ja, also ich weiß auch nicht. Also baut doch lieber mehr RAM ein. Ich weiß nicht, ob man wirklich Compressed Memory braucht.
Das Problem ist, dass halt eben gelegentlich Virtual Memory alleziiert wird, der ja nicht gebraucht wird. Und dann musst du ihn haben. Du kannst beliebig viel RAM einbauen, damit tritt das Problem einfach ein paar Stunden später auf. Aber früher, später möchte da irgendjemand Virtual Memory haben.
War das nicht aber eventuell auch so, dass es nur eingeschaltet wird, wenn man auf Batteriemodus ist oder irgendwie sowas? Welches Feature war das? Ah nee, dieses Timer-Coalescing war für nur Batterie, ne?
Also ich sag mal, diese komischen Power-Features hier, das Timer-Coalescing, App-Nap, Power-Saver und Compressed Memory, solange ich davon in der Performance, in der Snappiness meines Gerätes überhaupt nichts merke, bitteschön. Aber wenn ich irgendwann mal irgendeinen Tap nach vorne hole und dann macht's wieder so plötzlich so wupp wupp, so ein spürbarer Delay, dann...
Ja gut, aber das ist ja genau dagegen.
Ja okay, das wollen wir mal sehen.
Also das Compressed Memory, das ist halt schnell. Also schnell im Sinne von so dermaßen schnell, dass es viel schneller ist als jede andere Maßnahme, die du dann ergreifen müsstest, weil halt gerade der Speicher... Und vor allem, du sparst ja auch Swap auf der Platte. Was bei diesen großen Ram-Mengen heutzutage auch nicht ganz unterheblich ist.
Ich meine ja auch so eine Kombination von diesen ganzen Technologien.
Deine SSD wird nicht so viel abgenuckelt.
Die SSD wird nicht so viel abgenuckelt. Ja, es ist einfach generell nicht sinnvoll.
Und im Moment, wo sie irgendwie Ruck, Ruck, Ruck macht, kommt auch ein bisschen später erst. Weil es ja wegkompresst und dadurch mehr...
Genau, also ich finde das total sinnvoll, das Feature, wo du mich jetzt gerade darauf hingewiesen hast, dieses Timer-Qualessing machen sie nur im Battery-Mode? Kann gut sein.
Weil warum sollten sie das machen, wenn Strom dran ist? Dann müssen sie ja da nicht so ein Voodoo machen, dann können sie die Timer wieder ordentlich fahren.
Da steht auf jeden Fall, giving your battery a break, too.
Darf ich gerade noch mal ganz kurz, eine Sekunde noch auf Text zurückkommen, sonst veräst sie das wieder. Die Leute, die das hier schon drauf haben, können sie mal nachgucken, wo diese Texts im Fallsystem abgespeichert werden. Ist das wieder so ein Extended Attribute für Finder-Info?
Kannst du mal davon ausgehen, dass das die ganz normale Spotlight-Metadata-Infrastruktur ist, die jetzt auch schon verwendet wird?
Und bei dir ist ja noch was anderes. Wenn du so was bunt machst, dann wird halt ein Extended Attribute angelegt für das File. Es nennt halt COM, Apple, Finder, Info und dann schmieren sie da irgendwie was rein. Die Frage ist, ob sie diese Texts auch irgendwo da drin verwuddeln oder ob es da für einen separaten Extended Attribute gibt.
Das wird nicht dem Finder zugeordnet sein, denke ich mal.
Aber wenn du das File kopierst, verlierst du dann das Tag oder was auf ein anderes System?
Normalerweise kommt darauf an, wie du das kopierst. Das war aber jetzt auch schon so. Wenn du jetzt deinen File mit allen möglichen Tra-La-La-Kopierst, werden auch die Extended Attributes mit kopiert und wenn du das irgendwie versuchst, um worüber zu schummeln oder das auf ein SMB-Filesystem oder so was draufwusstest oder sonst etwas, oder dabei beim Kopieren einen Quark machst, dann verlieren die Dinge alle. Dann sind dir aber alle diese Farbmarkierungen weg und irgendwelchen anderen Zeugs oder sowas. Aber wie gesagt, wer das da hat, bitte mal kurz nachgucken. Einfach mal einen Tag irgendwo drauf machen, gucken, was das für Extended Attributes hat. Das würde mich mal interessieren. Ich bin ja noch so ein Command Line User.
Das ist eine absolut berechtigte Frage, wo es jetzt genau liegt, aber das müsste eigentlich im Fall liegen.
Für die, die nicht wissen, Ls minus add zum Beispiel in der Kommandanzelle. Ja, minus Add-Zeichen. Dann zeigt er dir die Extended Attributes an. Zumindest die Namen der Extended Attributes. Dann kannst du dir mit X-Adre den Namen gucken, was da drin steht. Aber das würde mich mal interessieren. Ich muss mit meinen Geräten arbeiten, außerdem bin ich kein Apple-Developer. Deswegen kein Mavericks.
Tja, traurig. Aber es ist wahrscheinlich auch noch nicht... Also die Zeiten, wo wir uns ja jede BetaOS installiert haben, die sind ja auch vorbei. Zumindest auf dem Desktop, auf dem Telefon. Dafür umso mehr. Wie es so aussieht. Du hast es drauf, ne?
Was hielst du denn von dieser Keynote an sich?
Ach, die fand ich sehr sympathisch tatsächlich. Also ich hab immer noch ein Problem, wenn der Tim spricht, der Cook.
Aber es ist besser geworden.
Aber es ist besser geworden, muss man sagen. Und ihr Freak-Cready-Ricky oder so, den hat sich da scheinbar zu langsam als den Keynote-Star hochlemmen hin. Der war auf jeden Fall sehr... Also da ich so das eine oder andere Mal tatsächlich schmunzeln müssen, was er für Sprüche zwischendurch gebracht hat und Witzchen und so, den fand ich sehr angenehm. Also der hatte ja bei seinen diversen Auftritten einfach immer so einen Spruch dabei.
Ich glaub, der mochte den Scott Forstel. Ich hatte immer noch mal so nachgetreten.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so jetzt unbedingt auf Scott Forstel...
Er hat auf jeden Fall auf diesen Geomorphismus, natürlich hat er auch so einige Male so. Da war auch hier, we literally ran out of Greenfeld oder so.
Tja, ob das, womit sie das jetzt ersetzt haben, automatisch so sehr viel besser ist, I don't know. Also beim Game Center, diese komischen Blasen.
Das ist tausendmal besser als diese komischen...
Also bei den Blasen denke ich einfach an Blasen, aber nicht... also vorher wusste ich zumindest, dass es was mit Games zu tun hat.
Und Kugeln haben nichts mit Games zu tun?
Blasen, Seitenblasen.
Wie oft benutzt du denn Game Center jetzt mal?
Ja, Seitenblasen und Spaß und Kinder und so.
Also das ist einfach nicht... mit der Assoziation wäre ich jetzt nicht hoch.
Ja, aber mal ehrlich, das ist besser als irgendwo so, was eigentlich eher schon mit dem Glücksspiel zu verbinden ist, wie dieses grüne Samt. Da denkt man doch schon eher an so einen Poker-Tisch. Okay, Billy hat vielleicht noch so ein bisschen, aber eigentlich mehr an Zocken und an Geld. Das hat auch nicht so das schicke Image. So gesehen sind da so ein paar... Seifenbläschen hier, die so ein bisschen rumschweben. Sieht doch viel modern aus. Mehr Farbe, ein bisschen frischer. Wir sind hier im 21. Jahrhundert. Da müssen wir nicht hier so einen Pokertisch vom 200 Jahre her einsetzen.
Na ja, also bei Gameshatter kann man sich schon noch streiten, aber ich find's trotzdem optisch gesehen einfach um einiges angenehmer. Also wirklich. Ja, Mac OS haben wir jetzt ja schon durch, ne? Wir steigen jetzt quasi direkt ein, nochmal die Keynote live zu verfolgen.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich schon alles ist, was wir zu OS X irgendwie sagen können oder sollten.
Na, die Maps-App ist toll. Den Kalender-Shut, den hab ich gar nicht ausprobiert.
Den Maps hab ich auch ausprobiert, das ist ganz okay.
Ja, es waren nur so 10 Minuten, so in der Mittagspause, mal ein bisschen rumdatteln. Und dann haben sich alle vor diesen Maps im Fullscreen auf dem 27 Zoll festgeguckt und ja, dann war's passiert.
Ja, ich bin gespannt, wie viel wirklich diese Batteriesparerei bringen wird, weil sie ja jetzt auch bei der Hardware schon so kräftig vorgelegt haben.
Das würde ich auch behaupten, dass diese Mavericks auch schon eine ganze Menge halt vor allem für Laptops an Featuren hat. Also Desktop sind jetzt, wie wir ja wissen, verkaufen sie ja nicht mehr so viele. Ich glaube, es ist schon auch sehr mobile optimiert, dieses OS.
Multiple Screens, würde ich jetzt sagen, ist eigentlich eher so ein Pro-Feature.
Nee, nicht wirklich. Das ist auch gerade dann, wenn du deinen Laptop eher oder MacBook Pro halt irgendwie an noch zusätzlichen Display anschließt. Also ich glaube, viel mehr Leute nutzen das mit ihrem Laptop, als dass sie einen Mac Pro haben, wo sie zwei Displays dran machen.
Das würde ich überhaupt nicht sehen.
Klar, da gibt es natürlich die feine Card-User und so, aber mal ehrlich, wie viel sind das?
Wenn du einen Mac Pro hast, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass da mehr als ein Bildschirm dran ist. Sehr viel größer, als wenn du einen Laptop hast.
Also ich hab einen Mac Pro, da ist ein Bildschirm dran. Und vorher war an dem gleichen Bildschirm halt mein MacBook Pro dran, aber da hatte ich auch schon mal den Deckel zu, weil ich mag eigentlich zwei Bildschirme gar nicht so leicht.
Ja, aber mal ehrlich, also die meisten Laptops werden einfach Single-Screen benutzt und deswegen haben sie auch ursprünglich dieses Feature so gemacht und sich nicht groß Gedanken gemacht. Und jetzt haben alle die Pro-User rumgenervt und so. Also kann man das nicht anders vorstellen.
Ich glaube, die Pro-User haben schon am meisten geschrien, doch.
Naja, also ich bin gespannt, wie OST sich so einführt. Was ist euer Tipp? Wann kommt's raus?
Herbst. Ja, ich mein, so ist doch jetzt irgendwie, jetzt ist, wat, jetzt haben wir gleich Juli. Und August, ne, wann? September?
Sollen wir offizielle Schätzung abgeben, ja? Ok, 10. Oktober.
Das klingt ja jetzt so, als ob so ziemlich alles, was jetzt angekündigt wurde, im Fall kommt, dann auf einmal rauskommt.
Der muss ja so ein bisschen, das iPhone kommt mit dem iOS 7 zusammen raus. Und das weiß ich nicht, ob das Mavericks passend mit dem Mac Pro irgendwie erscheinen wird.
Also unter Garantie läuft dieser Mac Pro nur unter Mavericks. War das jemals anders?
Ja, das ist so, weil die das so wollen, aber die könnten auch schon anders. Am Ende ist dieses Ding auch nur ein PC mit ein bisschen Zeug drin. Also da könnten die 10.4 drauf fahren, wenn sie wollten.
Also klar könnten sie das, aber die Frage ist, wollen wir zum Mac Pro wechseln?
Moment, eine Sache, die jetzt zum Beispiel noch nicht geht, also mit iOS 7, das AirDrop geht noch nicht mit dem Mountain Line.
Nee, es geht nur mit dem Mavericks.
Das heißt, du brauchst dann auch...
10, 6, 8, 10, ne wie heißt das?
Du hast auch gesehen, dass du das für bestimmte Leute freischalten kannst.
Ja, ich hab's für alle und es geht nicht.
Aber wir beide könnten jetzt geil über das Sport testen.
Macht ihr mal weiter, wir tauschen hier mal Körperflüssigkeiten.
Von meinem neuen Verstärker.
Ich mach jetzt everyone. Hoffentlich steht jetzt keiner vor der Tür und schickt mir Zeugnis.
Ah, da ist er, Black Surfer.
Und jetzt kann ich einen Screenshot machen und kann dann die Kleinen machen. Und du denkst gar nicht, dass ich es schon hab, obwohl ich mir einen Screenshot gemacht hab. So und die Kleinen, jetzt hab ich's.
Steht da auch die Kleinen.
Ja, siehste, aber warte, jetzt guck ich nach. Die regen sich gerade so auf, dass irgendein Snapchat unter Mavericks, ne, unter iOS 7 nicht mehr den Screenshot detectet. Ja, siehste, ich hab das hier. Und jetzt ich zu dir, ja? Jetzt bist du dran.
Also, das heißt, um dieses tolle Feature, das ist ja wirklich ein absolutes Killer-Feature, nutzen zu können, da braucht man dann auch den...
Gut, das wird sicherlich noch kommen. Was sich ja auch noch geändert hat, ist Safari, unser neues Prozessmodell. Da bin ich ja ganz scharf drauf. Weil, so wie es derzeit läuft, läuft es einfach gar nicht, ne?
Also, AirDrop funktioniert.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein cooles Feature, weil das ist das, was schon immer gefehlt hat. Ja, also so direkt von iPhone zu iPhone, man kann schnell was austauschen, ohne dass man dem gleich eine Mail schicken muss oder irgendwie so über 1000 Umwegeserver.
Oder auch zum Rechner.
Wenn man auch nicht geht, dass dann... Doch, das geht so. Kannst du ein Foto zum Rechner schicken?
Nein, nicht mit Mountain Line, aber mit Mavericks, ja dann hoffentlich. Kann man schon, geht nicht. Taucht nicht, uff.
Hier, ich schick dir mal...
Aber auf welche Dokumente kannst du den dann zugreifen mit dem AirDrop?
Na, auf dem iOS meinste?
Ja, auf welche Dokumente? Na, alles Mögliche.
Du hast ja überall diesen Share-Button. Überall wo du diesen Share-Button hast, kannst du auch sagen, schickt den ans AirDrop und dann schiebt er das da raus. Also du hast ja hier so eine Spalte, ich zeig dir das mal. Hier drückst du auf Share und dann gibt es hier diese Spalte und da sind alle AirDropper, die da gerade am Start sind drin und dann dätscht du da drauf.
Ich schicke dir mal zum Beispiel Kontaktdaten von jemandem. Jetzt kommt bei dir so ein Fensterchen und dann kannst du annehmen. Hier steht Waiting bei mir und blinkt. Und jetzt hast du es angenommen, Send.
Aber ich finde, das haben sie ja zum Beispiel ziemlich cool gemacht.
Na komm, sag schon, obwohl du kannst ja heute nicht mehr renten.
Ich hatte ehrlich gesagt noch keine echte Quality-Time mit iOS 7, von daher kann ich da nicht so viel.
Also da hab ich jetzt schon einiges an Time, nicht nur Quality-Time hinter mir bisher.
Aber da waren wir ja noch nicht.
Dann sparen wir uns das erstmal auf oder wollen wir gleich auf iOS 7 gehen.
Du wolltest jetzt über den Mac reden, ne?
Ja, wir können uns auf alles einigen. Mir ist egal.
Dann lass uns doch noch gleich beim iOS bleiben, dann haben wir es hinter uns.
Das ist ein Hafen-Spinner.
Was ist denn da los, Tim? Was machst du noch im Chat?
Ach so, das ist wieder dieser Heini.
Der mal gekickt.
Muss man ignorieren.
Und dann tipp mal drauf. Und jetzt drehen.
Wo drauf tippen?
Einmal in die Mitte. Ja genau. Und dann kannst du auch das ganze Ding zur Seite sliden.
Also damit auch alle wissen, wovon wir reden, ich probiere gerade diesen Kompass aus. Ja, der sieht relativ schick aus.
Ja, und dann kannst du zur Seite sliden, dann gibt es auch noch die Wasserwaage in Schick.
Zur Seite sliden?
Ja, den Screen so.
Ja, so wie bei Vezar. Und du kannst den auch hinlegen und auch justieren, indem du noch einmal drauftappst wieder. Also, oder mach mal ein bisschen schräg, nee, mach mal schräg so ein bisschen. Noch mehr, mehr, mehr, sodass 5 Grad sind oder so. Und dann tapp mal drauf. Genau, jetzt lässt du los. Und dann kannst du sozusagen, falls du irgendwie, weißt schon, also mit klicken kann man den immer wieder auf Null stellen, egal in welcher Schräglage. Kalibrieren auch könnte man sagen. Und dass der Kompass jetzt auch, während du im Kompass-Modus bist, immer anzeigt, ob das Ding gerade liegt oder nicht.
Ja, das ist wirklich, das ist wirklich schick. Und dann muss ich auch sagen, das ist auch eine Richtung, die ich echt unterstützen kann, dass das einfach etwas technuierter wird an der Stelle. Wenn man nicht irgendwie versucht, irgendwelche Objekte, die man sowieso noch nie in der Hand gehabt hat, nachzubilden und die sich einfach als unpraktischer weisen. Hier wird einfach auch der Space genutzt, einfach ein intelligentes Interface. Ist geil.
Und sieht nicht mehr so aus wie so ein Ding auf dem Schiff. Ich meine, das war vorher auch okay, aber ich finde das alles ein bisschen moderner, so ein bisschen Space-Igualität finde ich irgendwie ganz cool.
Kann man jetzt ein bisschen ernster nehmen einfach?
Genau, muss man nicht mehr so neidisch auf die Android- und Windows-Telefone gucken. Fast.
Also hinten im letzten Screen sind meine ganzen Apple-Apps, die habe ich da irgendwie so nach, also die nicht auf dem Frontscreen oder auf dem ersten festgetackert sind, falls du noch mal die anderen Apple-Apps, iOS-Apps ausprobieren willst. Ja, also ich meine, ich habe es ja auch mir relativ schnell installiert, weil wir ja auch so einen Developer-Account und so weiter haben und ich muss sagen, dass bis auf die Eigens, finde ich eigentlich so diese Abkehr von diesem Geomorphismus und alles so technischer und sauberer und klarer, es ist halt unglaublich klar und crisp und alles so, ach, das fühlt sich schon toll an. Und ganz viele Sachen, die jetzt vielleicht nicht so wahnsinnig, also die weniger intuitiv vielleicht sind vom Interface her, wo man halt so wissen muss, ok, jetzt kannst du nach links swipen oder nach oben oder nach unten. Das fühlt sich aber auch dann, wenn man es einmal hat, gleich so viel besser und schneller an. Also, hat ja gleich geschrieben irgendwie auf Twitter, dass ich irgendwie mich gleich viel produktiver fühle und irgendwie, auch das Multitasking, alles ist irgendwie, ach, toller.
Und das Airplay geht jetzt nicht auch auf dein Bildschirm oder irgendwie so, weil Airplay geht doch jetzt hier auch. Warum geht das nicht?
Weil du wahrscheinlich in dem falschen WLAN drin bist. Bist du in dem Gast-WLAN?
Beschreibe geht nicht.
Der zeigt mir nur mein eigenes iPhone als Ziel an.
Ja, dann bist du in dem falschen WLAN.
Ja, und ich hatte auch so ein bisschen Sorgen, so am Anfang, weil dünne Schrift und alles so andere Farbgebungen so, hatte ich ja so ein bisschen Angst, dass so der Kontrast vielleicht einfach auch zu schlecht ist, um das so bei Tageslicht und so weiter zu lesen, aber im Praxisbetrieb... Im Praxisbetrieb habe ich das jetzt zumindest nicht so feststellen können, dass es da Kontrastprobleme gibt, trotz der dünnen Schrift.
Aber was mir noch oft passiert ist, dass ich am Anfang beim Anloggen wirklich in die falsche Richtung slide.
In die falsche Richtung slide?
Ja, weil da keine Richtung steht und es wird jetzt besser so mit der Zeit, aber manchmal komme ich noch durcheinander. Also irgendwas könnten sie da schon noch hin machen.
Aber was ich halt auch festgestellt habe, dieses Control Center, dieses Hochswipen und dann sofort Helligkeit einstellen, das ist halt auch so... Das war auch so ein Riesenstachel.
Control Center ist cool, oder?
Das ist göttlich. Warum sie das jetzt eingebaut haben.
Das hatten sie beim iPod 5. Generation, da hatten sie das irgendwie gut gelöst. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Naja, jetzt haben sie es, finde ich...
Blackmagic, wer ist denn Blackmagic?
Sie steht da oben drauf.
Die spielt bestimmt auch gerade ein Video ab, aber das ist halt nicht auf meinem Leben her. Was heißt lame? Wir benutzen ja hier gerade unseren Beamer für andere Sachen.
Verspruchs-Chat drauf, schreibt mal um.
Man sagt mir gerade bei Beta 2 wäre da ein Pfeil. Echt, da ist ein Pfeil? Bei mir ist da kein Pfeil.
Das unnötigste Feature in Anführungsstrichen ist dieser Parallaxe-Effekt. Den hätten sie sich einfach komplett klemmen können. Der bringt einfach nix.
Oder sie müssen ihn wirklich noch irgendwie sowas von schnell machen. Also, da ist so eine gewisse Latenz dazwischen und die sorgt dafür, dass man es nicht als echt empfindet. Also, wenn sie schon das Brain tricksen wollen, dann müssen sie sich schon ein bisschen, ja, schneller anstellen.
Ist das jetzt nur beim Bildschirm-Hintergrund?
Start-Screen. Die Icon. Also...
Da, wo die Icons sind, aber auch im Log-Screen. Homescreen und Log-Screen. Da, wo du Wallpapers setzen kannst. So, zack, jetzt haben wir's.
Ja, aber das bringt's halt nicht. Die Wetter-Up ist noch sehr, sehr schön geworden, muss man sagen. Allerdings hat's...
Hast du gesehen, als das Schlechtes war mit dem Blitzen? Vor allem kommen die relativ selten.
Aber sie haben halt immer noch Yahoo-Wetter und Yahoo-Wetter stinkt mal amtlich. Also, das ist wirklich eins der schlechtesten...
Wie die meisten Wetter.
Ja, also da muss ich mal einen kleinen Abtipp zwischendurch. Nach wie vor, Weather Pro ist echt die geilste Wetter. Ab und zu Sachen Wetterdaten.
Brauchen die nicht alle bei der gleichen Quelle?
Aber ich hatte das mehrfach, dass sie mir richtig Blitz und Donner und Hagel eingeseicht haben und ich saß in strahlender Sonne oder andersrum. Und zwar fürs aktuelle Wetter. Ich rede noch nicht mal von Wettervorhersage. Ich rede von aktuellem Wetter. Das heißt, das Wetter, das ihr gerade anzeigt, und das ist echt für'n Arsch.
Also ich benutze das seit sechs Jahren, ich bin Motorradfahrer, ich bin sehr angewiesen auf korrekte Regen, Niederschlagsvorhersagen und so weiter. Und mich hat das nie enttäuscht.
Was ich mache, ist, ich benutze den WeatherPro, gucke natürlich auf den Wetterradar und gucke, was da kommt. Klar, das ist okay, da kann man nichts sagen. Aber ihre Wettervorhersagen, bzw. die Wettervorhersagen für jetzt, sind in der Regel für'n Arsch.
Aber es ist immer noch besser als Jehu-Wetter.
Da ist ja auch gerade, guck dir erstmal einen Armi-Quatsch wieder an, um festzustellen, dass es eigentlich ganz schick ist. Berlin, Wisconsin oder so was aus, immer wieder gerne.
Ich wette, ich wette, Tim guckt jetzt den Kalender an. Vielleicht können wir damit seine müden Glieder wieder beleben. Zum Beispiel den Kalender, den finde ich so extrem schick geworden. Also ich meine, ich bin jetzt kein Kalender Pauli, sondern Tim findet wahrscheinlich gleich 1000 Makel da dran. Aber der sieht auch irgendwie sehr viel klarer.
Tim nimmt noch mal einen Schluck aus der Marte.
Und die Bildersortierung finde ich geil.
Das ist wirklich hilfreich.
Wenn er so Bilder zusammenfasst und so, das ist wirklich schick.
Der Kalender ist, ich meine, sie haben halt genau das umgesetzt, was ich hier jetzt jahrelang vor mich hingerentet habe. Das ist halt genau das, was ich meinte. Man kann halt jetzt mit der Geste durchgehen und es geht Woche für Woche durch und Zeit ist einfach mal kontinuierlich. So wie Zeit halt ist. Warum es jetzt so lange gedauert hat, bis ihr das dann auch mal...
Nein, Zeit kommt in Monatsquanten.
Na ja, sie mussten halt erstmal die ganzen Mobile-Max-Folgen übersetzen.
In Deutschland kommt übrigens Zeit in Kalenderwochenquanten.
Ja, Kalenderwochen zeigen sie noch nicht an, ne?
Ja, aber da gibt es geile Hacks. Bei uns in der Firma gibt es in der Google Group ein Wochennummernkalender, den man einblenden kann.
Ja, aber das verstehe ich nicht, warum sie sowas nicht einbauen können. Oder gibt es das?
Kalenderwochen sind schwierige Thema. Du weißt ja, dass Apple seit Jahren immer noch überhaupt mit dem Thema Datum und Zeit kämpft. Deswegen kriegen sie es ja jedes Jahr immer noch, hier backen und unten etwas einzubauen für den Sommerzeitwechsel oder so, unten kinken. Und Kalenderwochen werden ja in Amerika anders berechnet als bei uns. Ich weiß.
Aber anders berechnet, also die Woche fängt am Sonntag an?
Nee, die Definition ist auch eine andere. Bei uns ist glaube ich die offizielle Definition der... Danke. Der Kalenderwoche ist die erste Woche des Jahres, die ein Mittwoch enthält.
Ach.
Das überprüfe ich jetzt hier direkt mal.
Deswegen hasst ihr nämlich manchmal, dass zum Beispiel in manchen Jahren ist der 1. oder 2. Januar noch in der Kalenderwoche 52 oder 53 vom vorherigen Jahr.
Und der Mittwoch ist sozusagen der Tipping-Point.
Die erste Woche, die ein Mittwoch enthält, ist die erste Kalenderwoche. Und bei den Amis, die haben es ja wieder so, bei denen fängt ja die Woche auch am Sonntag an und so weiter und so fort, die haben eine andere Definition dafür.
Aber im Kalender-App auf dem Mac gibt es ja Kalenderwochen, die kann man ja einblenden. Und hast du da schon mal überprüft, ob die...
Nö, aber ich glaube schon, ein Thema, was wir bewerkstelligen, ist genauso wie das mit der Sommerzeit. Nur wie gesagt, Apple kriegt das alle Jahre immer wieder gebacken oder möglichen, andere Leute das kaputt zu machen. Ah, die Woche, die den ersten Donnerstag des Jahres enthält, sagt ISO. Okay, früher... Aber so, Pima Daum war, Mittwoch, Donnerstag...
Die erste Kalenderwoche ist diejenige, die mindestens vier Tage des neuen Jahres enthält. ISO 86.01.
Ach, gibt's auch noch 23.
Da steht jemand mit dem Donnerstag des Jahres.
Es gibt keine unvollständigen Kalenderwochen?
Mehr als vier oder mindestens vier.
Wochentage enthalten, ne?
Mindestens vier Tage des neuen Jahres.
Ja, dann muss ja ein Donnerstag drin sein.
Und es gibt keine unvollständigen Kalenderwochen. Also eine Kalenderwoche hat immer alle sieben Tage. Deswegen auch geht die vom alten Jahr noch ins neue Jahr rein, weil die auf jeden Fall voll sein muss.
Kalenderwochen sind eigentlich eine verdammt praktische Geschichte. Und ich finde, auch wenn es immer so ein bisschen das Gefühl hat von mittelständischer Betriebswirtschaft, ist es einfach mal praktisch, darüber auch seine Termine zu koordinieren. Ich hätte Zeit in KW23. Ich meine, das ist einfach mal eine klare Aussage.
Ja, was mich immer nervt, ist Leute, die nur so denken und glauben, alle Welt wüsste das. Wenn mir irgendwelche Leute sagen, wir liefern einen KW42, dann denkst du, ja, können wir das nochmal in anderen Zahlen ausdrücken oder so. Aber gut, jeder hat da sein.
Können Sie mir das bitte noch mal langsam sagen, ich habe ein iPhone? Ja, ich kann das nicht verstehen. Tja, naja, ganz schön hell, dieses iOS7.
Vielleicht gibt es ja auch den Apfel-Alt-Control-8-Shortcut irgendwo für den Inverted Mode. Ja, aber ich finde es wirklich, also ich war da auch sehr skeptisch erst und habe es jetzt aber benutzt. Also ich meine, die erste Beta, die war auch echt buggy. Da gab es ja auch echt viel Crashes, spontane Reboots und was nicht noch alles. Und jetzt mit der zweiten. Es ist doch um einiges benutzbarer schon geworden. Oh, die Voice-Memo hier auf der ersten Seite. Sie haben noch Voice-Memos wieder reingebaut. Die sieht auch so richtig, oh, technisch aus.
Die gab es in der ersten Beta gar nicht. Die ist jetzt wieder dazugekommen.
Aber ich habe es genau anders.
Ich hatte gar keine Abstürze mit der ersten Version und jetzt mit der zweiten Version stürzt ein Mail und da wird ab bei gewissen Spam-Mails, Crasheds, etc.
So ein bisschen wird jetzt doch wieder dieser Traum von diesem Trikorder wahr, dass es eben nicht alles so geomorphistische Flausch-Scheiße ist.
Was hältst du denn von dieser Sache mit den Buttons?
Mit den Buttons?
Na ja, es gibt keine mehr.
Also das ist definitiv noch ein bisschen problematisch. Zum Beispiel bei der Maps-App. Wenn du dich fragst, wo schalte ich jetzt den Modus um zwischen Karte und Satellitenfoto und so. I war jetzt total unintuitiv für mich.
Ja gut, aber das ist jetzt eine Änderung. Das hat ja mit der Optik jetzt nichts zu tun. Du meinst jetzt eher die Optik, oder Tim? Dass man Buttons nicht mehr so gut als solche erkennt.
Ja, man übersieht halt gerne mal Sachen auch. Also das, was du irgendwo mal... Nee, irgendjemand hat das gesagt. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wo das war. Aber irgendjemand meinte, dass so ein Button manchmal schon auch ganz praktisch ist, um da kurz und prägnant mit dem Icon oder was auch immer...
Auf irgendwas hinzuweisen, dass man da klicken kann.
Also was mir schon ein paar Mal passiert ist, ist tatsächlich, dass da so Text war und ich war mir nicht sicher, ob ich da draufdatschen kann oder nicht.
Ja, aber ich finde, das geht alles irgendwie. Ich hab jetzt noch nicht so wirklich Probleme gesehen. Aber dass so manche Sachen jetzt anders sind als vorher, klar. Aber hätten sie da richtige Buttons, dann wär es auch anders als vorher. Und dann müsste ich mich auch kurz umstellen.
Und was auch ein Ding ist, es wird echt lange dauern, wahrscheinlich bis alte deine Lieblings-Apps jetzt das neue...
sich angepasst haben werden.
Also so ein paar Apps, die hab ich jetzt auch schon runtergeschmissen, die sind einfach total kaputt jetzt. Also die kommen mit dem... was weiß ich, was die da für Frameworks benutzen, um ihre GUI zu rendern, aber da kleben die Buttons irgendwo im Nimmerleinsland oder sind so halb überdeckt von irgendwelchen anderen Flächen. Und in der Facebook-App ist das auch teilweise so, wenn da irgendwie... irgendwie kommen dann so komische halbtransparente schwarze Flächen dazwischen. Also ich fürchte ja, da müssen auch so die Drittparty-Entwickler nochmal ordentlich dann ihre Interfaces polieren, wenn sie noch ganz irgendwie antike Apis benutzen oder so. Das ist mir jetzt auf jeden Fall auch schon ein paar Mal passiert.
Aber so mit dieser Text-Link-Optik, also im Prinzip ist es ja alles so ein bisschen wie Webseiten, ne? Die Apps sehen irgendwie sehr viel mehr webseitig aus. Ich sag noch nicht mal, dass es unbedingt schlecht sein muss. Das ist halt vor allem anders, klar. Und man muss sich irgendwie dran gewöhnen. Und ich weiß nicht.
Wahrscheinlich muss man es einfach benutzen. Also ich bin mir jetzt schon ziemlich sicher, dass ich das jetzt schon besser finde als das Letzte. Also IOS 6. Von der Optik und vom ganzen Behavior irgendwie.
Wir haben nichts zu sagen zu IOS 7.
Doch, Safari ist geil.
Safari ist geil.
Flutscht. Flutscht schnell, sieht schick aus. Auch dieses leicht transparente, so ich finde es irgendwie ganz schick gemacht, es sieht aus wie so...
Multitasking, also das ist jetzt auch endlich mal irgendwie... Also ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt schon der letzte Stein der Weisen ist, aber es ist auch Dimensionen besser als vorher. Ja, hier Doppel, Doppel auf den Homebutton und dann... Achso.
Achso, hier bei dem Multitasking-Dings, also Doppel-Click, wo man da landet, da musst du dir erstmal überlegen, wie man dann Apps killt.
Ja, aber ich kam halt von alleine auch drauf, das war ganz geil.
Ich glaube, ich hab's irgendwo dann gesehen, aber sonst, ich weiß nicht. Und sag mal, hier mit diesen Apps, die sich Auto-updaten, da kommt dann so ein blaues Kügelchen davon, wenn man sie noch nicht gestartet hat, ne? Ja, damit man sie, also ich hab jetzt Auto-updaten nicht an, sondern ich klicks noch, aber wenn du so noch nicht gestartet hast, seitdem du sie abgedatet hast, kommt so ein blauer Kreis davor. Und was ich noch cool finde, ist jetzt an den Privacy-Features, die fragen jetzt auch, wenn ein Programm Zugriff aufs Mikrofon haben will.
Oder auf die Fotos.
Oder auf die Fotos oder auf Bluetooth, dann poppt auch so ein Request da auf und sagt hier, Mambel will zum Beispiel Zugriff auf den Mikrofon, willst du das? Und dann sagst du, äh, ne, die wollen mich ja nur belauschen.
Und was auch noch geht, oder was auch ist, wenn du das an einen fremden Rechner ransteckst mit einem Kabel, dann fragt er dich, ob du jetzt diesen Computer trusten willst. Und kannst dann sagen, don't trust, und dann gehen die ganzen Prozesse, die da irgendwelche Files gleich runterladen wollen oder was auch immer, die kriegen dann so, äh, äh, äh.
Wollen wir gleich mal testen, Hucki, schließ mal bei dir an.
Dann starte ich erstmal hier mein iPhone-Ripper.
Und was noch ist, habe ich gesehen hier dieses Activation-Log, was Apple ja gesagt hat, was irgendwie den Diebstahl verhindern soll.
Oder das heißt, den Diebstahl entwerten soll.
Ja, das habe ich auch mal eingeschaltet, aber ich habe keine Ahnung, weil Hucki hat mir ja meins ja noch nicht geklaut bisher. Das heißt, du klaust mir mein Phone, schließt es bei dir an, dann wird mein Phone schon mal geladen und jetzt, was passiert noch?
Mach mal jetzt irgendwie das Leiter-Ein-Log. Irgendwie müsste ich jetzt gleich fragen, ob du...
Ja, trust the currently connected computer, trust this computer to load full access to your device and all of its data. So, und was heißt das jetzt für dich? Du kannst mit deinem Xcode, iTunes und wie nicht zugreifen.
So, jetzt mache ich Image-Capture auf und sehe aber deinen Film-Modus. Aber die Frage ist, ob ich sie runterladen kann.
Ja, du siehst sie ja schon.
Ja, genau, es funktioniert also nicht so richtig. Schade.
Das ist ja unglaublich.
Tim, was hast du noch für Erkenntnisse dabei?
Ich glaube, die Frage ist ja auch, will you trust this Computer? Ja, nee, dann ist es noch nicht fertig. Das ist ja mal ein Sicherheitsfeature.
Also ich kann nur mit allgemeinen Bedenken kommen. Ich habe so ein bisschen Angst, dass die, oder ich frage mich, sagen wir es mal so, Angst ist immer eigentlich der falsche Weg. Ich frage mich, wie werden sich künftig die Anwendungen voneinander unterscheiden optisch? Also ich habe es ein paar Mal gestartet, aber so diese tabularische, textuelle Anzeige von den Contacts, vergleicht zu wie es vorher war. Also ich muss viel mehr lesen.
Woher wird man noch das Beispiel?
Ja, da hast du immer so, was es ist, wert, was es ist, wär's. Also eine einzige Textwüste, die keinerlei Struktur hat. Du musst irgendwie das von oben nach unten durchlesen und du hast immer nur blau-schwarz, blau-schwarz, blau-schwarz, blau-schwarz.
Du hast so ein iPhone, dann die Spielzahl, dann irgendwie Facetime, dann die Symbole dahinter, dann Home, die Adresse. Also ist doch, wie sah es denn vorher aus?
Ja, lesen, genau.
Und vorher hast du was gemacht?
Du hast eine klare Gruppierung gehabt.
Du hast diese grafischen Einfassungen, auf die sie jetzt so bewusst verzichten. Jetzt ist immer alles so auf weißem Papier gedruckt und scrollt irgendwie so hintereinander weg. Und die Buttons und alles, was auch einrabt, ist auch alles Text, Text, Text, Text, Text. Das heißt, du schaust drauf und so eine Anwendung, die irgendwie Notizen macht und so weiter, wenn sie diesem Schema folgt, ist halt einfach extrem textlastig. Und ich frage mich halt, wie dann noch die Unterscheidung sein soll und wie dein Auge schnell geführt wird zu diesen Informationen. Das ist ein offenes Rennen, keine Ahnung. Also mir zeichnen die sich das zumindest noch nicht klar ab, wie das sein wird. Vielleicht kommen wir jetzt auch weg von diesem, ich meine, was ist, wenn wir wegkommen von diesem verspielten Ich bin ein Gerät-Ding, was bisher ja eigentlich mal alles definiert hat. Taschenrechner von anderen Firmen, Kalkbot und wie sie alle heißen, die irgendwie auch so einen Spaß zum Ausdruck gebracht haben, ich erfinde jetzt hier so eine Maschine, ich bin hier seine Rechenmaschine und so sehe ich halt aus.
Das können andere Apps immer noch weitermachen. Ist eigentlich fast auch gut, dann kann man zwischen Original-Software und Third-Party unterscheiden. Naja, die Apple will sich ja auch absetzen, oder?
Naja, ich glaube, Apple hat eher ein Interesse an einer homogenen Experience.
Ja, das Ding ist nämlich schon, dass Apps, die sehr stark auf 3D-Effekte gesetzt haben, wenn du dann so ein bisschen Safari brauchst, ein bisschen Mail, ein bisschen was auch immer, und dann gehst du in so eine App, die so richtig Bevel, Schlagschatten benutzt, dann sieht das erstmal komplett fremd aus. Das muss man schon sagen.
Gab's in dem iOS 6 auch einen Maps-Fullscreen-Modus?
Maps-Fullscreen-Modus?
Wenn du jetzt einmal so drauf tappst, kriegst du die Maps in Fullscreen.
Glaube nicht, nee.
Warte mal, ich...
Man vergisst ja so schnell, ne? Einmal drauf tappen. Nee, da oben dieser Chrome, der bleibt immer da.
Nee, hier kannst du den Eilball klicken und an- und abschalten.
Guck hier so.
Ist eigentlich auch ganz cool.
So ein bisschen wie es schon immer mit dem Videoplayer war, ne? Ja, das finde ich eigentlich auch in Ordnung, das kann man machen. Weil dadurch nutzt man natürlich auch den zur Verfügung stehenden Screenestate viel besser.
Ja, könnten sie eigentlich für alle möglichen Sachen machen.
Ja, Fullscreen-Modus.
So, jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt. Ich logge mich ein.
Oh, in deinen replizierten Mac.
In meinen replizierten Mac logge ich mich jetzt gerade ein. Genau. Themenwechsel.
Loggst dich schon am Bahnhof ein.
Ich werde gleich mal unser Passwort von mir haben. Wieso? Will alle möglichen Passworte von mir haben.
Erstmal mit der iCloud synchronisieren. Also der Dennis Vader und dein Rechner, der pfeift hier. Was macht denn der?
Der rechnet.
Leg was runter, dann sparst du doch ein paar hundert Umdrehungen.
Was rechnet der denn? Der rechnet was. Der muss ja ein bisschen Grafikprozessor rechnen. Nee, die schmilzt weg. Gib mir was anderes.
Die ist schon geschmolzen.
So kann ich nicht arbeiten. Ich brauch was rechts und links. Gib mir was für beide Seiten.
Nee, einfach nur so hinten drunter, damit die Lüfterritze ein bisschen höher ist. Ja, wenn die sozusagen ihren Auspuff bei diesem MacBook Pro mal ein bisschen besser designt hätten, dann wäre der echt kühler, der Rechner. Da durchmerkt man das. Wenn man den leicht anhebt, ist der schon echt...
Kommen wir zum Thema MacBook Pro? Ich hab so das Gefühl, wir können halt irgendwie gar nicht so richtig erzählen irgendwas. Wir sind doch so geschockt und so informationsfrei.
Lala, Beta.
Ja, erstmal so die ersten Beschnupperungen halt, ne? Also Dennis und ich finden es toll.
Ich find es eigentlich erfrischend neu, dass die eigentlich nicht schick sind, mag sein, aber ehrlich gesagt interessieren mich die alten Scheiß. Das ist ja kein Feature, kein Anti-Feature. Das ist ja nur so ein Mini-Teil der Optik. Ja, aber mal ehrlich, mit dem neuen Design würden die alten Eigens jetzt auch nicht wirklich passen. Mag ja sein, dass das Safari eigentlich noch so ein bisschen unfertig aussieht. Kann sein. Sind wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht mehr glücklich, dass sie mal den Compass für ihr Safari-Dings genommen haben. Wahrscheinlich sind die da drinnen auch kräftig am diskutieren, was sie da nun machen. Ich glaube, sie hätten gerne was anderes, aber es ist nun mal ein bisschen spät. Aber ich finde an sich hier, also gerade wenn man hier die Settings aufmacht, wo alles schon so schick, wohlsortiert und modern ist, ich finde das schon sehr angenehm.
So, Tim hat hingegen noch allgemeine Bedenken. Kann sie aber noch nicht präziser formulieren. Nee, kann ich nicht. Dann sind wir durch mit iOS.
Mir ist das Netzwerk immer noch nicht funktioniert.
Und man kann jetzt bei jeder.
Ich finde es eigentlich ganz okay. Aber ich warte sowieso mit dem ganzen iOS-Quack. Ich bin eher gespannt auf eine neue Hardware, nämlich ein iPhone 5S. Ob sie da gebacken kriegen, ihr Netzwerk auch physikalisch in Ordnung zu bringen, sodass man hier auch mal LTE benutzen kann in Deutschland. Und nicht auf dem Schummelnetz von der Telekom, sondern halt überall so fertig.
Also ich hab LTE, das ist super. Ich als Telekom-Opfer muss mich ja auch mal freuen.
Ja, ist ja okay. Und dann in dem Zusammenhang, da hätte ich jetzt auch mal mehr Lust, ein bisschen drüber zu spekulieren, als jetzt iOS mit und ohne Rahmen um die Buttons und so. Dazu ist jetzt einfach schon alles gesagt, finde ich.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Man kann jetzt auch pro App einstellen, ob die Roaming-Data benutzen oder nicht. Also irgendwelche Programme im Hintergrund halt immer die ganze Zeit Zeug ziehen. Weil das können die ja jetzt. Kannst du sagen, ja hier Amazon und eBay und Shit und so. Du willst nicht, dass die, wenn dein Telefon aus ist, dass die da weiter Daten ziehen können. Du kannst das abschalten. Nein, aber für einzelne Apps. Ich weiß nicht, wo das war. Weil es sind jetzt so viele Einstellungen, dass die alle so ein bisschen untergehen. Ich glaube bei Cellular und dann bei... Ja doch, hier bei Settings und dann Cellular. Und dann use Cellular Data 4. Und dann kannst du ja die ganze...
Jetzt gibt es noch einen Bereich, über den wir etwas signieren können, den ich nämlich sehr interessant fand, der sich ja zwar in der Keynote auch schon abgezeichnet hat, aber wo man auch erstmal ein bisschen drüber nachdenken muss. Sie haben ja dieses Multitasking für Apps auf iOS signifikant enhanced. Jetzt, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, kann man halt jetzt... Gibt es diese alte Unterscheidung nicht mehr, mit du musst eine App sein, die dieses oder jenes oder sonstiges tut, um im Background zu sein? Ich weiß nicht, ich hab davon nichts gehört.
In der Developer-Ding an ist so, du kannst es dir im Xcode schon einzeln einschalten, was dein App irgendwie machen will im Hintergrund oder so. Weil die im Xcode haben dir ja so viel vereinfacht, kannst du da klicken, was du gerne hättest. Und deswegen gibt es ja auch dieses neue, dass das OS für dich Sachen im Hintergrund zu Ende lädt. Du kannst also als Programm sagen, hier, ich lad grad voll, oder lad du mal als OS für mich Folgendes runter. Ich kann mich dann schon mal ausmachen. Und das Telefon kann so Push-Notification-mäßig kann das Ding in Ruhe zu Ende runterladen, wenn es da ist. Und das Programm wird beim nächsten Mal wieder gestartet. Oder es wird gestartet, wenn es da ist, weiß nicht, wie es genau läuft. Dann macht das Programm weiter. Das heißt, die Programme können ihr Download von Sachen outsourcen.
Also ich hab so verstanden, dass du jetzt direkt selber auf die Push-Notification selbst reagieren kannst mit deinem eigenen Code. Aber du nicht unter Umständen sofort in dem Moment, wo die Push-Notification kommt, aufgerufen wirst, sondern wenn das OS halt der Meinung ist, dass jetzt der richtige Moment wäre. Nämlich zum Beispiel, wenn der User ohnehin schon das Teil in die Hand nimmt und gerade benutzt, Unlock macht, irgendwas startet und so. Und quasi ohnehin die CPU-Maschine angeworfen wurde, um nicht jetzt mit jeder Notification gleich in so ein, ich verbrauche mal, stromlos zu ran.
Wenn es nur eine Nachricht ist, die dem User angezeigt werden soll, also zum Beispiel da ist eine neue Nachricht für, dann muss er ja irgendwas anzeigen. Auch wenn die App noch nicht läuft oder der User sein Telefon noch nicht in der Hand hat. Ist auch ein bisschen kompliziert. Es gibt ja tausend verschiedene Push-Notifications, aber was ich eigentlich meinte, sind ja, wenn das Programm das runterladen wird, es hat ja mit Push-Notification erstmal noch nichts zu tun.
Sagen wir Podcast Client. Da kommt halt die Push-Notification. Das neue Mobile Max 113 ist jetzt verfügbar. Aber du musst das halt bisher dann eben auch die zugehörige App starten oder diese Notification auswählen, damit diese App auch in den Vordergrund kommt. Und dann durfte sie halt anfangen, das runterzuladen. Und dann durfte sie halt auch im Hintergrund sein. Ab dann. Weil wenn sie dann sofort wieder beendet, darf ja der Download-Prozess im Hintergrund weiterlaufen, bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt. Und jetzt sieht es für mich eher so aus, als ob quasi mehr oder weniger sofort, nachdem die Push-Notification kommt, dieser Download-Prozess auch gestartet werden darf. Aber halt nicht unbedingt jetzt immer garantiert sofort, sondern wenn das OS der Meinung ist, jetzt wäre es halt mal Zeit dafür.
Ja, es hört sich alles ganz gut an. Da muss man mal aufpassen, dass die bei Apple nicht so eine Art Interface-Monopol kriegen, dass alle Programme nur noch über Push-Notifications irgendwie mit der Außenwelt reden. Sondern ich hätte gern auch ein bisschen, wenn es dann alles so easy und entspannt ist, dass die Programme vielleicht dann doch wieder selbst irgendwie per IP mit der Außenwelt kommunizieren und es nicht alles über Apples Server geht.
Also, like new multitasking APIs to keep content and apps up to date. Tja, so richtig genau auf der Webleite. Ich guck grad nochmal, ob da irgendwo jetzt mal noch ein bisschen mehr zu den Multitasking steht, aber...
Möchtest du natürlich mal Brownies?
Mit oder ohne?
Ohne.
Also...
Gib mal eher die Tüte.
Ich denk, die dürften auch okay sein.
Von wann sind die denn?
Ich hab ja mal wieder aufgeräumt.
Jetzt trau ich mich nicht.
Gib her.
Jetzt wollt ich euch den Vorzug lassen.
Von wann sind die denn?
Von... Weiß ich nicht mehr so genau. Zwei Wochen.
Zwei Wochen.
Eine Woche. Ähm, ich pack den mal dann mit meinem Rechner. Na ja, gut. Hier gibt's noch eine andere Geschenkelieferung. Auch noch mal hier kurz anbringen.
Hier.
Guck mal, hier gibt's Geschenke. Hallo zusammen, für jeden ein Codequartett.
Welche Zahl bin ich denn hier?
Wurde gerade erfolgreich ge-crowdfunded. Wer will ein Codequartett haben?
Das wurde ge-crowdfunded.
Ja, das wurde ge-crowdfunded.
Hier find ich den Eject-Button oben auf der Öffnungsklappe. Das hat schonmal was.
Genau.
Was macht denn dieses Codequartett?
Du musstest Eject um.
Na ja, war schon ein Schritt weiter.
Alle Datengrafik-Texte sind open source und auf www.zuplanus.de zu finden. Und hier steht noch irgendwas für dich, Clemens. Das verstehe ich aber nicht. Du solltest Netzwerkeinstellungen checken. Ich weiß aber nicht, wo man bei einem Quartett Netzwerkeinstellungen. Was haben wir denn schönes hier im Codequartett?
Was ist denn besser bei Hello World Lengths? Muss ja besonders kurz sein, damit man gewinnt, würde ich mal sagen, oder?
Das kann man so sehen, ja.
Alang ist hier schon mal bei 35 bei Hello World.
Ich check ja gerne mal Netzwerkeinstellungen, aber... Ich hatte jetzt in den letzten Tagen mit so richtig kaputten Typen zu tun. So Windows-User. Das Netz geht nicht. Ja, gut. Pink geht gar nicht. Dann machen sie mal die Firewall aus, fragt er mich, welche. Ja, hat er auch. Auf dem Rechner, auf dem Router? Nein, der Router war ja meiner. Aber ich musste versehentlich einen Windows-User in eins meiner Netze lassen. Und dann hat er Romifo mit seinem McAfee abgewirkt und seine Windows-Firewall und seine Lade. So viel zum Thema Netzwerkeinstellung checken.
Robi hat 19 bei Hello World, das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal ganz weit vorne.
Das ist ein bisschen Hello World fixiert.
Mir fehlen hier sozusagen noch die grundlegenden Kategorien der Sprachen. Also mal wieder so ein Dynamic Object Functional, Side Effect Free, oder?
Aber was ist da besser?
Multitasking, das kann man ja dann definieren, wie man das spielen will. Wenn das halt so Visual Basic Leute sind, die spielen das dann halt so, dass das schlecht ist. Und für die anderen spielt es halt so, dass es gut ist. Da kann ja auch Unleserlichkeit zum Beispiel fehlen, mir hier auch so ein bisschen.
Wie viele Wege gibt es, das Problem zu lösen?
Genau, ist der More One Way to the Way.
Was gibt es noch?
Das wären interessante Sachen. Oder auch die Readability, also die Lesbarkeit des Codes.
Wobei das natürlich jetzt auch schon...
Ja gut, aber mit sowas wie Brainfuck und Whitespace hast du auf jeden Fall einen niedrigen Score. Und ich würde sagen, umso weniger... Also so Kobol steht da durchaus vorn.
Ja, oder dann auch so ist es eine Multiparadigmensprache oder sind sie straight, ja.
Genau, so würde ich das machen. Trotzdem schönes Ding hier.
Diskussion im Isolaire 9 oder 10.
Wir bedanken uns auch, wenn wir an allem was rumzumeckern haben.
Ja, wir danken uns artig.
Also sagen wir mal so, ich würde es lieber haben als einen iMac. Also ich bin...
Warum?
Ich weiß nicht, aber ich mag dieses alles in einer Kiste-Konzept irgendwie... Für einen desktop-Rechner. Nee, aber so dieses Display separat und so. Weiß nicht, also irgendwie...
Man kauft den Mac mini.
Irgendwie finde ich das schon schöner, mit so einem Mac pro. Und ich hätte schon gern... Also, naja... Ich überleg schon die ganze Zeit, ob ich sowas eigentlich wirklich brauchen würde. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Eigentlich wäre so ein Mac mini wahrscheinlich vollkommen ausreichend. Ich meine, das Einzige, was ich wirklich brauche, wo ich ordentlich Rechenbums brauche, ist halt Video und Audio. Und das mach ich jetzt auch nicht so viel, dass es jetzt wirklich schmerzt.
So ein Mac mini hat durchaus Bums. Wenn man ihn IO-mäßig mal ein bisschen entlastet, oder eben was ordentliches zum IO gibt, das Problem, wie gesagt, weil die Dinge immer früher hatten, ist, dass Apple da so eine Gurkenplatte eingebaut hat.
Ja, ich weiß schon. Aber bei Videorändern und Audiorändern, da brauchst du halt auch richtig Dampf auf dem Prozessor. Was hat der jetzt nochmal?
Naja, es wird ja mehrere geben. Aber sie meinen, der dickste soll 12 haben.
Ja, aber es gibt nur noch einen. Und das ist halt jetzt diese nächste Generation von Intel-Schwergewichten mit irgendeinem Codenamen, den ich nicht kenne.
Gibt's ja auch noch nicht.
Und der wird da rauskommen. Nur das Ding ist, dass eigentlich die CPU, also der Mac Pro ist eigentlich der erste Computer, wo die CPU eigentlich nebensache ist.
Naja, der Data, also was natürlich schon extrem krass ist, auch die IO.,
Nee, was extrem krass ist, ist die GPU. Also erstmal, das Ding kommt serienmäßig mit zwei GPUs. Und das Ding ist ja im Prinzip dreieckig. Also er hat zwar aus und eine runde Hülle, aber im Wesentlichen ist der Computer dreieckig. Und die eine Seite ist CPU und die anderen beiden Seiten sind GPU. So, das ist die Aufteilung und so ist es da irgendwie auch rechenpowertechnisch verteilt. Also diese GPU nimmt irgendwie gefühlt zwei Drittel dieses Rechners ein, aber auch ganz praktisch. Und nur eine von diesen GPUs ist überhaupt an die Bildschirme angeschlossen. Also um die GPU als Bildschirmtreiber zu nutzen, kannst du sowieso nur die eine von den beiden verwenden. Also zumindest so in der klassischen Konstellation, dass die halt so Pins zugeführt bekommt und da sind dann so Bildschirme dran. Und diese eine kann halt vier, ne, was war das, drei, dreimal 4000er Bildschirme, also so 4K-Displays, die Apple leider nicht gleich mit angekündigt hat?
Treiben.
Und dann hast du noch so ein Teil. Und jede von diesen GPUs hat 6 GB RAM. Jede von den beiden. 12 GB RAM, nur Videospieler. Das muss man sich mal klar machen. Das ist einfach eine Höllenmaschine. Aber eben für Software, die von GPUs was rauskitzeln kann. Das Ding ist jetzt nicht langsam mit seinen 12-Core-Neustar-Intel-Tralala-Hass nicht gesehen. Aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass sie sagen, so viel CPU wie irgendwie geht. Weil die eigentliche Anforderung für den Mac Pro ist, ob sie wirklich viel Crunching machen. Also entweder Numerical-Crunching machen oder Video-Audio-Crunching machen. Und ich meine, dafür werden die Dinge auch benutzt.
Aber macht zum Beispiel Audio, macht doch keiner auf der Grafikkarte.
Naja, na doch.
Noch nicht.
Also ich hab da jetzt keinen wirklichen Einblick, wie gerade so die Plugins alle so programmiert sind. Aber die Performance, die die brauchen, das ist ja parallel processing. Das ist ja eine klassische Anforderung von solchen Plugins. Und darum geht's, dass du da dein Logic da drauf schmeißt und dann hast du da irgendwie deine zehn Spuren und auf jeder dieser Spuren fährt halt eine Myriade von mega komplexen Röhren, Verstärker, Simulationskompressor, hast du nicht gesehen, irgendwie Schimmer, Echo, Hall, Entferner, Polierer, Plugins drauf und die fressen halt die CPU-Leistungen bisher bzw. sollen halt in Zukunft oder ich vermute mal, dass es teilweise auch jetzt schon so ist, dass eben solche Teile mit OpenCL programmiert werden und jetzt sollen sie halt das machen. Und deswegen wollte ich da auch nochmal darauf zu sprechen kommen, weil dieser Mac Pro ist in gewisser Hinsicht ein Software-Paradigmenwechsel. Sie bauen eine Maschine, die nicht unbedingt für die Software gebaut ist, wie sie bisher vor allem verwendet wird oder produziert wird. Sondern sie bauen jetzt eigentlich einen Rechner für Software, wie Software zu sein hat. Sie sagen einfach, du willst Performance aus dieser Kiste haben für Multimedia-Bearbeitungen in irgendeiner Form? Bitte schön. Haben wir richtig viel. Weil was da aus diesen GPUs rausfällt an theoretischer Computing-Performance, wir haben auch mal eine Zahl gesagt, wie viele Teraflops waren, dass die da irgendwie rausgeschissen kommen, da ist irgendwie eine Menge zu holen. Und die eine GPU ist einfach nur da, um genau so was zu machen.
Sieben Teraflops. Mehr als doppelt so viel, als wie der alte Mikrofon.
Aber ich finde, die haben schon einen kleinen Designfehler. Ist mir gerade mal so aufgefallen. Und zwar wenn du sagst, dass sie ja, die haben halt die CPU, dann haben sie die eine Grafikkarte, die immer Full-Action macht, also die auf jeden Fall auch warm wird, weil sie die Bildschirme anspeist. Das heißt, es könnte sein, dass die zweite GPU gerade mal nichts macht, weil gerade mal kein OpenCL benutzt wird, richtig? Das ist aber so, dass dieser Kühlkörper, wenn man sich den anguckt bei Apple von oben, dass der ist ja auch ein Dreieck und der hat innen drin auch noch so Streben. Und die gehen von beiden Grafikkarten so gerade runter zur CPU. Das heißt, die CPU kann die Wärme zu den Grafikkarten schicken und die Grafikkarten könnten ihre Wärme in Richtung CPU schicken. Weil wir haben ja gesagt, wenn eins nicht benutzt wird, dann verteilt sich das dort so mit der Wärme. Wenn man aber jetzt ausgeht, dass gerade diese eine CPU nicht so doll benutzt wird, dann kann die CPU dahin zwar ein bisschen abgeben, die andere Grafikkarte aber eher nicht. Das heißt, sie hätten die Quelle, die zu den beiden anderen geht, hätte die freie GPU sein müssen, die am wenigsten höchstwahrscheinlich zu tun hat. Oder sie haben da bessere Tests als ich, als ich mir das jetzt so denke und haben das ein bisschen besser.
Ich weiß, was du meinst, ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob das wirklich vollkommen ausgeschlossen ist, dass diese GPUs so zusammengeschaltet sind, dass sie irgendwie ohnehin weitgehend wie eine rüberkommen.
Ja, also am Ende ist das ja alles bekannte Technik. Hat ja jeder PC, der ein bisschen besser irgendwie am Zocken ist, der holt sich zwei AMD oder zwei Nvidia Grafikkarten, macht da bei AMD heißt es Crossfire, so einen Link hab ich zuhause auch. Ich hab zuhause drei dicke Karten, alle drei zusammengesteckt, kannst du Crysis spielen und flutscht. Das gleiche geht bei Nvidia auch. Bei denen heißt es glaube ich SLI oder sowas. Und das haben, also das machen die Hardcore-Gamer oder die Leute, die meinen, sie brauchen zwei Grafikkarten, machen das schon seit ewig. Also das ist alles überhaupt gar nichts Neues. Was man beim Zocken aber hat, sind sogenannte Mikroruckler. Das heißt, du hast zwar deine 60, 80 oder 100 Frames zur Not bei irgendwelchen Spielen, aber da trotzdem die beiden Grafikkarten sich minimal sinken müssen, hast du so eine... Ab und zu mal so ganz kurz so einen Ruck drin. Du kannst es nicht genau beschreiben, aber es ist irgendwie da und das nervt so ein bisschen. Deswegen eigentlich, wenn man weiß, eine Grafikkarte reicht, nimmt man lieber nur eine anstatt zwei. Aber man muss schon sagen, dass zwei wirklich... Also dann rockt so ein Spiel, weil dann ist egal, was du da an High Definition oder sonst wie für Quality einstellst, es flutscht einfach. Und ich denke mal, dass Apple da auch nichts weiter macht, außer dass die beiden Grafikkarten schon dauer-crossfired sind, also zusammenarbeiten. Weil bisher gab es bei Apple nicht diesen Treiber dafür. Und dass die mal mit AMD sich zusammengetan haben, und Apple hat gesagt, wir wollen ja auch einen Treiber, der das so kann und der das schön aufteilt und macht mal. Und wahrscheinlich hat Apple, weil die ja das Open-Cell auch sehr doll pushen, weil es war ja auf deren Initiative, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, alles, haben die sich wahrscheinlich ihren Treiber auch so gemacht, dass das automatisch schön auf beide Grafikraten aufteilt, so wie sich das gehört.
Das denke ich auch.
Ja, aber bist du sicher, dass wirklich schon so viel, klar gibt es da so ein paar Photoshop-Plugins, die jetzt Open-CL wollen und sowas.
Aber ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt...
Nach Final Cut Pro.
Aber das ist noch ein bisschen wenig für die paar Anwender da, oder? Das muss ja reichlich mehr werden, damit sich das wirklich auch für irgendwelche Normalos lohnen sollte.
Normalos?
Normalos, die noch so einen Rechner haben wollen. Weil natürlich gibt es auch Normalos, die sich so einen Rechner kaufen. Leute, die halt was Dickes, Ordentliches, Fettes zum Zocken, zum was auch immer haben möchten.
Ist glaube ich nicht ihre Zielgruppe zum Zocken. Ganz ehrlich, also der Mac Pro heißt nicht ohne Grund so.
Du meinst also, dass das wirklich ein Rechner für Pros ist?
Ja klar, das ist was für Leute, die machen Audio und die machen Video oder die machen Photoshop in Dimensionen, wie wir uns das nicht vorstellen können. Ich meine die Bilddatenmengen, die da bearbeitet werden, die sind enorm und du brauchst halt einfach enorm Power, vor allem damit du deine ganzen Effekte, also Photoshop, ich meine früher, da hat man dann, weißt du, das eine Plugin angewendet, das nächste Plugin angewendet, das nächste Plugin angewendet, das waren immer so sequentielle Sachen. Heutzutage möchtest du aber eher das alles in Layern haben und jedes Plugin, jeder, also wenn dir das quasi wie, das was hintereinander stattgefunden hat, findet jetzt quasi übereinander statt. Und du möchtest halt immer alles wieder parametrisieren, das heißt du hast geradezu die Erwartung, dass möglichst alle Plugins in Realtime arbeiten und das auf verdammt großen Bildern. Du lädst da irgendwie so ein RAW runter und du willst dann auf diesem RAW, wir erinnern uns RAW, um da überhaupt mit arbeiten zu können, musste man konvertieren und so weiter, um überhaupt was damit machen zu können. Und jetzt möchtest du aber eigentlich auf dem RAW arbeiten und dann da drauf alle möglichen Plugins haben und die Computing-Anforderungen dafür sind enorm. Also du musst da einfach enormen Datendurchsatz haben und du musst einen enormen Computing-Power zum Einsatz bringen.
Also du meinst, wir können jetzt so festhalten, dass es für Normalos, die keinen Final Cut oder Photoshop benutzen, sich die zweite GPU da schon so gar nicht wirklich lohnt?
Ich weiß nicht, was du mit Normalos meinst. Sowas wie mich?
Na sagen wir mal, sowas wie mich und Hucke. Wir beide sagen ja auch schon, wir hatten gerne auch so eine Kiste, aber wir sind jetzt keine Final Cut oder Photoshop-Nutzer.
Na gut, bei Hucke spielt Audio schon eine Rolle, ja?
Final Cut, also ja, aber ich meine, so wie ich das jetzt ja sehe, ist meine CPU da vor allen Dingen am Anschlag, wenn ich irgendwas mit...
Also jetzt zum Beispiel meine Software, die nicht eine halbe Stunde braucht, um einen Podcast raus zu rendern, oder das Ding schon gerendert.
Aber ich meine, das liegt ja auch vor allen Dingen an dieser speziellen Software, also es gibt ja andere Audio-Software, die auf deiner Hardware im Zehntel der Zeit das Audio rausrendert. So ist es ja auch nicht. Und ich weiß nicht, ich kenne halt, also jetzt wenn ich so drüber nachdenke, welche Software benutzt denn OpenCL? Also mir fällt da jetzt auf jeden Fall nicht so wahnsinnig viel ein. Ich hab grad mal geguckt, ob du in der Wikipedia oder irgendwie mal was findet, welche Apps so OpenCL supporten, ob es irgendwie Audio mit OpenCL gibt, und ich finde da jetzt erstmal so spontan nichts. Aber da können ja vielleicht in den Kommentaren mal so ein paar Leute, die vielleicht da besser Bescheid wissen, mal ein paar Tipps hinterlassen, welche Apps denn von sowas überhaupt profitieren würden.
Aber nochmal zu diesem Paradigmenwechsel. Weil den vollziehen sie ja einerseits jetzt in der Hardware intern, aber auch in der Hardware extern. Denn nun kann man keine PCI-Karten mehr mal reinstecken. Jetzt gehören auch PCI-Karten auf einmal wieder zu dieser Kategorie von Technologie, wo man sich denkt so, ah, Dinosaurier, wer will denn das noch haben und so weiter. Naja, ich meine, zugegeben, eine PCI-Karte in einen Computer reinstecken oder überhaupt eine Erweiterungskarte in einen Computer reinstecken, das war noch nie eine Freude. Ja, finde ich. Also ich hab diese blöde USB-3-Karte, die immer noch nicht funktioniert, die du mir irgendwie aufgeschwatzt hast, irgendwie in diesen Rechner reinschraubt. Da musst du Deckel aufmachen, Schrauben lösen und das ist bei MacPro schon echt einfach. Ja, aber die musst du auch irgendwie erstmal rankommen und dann spannt da diese Grafikkarte darunter und dann musst du einen Platz finden und diesen Teil da richtig reinstecken. Klar, das geht alles irgendwie, aber das sind nicht mehr die alten Zeiten, wo du noch IRQ-Jumpern musstest und so. Aber es ist einfach ein tedious Vorgang und von daher kann ich durchaus verstehen, dass da irgendwie Leute keinen Bock drauf haben. Jetzt hast du natürlich eine ganze Menge solcher Technik da draußen.
Du kannst schon noch das Leben von deinem Rechner mit eine Weile erweitern.
Ja, genau. Na gut, ich meine, das kannst du mit einem externen Teil, was genauso performant dranhängt, noch sehr viel einfacher tun.
Ja, aber eine Karte drin zu haben und dein Rechner bleibt von außen eigentlich genauso eine Blackbox wie vorher und aber so ein rundes Ding zu haben, wo jetzt irgendwie schon ein Kabel mit, sagen wir einfach mal wieder USB 3, weil in der Zukunft wird es dann USB 4 sein irgendwann, mit so einem Ding dranhängt und dann noch ein anderes Kabel, wo noch irgendwie was anderes dranhängt. Also irgendwann ist es halt ein bisschen blöd. Und ich würde mir eigentlich schon auch denken, dass manche Power-User so ein Mac Pro mit dem Alugehäuse, ob es so ein schickes oder nicht, aber weißt du, das kannst du so an beiden Griffen hochnehmen, kannst du mal irgendwo hinschleppen, auch irgendwo hinstellen, auf eine Veranstaltung zum Beispiel, im Kongress standen da irgendwie vier, fünf Stück rum. Stell dir vor, da würden so runde Dinger mit irgendwelchen Kabeln hinten dran rumliegen. Okay, man braucht zum Surfen keine runden Dinger und keine Kabel.
Ja, war jetzt vielleicht nicht das beste Beispiel. Ich bin ja ganz auf deiner Seite. Ich wollte ja eigentlich auch genau auf dieses Problem ansprechen. Also ich denke, das wird sich irgendwann lösen. Weil jetzt heißt ja die Lösung eigentlich, die Web-Performance, Audio-Capture und Video-Capture findet in externen Geräten statt. Und diese Recheneinheit, Mac Pro, und nichts anderes ist das Ding. Das Ding ist im Prinzip nichts anderes als Computing. Da ist nichts anderes drin als Computing. Da ist keine Festplatten drin. Also klar, da ist so ein bisschen SSD drin, aber du kannst halt keine Festplatten reinschrauben. Da sind keine Laufwerke mehr in irgendeiner Form, kein CD, kein DVD, nichts dergleichen. Keine PCI-Karten, keine Capture-Karten, keine Ausgabe-Eingabekarten, nichts. Kannst du da reintun.
Hat das Ding eigentlich einen Lautsprecher? Der sagt ja auch hier extern.
Das haben sie ja mit dem Cube schon mal gemacht. Das war eine verdammt schlechte Idee. Das war auch so ein Grund, warum der Cube so ein Scheißgerät war. Genau, die haben noch so rumgeliefen und die Kabel zu kurzen. Aber der Mac Pro hat ja auch so eine kleine Quäke drin. Ich glaube, davon haben sie gelernt, weil das war ein Riesenproblem, dass der Cube keinen eingebauten Lautsprecher hatte, weil du immer nicht definiertes Bootverhalten herstellen konntest, weil diese komischen Lautsprecher, wenn sie nicht angeschlossen waren, dann wusstest du nicht, bootet der jetzt, was ist das überhaupt? Also das war eine ganz doofe Idee.
Ich hab grad mal geguckt bei Blackmagic, die ja so einer der...
Die bauen das Zeug, was man da ranstecken kann.
Die bauen schon das Zeug, ja. Die haben da so richtig so REC-Hardware mit Thunderbolt, mit Capture und so die richtig leckere...
Mit Thunderbolt.
Naja, die Blackmagic-Jungs, die sind schon immer relativ schnell dabei, weil das schon mit Industriestandard ist ganz viel. Also zum Beispiel in so einer Bude, wo sie so Filmscannen, so von 8 Millimeter bis 70 Millimeter, also so richtig die teuren Scanner und so rumstehen, haben das halt alles voll mit so Blackmagic-Hardware. Und die haben auch ihren eigenen Codec und so Kram, also das ist so... Bei Videos sind die schon ganz vorne mit dabei. Und ja, jetzt hab ich gerade geschaut, und die haben auf jeden Fall, bieten sie hier so REC-Hardware mit Thunderbolt, gleich direkt Capture und und was weiß ich, was man dann schon machen kann.
Das ist glaube ich auch so ein bisschen, wobei für Audio gibt es da herzlich wenig. Das einzige, was ich kenne, ist Apollo. Das sind auch so 19 Zoll Teile, die dann so optional Thunderbolt haben. Aber jetzt wird es halt richtig teuer. Weil wenn du jetzt in diese neue Welt hinein migrieren willst, dann hast du mehrere Probleme auf einmal. Also du willst natürlich erstmal deine alte Investition behalten. So, und du willst vielleicht nicht gleich jetzt –nur weil Apple ein neues Gerät angekündigt hat –das alles sofort verkaufen, sondern vielleicht nochmal zwei Jahre nutzen. Also da wird noch was passieren. Die Leute, die jetzt eigentlich einen neuen Mac Pro gekauft hätten, davon ausgehend, dass der genauso funktioniert wie die alten, können unter Umständen diesen Schritt nicht machen. Denn es wird dann auch irgendwann teuer. Du kannst ja jetzt so externe PCI-Gehäuse kaufen, aber um so zwei PCI-Karten unterzubringen, dann zahlst du für so einen Teil halt 850 Euro.
Da kannst du also auch gleich die Hardware neu kaufen, wenn es die dann ohne PCI gibt.
Eben.
Aber gibt es wahrscheinlich eben nicht mit allen Sachen.
Nee, gibt es nicht mit allen Sachen. Manchen aber gibt es nicht mit allen Sachen.
Im Audio ist Thunderbolt noch gar nicht angekommen, kann man schon sagen.
Ja, mit der Ausnahme von Apollo. Genau.
Also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, also diese... Also ich hab mir, als ich mir meinen Audio-Interface gekauft hab, und dann hab ich so überlegt, so will ich das jetzt in USB, oder will ich noch mal Firewire? Ich hab ja noch an meinem alten MacBook Pro hier Firewire, und dann, ah, USB, ich weiß nicht, dann hab ich mir halt das Firewire gekauft, und es funktionierte super. Und hätt's Thunderbolt gegeben in irgendwas Bezahlbarem oder so, dann hätt ich wahrscheinlich Thunderbolt genommen, weil irgendwie, keine Ahnung, so geprägt noch aus alten Firewire-Marketing-Zeiten oder was auch immer, so Audio-USB irgendwie klingt irgendwie einfach nicht so wie eine total tolle Idee.
Die Thunderbolt-Preise werden ja erst dann in den Keller rutschen, oder runterrutschen, wenn die PC-Leute das auch anfangen zu benutzen. Vorher werden natürlich die Mac-Preise einen Bluten lassen.
Nee, nee, nee, das ist halt, ich meine, ich habe ja von Holger schon gehört, dass der irgendwelche Probleme mit USB und Audio beim Podcasten hatte. Und irgendwie, ich habe schon, man hört schon öfters mal, dass da irgendwie Probleme gibt. Jetzt kommst du hier mit deinem RME-Problem. Und ich habe bisher mit diesem Firewire-Interface null Probleme. Also von daher bin ich schon mal, fühle mich so ein bisschen bestätigt in meiner Wahrnehmung.
Ist ja auch vom Prinzip wie eine Soundkarte.
Ja, USB ist auch eine scheiß Schnittstelle für Realtime.
Das ist einfach so.
Auch bei drei immer noch?
Da hat sich da konzeptionell irgendwas geändert, ne?
Das ist immer noch Polling.
Also USB ist einfach Polling. Du musst immer fragen, ist was da, ist was da, ist was da. Und Firewire ist irgendwie DMA.
DMA-Repräsent. In your Fressi.
Schreibt ja halt direkt in Speicher.
Genau.
Ja, es kann nicht nur vor dem Portal sein, aber...
Wollte ich gerade sagen, aber...
Wenn es um Performance geht, schon.
Genau.
Auch beim Performanter den Ram auslesen.
Na gut, also Mac Pro, ich glaube, das wird irgendwie alles dauern.
Also ich mein, aber nochmal zu der IO. Geschichte, also was die da so für Datenbusse fahren und was die da aus ihrem Flash-Speicher für Transferraten raussaugen, also das ist schon ja auch schwer beeindruckend, also da...
Naja, es wird der PC sein, der auch im Herbst rauskommt, wird es auch haben, der Standard-PC, meinst du nicht?
Nee, ich mein halt hier so auf dem, dass er mit, wie viel, 1,5 Gigabit SSD, also Flash-Speicher, das ist schon mal eine echte Hausnummer so und auch der Bus...
Ja ok, es wird der PC eventuell nicht haben, ich weiß nicht, wie weit die da schon sind.
Ob die auf ihren Boards so eine hohen Transferraten dahin kriegen, also klar müssten sie ja eigentlich, wenn sie auch die Intel-Chips und so, das müsste schon gehen, ne?
Eben, also Standard-Chip-Sets für Xeon-Prozessoren, also die Server-Boards werden das auch so haben. Ob sie den Flash halt auch so integrieren, ist natürlich eine andere Frage, aber ja. Aber die Server-Boards haben dann wahrscheinlich wieder zwei Grafikkarten, nicht so in der Form.
Ja, so, ich mein, dadurch, dass jetzt wieder sie alles so, ne, aus einer Hand so handgefertigt zusammenschnitzen und eben du nicht so dieses Board... Ja, aber das sie halt, ich meine, weißt du, wie es beim PC ist, kaufst du dir das Board, kaufst du dir den CPU, kaufst du dir den RAM, kaufst du dir die Festplatte, kaufst du dir, da steckst du das alles auseinander und dann muss es irgendwie passen, dann muss noch dein BIOS updaten und dann kannst du vielleicht auch alle Features benutzen und so weiter.
Oder du bekaufst bei Dell ein, gleich alles, oder bei HP.
Ja, aber ob die das halt auch so handgeschnitzt irgendwie optimieren, ist auch die Frage.
Aber sagen wir mal so, ich denke, es wird nicht allzu viele Rechner geben, die einen Xeon-Prozessor und halt die Grafikkartenbauer. Meistens hast du ja normale Rechner, die wo du mehrere Grafikkarten reinballerst. Oder du hast halt einen Rechner mit Xeon-Prozessor und der ist dann aber mehr so für Serverbetrieb ausgelegt und hat wiederum nichts mit Grafikkarten am Hut. Und ja, die fahren immer ein bisschen anders. Ich bin gespannt. Und vor allem auf den Preis bin ich gespannt.
Naja, genau, das ist natürlich so der Hauptpunkt. Der Preis. Also was würdest du tippen? Was würdest du da für dieses Gerät bezahlen?
Da ja auch wiederum dann doch nicht so viel dran und drin ist und so weiter und so fort. Also ich würde mal sagen, dass die Preise zum jetzigen Mac Pro eigentlich ziemlich ähnlich sind.
Und wie sind die so?
Ich glaube, das Low-End-Modell geht jetzt ging, gibt's ja jetzt nicht mehr, aber ging so bei 2000 Euro los oder knapp drunter sogar, ich weiß gar nicht. Und High-End war irgendwo so bei 4, also mit Build-In und Updaten und noch mehr Platte und Zeug rein konnte es natürlich besonst so hochschrauben. Aber ich glaube, in dem Bereich liegt das Ding auch so. Ich würde mich auch ehrlich nicht wundern, wenn da ein Mac Pro für unter 2000 Euro rauskommt. Der kleinste. Weil natürlich müssen sie ein bisschen fächern. Sie wollen schon auch das Ding irgendwie an Leute verkaufen, die nicht Final Cut Pro und sonst was benutzen. Und dann nur 6 Cores haben wollen oder so. Ich denke, den würde es auch geben. Warum nicht? Hat es jetzt mit dem alten Mac Pro aufgegeben.
Die CPUs sind glaube ich gar nicht das Problem. Die Grafikkarten.
Die könnten sie zur Not auch weglassen.
Na, das werden sie aber nicht tun.
Warum nicht?
Weil das, darauf wollte ich ja eigentlich am Anfang schon zu sprechen kommen. Weil das, verstehst du, das ist das, worum es jetzt geht. Wenn du Mac Pro sagst, dann meinst du damit.
Eine Grafikkarte, die frei ist und die nicht für den Bildschirm ist und nicht anfängt zu ruckeln, wenn du mal OpenCL benutzt.
Ja, einfach kompromisslose, rohe, nackte Computing-Performance für parallel Prozesse.
Dann machen sie halt zwei kleinere GPUs rein, ist mir egal.
Ich kenne mich in dem GPU-Bereich nicht so gut aus, aber ich glaube, hier geht es auch schon darum, dass du wirklich diese kapable GPU drin hast. Deswegen ist es auch wichtig, dass sie ihr neuestes OS da drauf werfen. Ich glaube, da müssen wir nicht drüber diskutieren. Die Dinger werden mit 10.9 rauskommen, das ist vollkommen klar. Allein schon, weil sie ja dort das erste Mal überhaupt OpenGL 4 implementiert haben. Da hängen sie ja derzeit noch ewig hinterher. Und jetzt irgendwie diese neue Generation von GPUs und dann diesen hohen Stellenwert für Grafikrechenleistung zu bringen, ohne dann gleich mit der neuesten Software zu kommen. Das wird einfach nicht stattfinden.
Vielleicht bringen sie ja dann auch Logic X endlich raus und das ist dann auch so voll GPU und alles und toll. Und hast du nicht gesehen?
Also ich werde mir auf jeden Fall keinen kaufen. So viel kann ich schon mal sicher sagen, nicht in absehbarer Zeit.
Ja, ich auch nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Das ist für mich irgendwie total...
Für das Level, mit dem ich hier gerade noch so Audio und Video betreibe, reicht noch so ein Notebook aus. Da warte ich zwar dann mal eine Stunde, um so ein bisschen Full-HD-Video vom iPod zu kratzen, aber so ist es dann halt, nicht?
Ja, ich hab auch CPU-mäßig hier irgendwie keine Probleme.
Niemand braucht die Smack-Probe.
So, wir sind zufrieden.
Schon wieder.
Ja, noch, das ändert sich ja auch ganz schnell.
Bei Mountain Lion dachten wir auch noch, wow. Und hier Versions, uuuuh. Und was nicht alles. Da war ich ja noch nicht dabei. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, bei der Ankündigung dachten wir auch, das ist ja total smart und hier Versions und uuuh toll und sowieso. Und dann kam es und so. Naja, eigentlich das einzig Tolle war ja diese Full-Disc-Encryption, die jetzt endlich mal dann auch dieses File Vault-Geräfte abgelöst hat. Das war das einzig richtig coole.
Ist doch ein Feature von Mountain Lion.
Aber das war so das einzige, was mal so ein cooles Feature war.
Ab Mac OS 10.7, haha.
Tatsächlich. Was war denn da überhaupt nochmal neu?
Was war denn da eigentlich sonst noch?
Leder-Optik.
So, ja, wo wir gerade bei Hardware sind. Es gab ja noch andere neue Hardware. Und ich sah mich dann doch genötigt, ein Upgrade zu machen. Und jetzt seit ein paar Minuten läuft die Kiste.
Warte mal ganz kurz.
Ich weiß bloß noch nicht so ganz genau, was ich dazu jetzt noch groß sagen soll. Was denn?
Ich guck gerade mal die Features von Mountainline. Wer von euch benutzt denn zum Beispiel Powernap? Powernap?
Bei Powernap weiß man nicht, ob man es benutzt.
Ja, aber...
Als wer schaltet seinen Rechner aus?
Oder wer von euch benutzt Dictation?
Ja, man kann jetzt auch in diesen Rechner reinsprechen.
Oder wer benutzt Game Center auf Mac? Also Gatekeeper, das war noch bei Mountainline neu. Ich guck gerade mal, was da auf der Featuresliste steht. Also das ist jetzt auch vielleicht ein ganz gutes Feature. Es nervt natürlich auch ganz oft. Aber ansonsten von den Big-Ass, Kick-Ass-Features, die Showcase-Features, iMessages, Comes to Mac, da hab ich jetzt ja gut, das hat auch sehr viel Licht und sehr viel Schatten.
Funktioniert aber besser als vorher.
Ja.
Ist aber so schwer.
Ja, aber es funktioniert auch immer noch erstaunlich schlecht. Also ich hab's wirklich sehr oft, dass es Out of Sync ist. Und ich hab wirklich beides gleichzeitig an. Ich tippe neben ein. Und die Antworten kommen nur neben einem Fenster an. Und lauter so Sachen. Notification Center ist auch ein heiß geliebtes Feature von uns allen. Stimmt's Clemens?
Ja, ab und zu fällt mir auf, dass es das gibt.
Das taucht selten auf. Und es ist ein bisschen still geworden drumrum. Erst haben sie alle gesagt, ja wir integrieren das, und dann wieder doch nicht, aber es ist ein bisschen still geworden.
Und das Sharing-Feature, das wurde da auch groß noch angemeldet. Also eigentlich war beim Mountain Lion so gut wie nichts drin, muss man mal sagen.
Na, es lief nicht mehr so scheiße instabil wie Lion.
Airplay war noch drin, aber das funktioniert ja auch immer nur so halb.
Wobei das hat schon eine Menge Auswirkungen gehabt. Also ich hab jetzt schon sehr häufig so Meetings gehabt, wo man dann einfach Apple TV und jeder, der gerade was zu zeigen hat, klickt sich mal eben drauf. Das ist schon ausgesprochen praktisch. Ich würde das grad noch für die wichtigen Sachen hinzuzählen.
So, und ja, dann war es das für Mountain Lion größtenteils eigentlich auch schon. Fotobooth hat ein Sharesheet bekommen. Und Setpicture ist Twitter-Profile-Picture wurde hier als Feature für Fotobooth aufgezählt. Ja, es ist wirklich eher dünn. Na gut, da können wir ja Mountain Lion, das kann nur besser werden.
Benutzt jemand diese Twitter-Integration oder diese Facebook-Integration? Gibt es überhaupt schon eine Facebook-Integration? Ich hab ja kein Facebook, aber...
Also die Twitter-Accounts hab ich schon alle im System angemeldet.
Und benutzt du das?
Na, ich benutze halt meine Twitter-App.
So dieses Twittern Sie aus jeder Gelegenheit. Twittern Sie aus Ihrem Taschenrechner Ihr letztes Ergebnis.
Also ich benutze nicht die vom Betriebssystem gebotenen im Notification-Center. Aber das hat auch was damit zu tun, dass ich halt auch gar nicht mehr so viel Twitter. Und wenn, dann tue ich das halt eher im Kontext mit app.net. Und deswegen benutze ich primär Sale. Und Sale benutzt dann wiederum die Accounts. Also was ich korrekt finde, ist, dass man so Accounts im System ablegen kann und Programme, die dann so nutzen können. Aber doof finde ich halt, dass ich das irgendwie immer nur noch auf Twitter, Facebook und ich glaube jetzt neu bei 10.9 haben sie jetzt auch LinkedIn. Da haben wir natürlich wirklich drauf gewartet.
Auf jeden Fall.
Da was wirklich cool wäre, wenn sie dafür mal eine vernünftige App hier machen. Die haben ja eh schon ihre Keychain-Zeugs oder so. Da könnte man dann auch hingehen und sagen, wir machen jetzt mal ein generisches Social-Media-Dingsen. Und dann kann halt der LinkedIn, der Xing, der schießt mich tot da seine Plugins spendieren.
Ja, weil das werden sie nicht tun.
Es geht nicht darum, was sie tun und was sie tun werden und könnten, sondern was schön wäre.
Ja, so eine Flatter-Integration.
Zum Beispiel Flatter.
Ja, ich glaube, das können wir vergessen.
Ja, aber das ist schade.
Das ist schade, natürlich ist das schade. Aber es ist halt auch unrealistisch, das zu erträumen.
Naja, du wolltest jetzt von deinem neuesten Hardware-Streich berichten, Tim.
Zu berichten gibt es nicht viel. Ich habe einen Upgrade gemacht von meinem alten MacBook Air auf das aktuelle MacBook Air. Im Wesentlichen ist jetzt erstmal alles gleich geblieben. Das heißt, ich hoffe, es bleibt nicht alles gleich, weil ich habe schon ein bisschen Ärger mit dem Gerät gehabt. Vor allem so lüftertechnisch. Das ist mir halt einfach zu warm geworden. Und das war für mich einfach nicht mehr zu vertragen. Also ich will den Lüfter nicht hören. Mein erstes Air, das ich hatte, das war ein Traum. Das war dieses erste keilförmige... Ich hör Clemens Lüfter die ganze Zeit.
Was machst du denn da? Zettel-Liege-Spiel? Nein.
Das ist ein alter MacBook Pro von 2010.
Machst grad noch nix, ja klar.
Was ich ein bisschen enttäuschend fand, ist, dass diese Migration nicht funktioniert hat über Ethernet. Warum auch immer. Ich hab gestern gestartet und dann meinte er noch so, heute Morgen, ich bräuchte jetzt nochmal so 25 Stunden. Und nichts bewegt sich. Also das war früher echt besser.
Hast du da vielleicht versichtlich so ein 100-Megabit-Dongel dran gemacht?
Ich hab da Thunderbolt Gigabit Ethernet dran gehört. Immer vom Geilsten und vom Geilsten.
Aber nicht Donnerbolzen gegen Donnerbolzen.
Aber hat irgendwie trotzdem nicht funktioniert. Das ist halt ein bisschen bekloppt. Ja, jetzt kann ich nur hoffen, dass diese angebliche Sparsamkeit des neuen Gerätes sich irgendwie zeigt. Also von diesen neun Stunden, die sie da reden. Da glaub ich halt nicht im Traum dran, dass ich da auch nur ansatzweise in diese Region komme. Aber wenn ich mal zumindest die magischen drei Stunden überschreiten könnte, wäre ich ja schon mal ganz zufrieden.
Wo hast du denn das Ding eigentlich her? Hast du den bestellt oder warst du im Apple Store?
Online.
Verstehe. Ich dachte, du gehst da mal hin und lässt dir von so einem blau-t-shirtigen Nerd deine Daten überspielen, von deinem PC. Und dann am Ende so, ja ich bin übrigens der Tim. Aber, ne, aber das hättest du da machen können. Die hätten genug Thunderbolt. Neutralader schießt mich tot, Adapter, da hättest du dich schön an eine Genius Bar gesetzt.
Dieser funktioniert schneller außerhalb meiner Räume.
Nee, wenn du das Ding als Platten-Ding zählst, hast du ja eine SSD links, eine SSD rechts. Und wenn du den einen als Target betreibst, dann dürfte das schon wirklich...
Okay, du hast das ja voll schonmal angedeutet. Also du hast schonmal Thunderbolt-Kabel zwischen zwei Thunderbolt-enabled-Geräte geschaltet und darüber den Target-Disc-Modus aktiviert.
Nein, habe ich nicht, aber es gibt einen Target-Disc-Modus bei den neuen Geräten.
Für Thunderbolt.
Weil den gab es am Anfang definitiv nicht. Ich hab nichts davon gehört.
Ich hab das jetzt gerade kürzlich neulich bei einer anderen Suche, ist mir das irgendwie untergekommen. Kann aber auch sein, dass da wieder mal drin stand, geht mal wieder nicht oder so. Probier doch mal aus.
Ich suche gerade mal. Tatsächlich, also laut Apple geht es. Zack. So, dann brauchen wir natürlich noch ein Thunderbolt-Kabel.
Für nur 49,99 für 3 Meter.
Da hab ich da, ich kann ja morgen eins.
Ich geh jetzt auch ein kürzeres Thunderbolt-Kabel. Es muss keine 5 Meter mehr lang sein.
Kostet aber glaube ich genauso viel.
Diese Apple-Adapter-Preise.
Die Chips an beiden Enden sind ja die gleichen. Und die 3 cm Kupfer dazwischen, die kosten jetzt auch nichts.
Ich war ja, als ich in England war, da fiel mir ein Scheiße. Die haben ja andere Steckdosen. Und dann bin ich...
Können wir die bitte endlich mal aus der EU rausschmeißen?
Dann bin ich da so in so ein Apple Store in der Mall. Also in Brighton gab es in der Mall so ein Apple Store. Da bin ich da so rein und meinte, hier habt ihr so einen Schnuffi, zum ans Netzteil ranstecken, weil die sind ja austauschbar. Nee, haben wir nicht einzeln. Musst ihr jetzt das Netzteil nochmal kaufen.
Nee, es gibt ja noch diesen Traveller-Kit.
Ja, aber das wäre sicherlich auch nicht billiger gewesen als...
Nee, nee, der Traveller-Kit, ich hab das schon eine Weile her, wo ich es mal gekauft habe.
Wenn du die Fragen hast, ob du mal kurz deinen Rechner aufladen kannst, dann hätten sie dich gelassen wahrscheinlich. Das 2-Meter-Thunderbolt-Kabel kostet tatsächlich nur 39 Euro.
Das gibt sogar einen halben Meter und das kostet nur 29.
Das ist es.
Das ist ja ein Schnäppchen. Jetzt müssen sie mir aber nochmal erzählen, warum eineinhalb Meter Kabel länger...
20 Euro kosten.
Warum es 10 Euro mehr kostet. 10 Euro für Litze. I know, aber so kriegen sie die Scheißtechnologie echt nicht durchgesetzt.
Warum kostet ein Flug nach Zürich 1000 Euro ein Flug nach Barcelona über Zürich 200? Du versuchst da immer noch irgendwie einen Sinn drin zu finden oder eine logische Erklärung.
Ja, natürlich, ich versuche einen Sinn des Lebens zu finden.
Die logische Erklärung ist, weil sie es können.
Ein Apple-Zubehörladen, das ist für mich die wahre Erleuchtung und Erkenntnis.
Aber es ist nicht erlaubt, dann nach Barcelona zu buchen und in Zürich einfach auszusteigen.
Doch, Pantse, damit wolltest du den Rest deines Tickets. Ja, aber dann geh doch mal in den Apple Store, such dir so ein blaues T-Shirt-Nerd und stell dem nochmal die Frage.
Welche?
Mit Mikrofon. Besorgt ihr mal so ein mobiles Aufnahmegerät?
Ne, das macht man nicht, das ist unfair.
Wieso?
Das find ich affig.
Da kannst du auch richtig sagen, du hast hier mal eine Frage. Und dann sagt er, ja, ich bin ja hier der Apple Nerd, stell mir deine Frage.
Naja, also davon abgesehen, dass ich tatsächlich mit den Antworten von den Apple Nerds und Apple Stores wirklich gute Ergebnisse erzielt habe bisher, hat das ja nichts mit den Kabelpreisen zu tun. Ich bin auch durchaus bereit, die Strafgebühr zu bezahlen, aber ich bin nicht bereit zu akzeptieren, dass diese Scheiß-Migration nicht auch über ein Gigabit Ethernet gut funktioniert.
Wenn du da ein Gigabit Ethernet hast, wirklich?
Ja, natürlich hab ich Gigabit Ethernet. Das ist ja der Witz an diesem Scheiß-Adapter, sonst bräuchte ich den ja nicht. Dann könnte ich ja auch USB reinstecken.
Wer weiß, was du da kaputt gemacht hast?
Ist ja auch nicht so, dass er nicht angefangen hätte zu kommunizieren.
Vielleicht hast du den ISDN-Kabel da drin gesteckt oder so.
Also ich bin über den Wookie-Status deutlich hinaus, dein Freund.
Dein Ethernet ist doch immer kaputt hier, vielleicht warten wir wieder so weit.
Nee, der hat es ja back to back gemacht. Du hast ja gar keinen Switch dazwischen.
Vielleicht ist es grundsätzlich kaputt.
Das hättest du zumindest nochmal machen können. Du hättest ja beide an deinen Switch anschließen können. Dann hättest du dazwischen mal auf den Switch gucken können, was da so geht.
Nochmal 24 Stunden warten. Das hat einfach zu funktionieren und fertig. Und vor allem, wenn es nicht funktioniert, wenn es stalled, hat diese Software mit einem klugen Fenster zu kommen und zu sagen...
Yes or no?
Alle Saaten nicht löschen, ja nein.
Diese Migration nicht weiter fortsetzen oder doch? Ja nein?
Vielleicht.
Vielleicht Cancel Abort.
Womit wir wieder bei dem Thema sind, warum lügen uns die Geräte in letzter Zeit immer häufiger an?
Ist auf jeden Fall jetzt nicht so die User Experience, die ich zu schätzen weiß.
Aber sag mal Tim, du hast ja hier im Werte eines neuen iPhones fünf irgendwie so Adapter rumliegen auch. Vier MagSafe Adapter. Was kostet das ein MagSafe Adapter?
Nur 10 Euro.
Nur 10 Euro. Das heißt, da hast du... Ja, dieses kleine Flimsel, Schnimsel. Das ist wirklich... Und dieser...
Aber da sind Magneten drin. Da sind ja die Magneten drin.
Die Old Dock zur Lightning Adapter für das iPhone, die kosten auch irgendwie 19 Euro oder sowas.
Hab ich einen von.
Dieser Adapter von dem alten Dock-Connector zum neuen Lightning, die du einfach so auf deinen alten Kabel raufsteckst. Die kosten auch 19 Euro.
Wieso hast du denn da einen von?
Kann man da nicht wirklich gleich das neue holen? Also für Geräte, die das Kabel fest dran haben?
Andere Leute, die meine Infrastruktur teilweise mitnutzen, haben iPhone 4s. Ich will da jetzt nicht in Details gehen. Nimm es einfach so.
Ein Lightning, du hast da einen Lightning-Adapter, oder? Von Alt auf Lightning, hast du nicht eben erzählt?
Ja, einen hab ich da.
Du meinst andere Leute, die hierher kommen, mit einem iPhone 5 fahren?
Im Auto. Auch Menschen mit einem iPhone 4 dürfen Musik einspielen.
Und laden.
Nee. Aber ist schon okay so, passt schon.
Ja, finde ich okay. Naja, ich meine, mit diesen MagSafe 2 Dingern, die Realität ist halt so, du wirst da draußen mal ein Netzteil brauchen und dann ist es halt das Falsche. So, und dann hast du halt so ein Teil dabei.
Was wir jetzt für einen Adapterkoffer für unsere Mac-Geräte mitnehmen müssen, ist echt nicht mehr feierlich, ja?
Das war noch nie anders. In gewisser Hinsicht ist es schon besser geworden.
Alle sind weiß und sehen gleich aus. Man muss erst mal noch ewig nach dem kleinen Icon suchen.
Das ist mein Adapter-Set, was ich eigentlich immer...
Hast du auch einen ausgepackten?
Ja, der steckt hier dran.
Muss ich aufmachen, ja?
Diese Tüten finde ich gut.
Ich kann die auch einfach aufmachen.
So was gibt es bei Modular zum Beispiel.
Die kannst du auch einfach bei Amazon klicken. Das sind sogenannte Mesh-Bags. Und die kann ich sehr empfehlen. Die gibt es von... Was ist dieselbe Firma? Rexel oder Hetzel. Also Rexel hat, glaube ich, Hetzel gekauft oder zumindest die betreibt die. Und die Mesh-Bags, die gibt es in allen möglichen Größenordnungen. In A5, A6, A5, A4. Und ich hab die großflächig im Einsatz. Fantastisch, gerade für solche Adaptersachen. Und ich hab halt für unterschiedliche Einsatzzwecke immer ein Täschchen. Und konfiguriere hab die immer so da liegen. Und wenn ich so einen Einsatz habe, weißte ich ja, so Alarmglocke, so Podcast-Einsatz. Dann nehme ich mir einfach das richtige, wenn du an die Stange springst, die richtige Auswahl an kleinen Täschchen. Zum Beispiel habe ich hier, das ist mein Mac. Das ist leider jetzt aus Unfallgründen gerade nicht so richtig bestückt. Genau, also in einem Tischchen habe ich einfach normales Netzteil mit Euro-Steckerverlänger. Also nicht mit diesem normalen weißen Standard-Stecker für die Steckdose, sondern Rasiererkabel dran, weil das einfach in meisten Fällen irgendwie sinnvoller ist und länger ist. Und normalerweise habe ich dann hier auch noch diesen Ethernet-Adapter mit drin. Und außerdem habe ich auch noch einen iPhone 5-Kabel, habe ich auch noch mit hier mit dabei, weil das für mich sozusagen zum Thema Stromversorgung gehört. Weil ich das iPhone ja auch mal dabei habe und dann habe ich eine Tasche, da ist Strom drin, und zwar Strom für den Rechner und der Rechner liefert das für das Telefon. Randstöpseln muss ich das Ding sowieso, weil ich ja Internet brauche und dieses Sharing über WLAN nicht gut funktioniert. Zumindest nicht immer. Das über USB auch nicht, aber es funktioniert meistens. Dann habe ich hier mein zweites Taschchen.
iPhone Basics.
Das ist mein iPhone Basics. Da ist auch so ein bisschen mehr drin. Das brauche ich nicht unbedingt immer, aber da sind so diverse Dinge drin. Zum Beispiel ein kleines, klinke, klinke Verbindungskabel, um mal eben in irgendwas, so Autoradios und so weiter, um da reinzugehen. Dann habe ich hier so meinen Glyph irgendwie dabei.
Hier liegt auch noch einer rum.
Das ist für ein iPhone 4, das ist der fürs iPhone 5. Da kann man mal so einen Ständer brauchen, das Ding irgendwie hinstellen will. Dann habe ich hier noch so einen Bamboo-Pen. Okay, den benutze ich eigentlich kaum, aber den habe ich da einfach mal mit reingetan. Das Kabel ist doppelt. Dann habe ich diesen geilen...
Hier wird der Wahnsinn des Wortes aus dem Nähteschen geplaudert.
Dieser Belkin Rockstar ist manchmal sehr praktisch, wenn du zum Beispiel an ein Device mehrere Kopfhörer oder wenn du mehrere Devices an einen Kopfhörer anschließen willst. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel auf dem iPhone Podcast höre, aber nebenbei am Rechner was mache und immer mal wieder Audio oder Video kurz abspiele, dann stecke ich halt diesen Belkin Rockstar da dran.
Die Sony Walkmans vor 20 Jahren hatten schon einen Ausgang für die Freundinnen.
Ja genau, aber hier habe ich halt weitere 5 Plugs, wo man sozusagen irgendwas ranplacken kann. Damit kann man irgendwie lustige Sachen machen.
Das aber einfach nur alles parallel schaltet, da ist nicht nur V, sondern auch kein Foto drin.
Dann habe ich noch ein Auto-Strom zu USB. Auch ganz praktisch.
Und ein Port-Dubler. Also ein Headphone-Ausgang, Port-Dubler.
Ja, der sollte hier eigentlich gar nicht drin sein. Hier sollte eigentlich eher der Flugadapter drin sein. Wo der jetzt ist, weiß ich gerade nicht. Und dann noch so ein kleines Stativ. Also so Kleinkram, wenn man sozusagen seriös länger unterwegs ist mit dem iPhone und für verschiedene Fälle halt so Zeug braucht. Und dann dieses dritte...
Dein Beischlafutensilienkoffer.
Das ist das vierte dann. Aber das dritte Täschchen ist mein Präsentationstäschchen. Da ist dann so eine Remote drin. Also so eine Click-Remote von Logitech, um halt Präsentationen zu machen. Und halt so das übliche Set an... Nee, das hat so eine eigene Funkverbindung. Du ziehst da so ein kleines Schnipsi raus und steckst das in den USB rein. Das simuliert dann einfach ein Keyboard. Funktioniert besser als der ganze Bluetooth-Gram.
Unterdrückt den Space-Tast oder...
Ja, ich hab einmal den Fehler gemacht, mit Bluetooth-Remote irgendwie auf dem Kongress zu präsentieren. Das war keine gute Idee. Ja, und noch so ein HDMI-Adapter. Ich kann direkt an den VGA-HDMI ran.
Ich hab auch lauter gerümpelt, aber es kullert bei mir so ein bisschen rum. Ich nehme immer diese Zip-Block-Bags, aber die gehen natürlich auch schon nach kurzer Zeit kaputt.
Genau, die gehen kaputt. Diese Mesh-Bags, die sind nicht totzukriegen. Ja, dann noch hier so ein USB-Stick. Für alle Fälle. Falls man seine Präsentation an ein anderes Gerät transferieren muss oder so ein Scheiß. Naja, also so versuche ich das quasi so scenarioorientiert zu machen. Und dann habe ich hier noch eine ganze Schublade voll. Sozusagen für den sonstigen Einsatz. Und da habe ich dann irgendwie noch alle möglichen sonstigen Konstellationen. Dann habe ich hier so mein Raspberry Pi-Täschchen und mein Recorder-Täschchen und mein so weiter. Ich habe auch immer ein USB-Hub in so einem Mesh-Bag. Weißte, wo immer alles dabei ist, wo immer das Netzteil dazu da ist und so das Minimumset an Kabeln. Das ist doch eine definierte Einheit von Gerät, dass wenn man das mal braucht, dass man dann nicht das mitnimmt und dann feststellt, dass irgendwie der wichtige Adapter fehlt oder so.
Sehr organisiert. Das muss man schon sagen.
Manchmal bin ich ganz gut organisiert. Mesh-Bags haben mir auf jeden Fall weitergeholfen. Kann ich sehr empfehlen.
Benutzt auch schon sehr lange, kann ich bestätigen.
Genau und die großen sind vor allem auch sehr praktisch. Die A4-Teile. Guck mal, da hinten hab ich zum Beispiel auch meine ganzen USB, Firewire-Kabel, alles hat so ein eigenes Täschchen. Ist auch so beim Umsortieren und Umräumen ganz gut.
Ja, bei Modulor gibt es die Mesh-Bags auch, hab ich es, wie ich es gerade doch vermutet habe. Modulor ist sowieso so ein toller Laden.
Der ist auch preislich sehr für Leute, die mit der Apple Store gewohnt sind.
Letztens brauchten wir zum Beispiel mal spontan Whiteboard, ein großes. Da fragt man sich ja auch so, wo in Berlin kauft man denn jetzt mal so ein Whiteboard? Und dann vielleicht bei Modulor. Tatsache, Modulor hat welche. Ha!
Wie Modulor nennt die Dinger Schlamper-Mäppchen?
Alleine ist es schon ein Grund da, Weißen zu kaufen.
Find ich gut. Es gibt sie auch als Reißverschlussbeutel transparent mit weißem Nylon-Gewebe. Also das Schlamper-Mäppchen ist glaube ich diese Stifttasche da, ne?
Genau, das ist auch ganz praktisch für so alles, was so ein bisschen stiftig ist.
Und die gibt es auch in schwarz. Ja, also Modulor, da fragt ihr immer nach der URL, es ist tatsächlich modulor.de, es ist ein Laden in Berlin. Die haben mal angefangen als so Architekten-Bastelbedarf, also wenn die Architekten ihre Modelle bauen, so kleine Modellbäumchen und so. Und die haben jetzt sozusagen, die hatten den Laden genau gegenüber von mir und haben immer mehr so in ihr Angebot aufgenommen, so bis irgendwann ein Lötkolben, dann hatten sie eine Holzwerkstatt. Genau, und jetzt sind sie ja an Moritzplatz in so ein dreistöckiges Megading umgezogen. Da gibt es halt wirklich zum Basteln alles. Kleber, Hölzer, Textilien, Papiere, Stifte, Farben. Also ich hab ja zum Beispiel, als ich meine Gitarrenbox gebaut hab, dachte ich mir so, okay, ich brauche also Birke, Multiplex in den Formen, wo krieg ich das jetzt her? Modulo, ach ja, gibt's irgendwie? Hab mir die Maße gleich da ins Web-Interface geklickt, konnte ich's da am Nachmittag gleich abholen.
Also die schneiden schon vorher zu, nicht dass du da rumstehst und wahrraus bist.
Guter Tipp, das ist ja gar nicht teuer da.
Nee, das ist nicht so teuer.
Weil ich hab letztens mal geguckt und hab nur völlig absurde Preisvorstellungen gefunden und das ist wirklich okay. Vor allem haben die so korrekte 10er-Packs und so.
Ja, so, ich mein dieses Holzzuschnitt und so, das können die nur bis zu bestimmten Größen und es ist auch ein bisschen teurer.
Sie haben den A3. Den A3!
Ey, dann kannst du die Kleineren in den größeren zusammengruppieren.
Ja, den A4. Wenn ich sogar den A0 kriegen könnte, kann ich wahrscheinlich komplette Co-Moderatoren vorhalten. So einfach so.
Lass dich mal kurz den Holz auspacken. Genau.
Und ob da ein 0 reicht?
Kryokammer 3 öffnen.
Ja, also...
Den Holger aus dem Schlampern, den Schlampern auspillen. Nein, und A2.
Also Modular hat echt viel Kram und ist...
Vorhin dachten wir noch Tim Tim Zichtenstrecken, aber jetzt gerade?
Da kann man wirklich mal so hingehen und so durchstöbern und man findet immer was, was man nicht braucht, aber immer schon gerne haben wollte. Ja, das...
Da kommt man ja auch nicht raus ohne nicht umscheißig.
Schwer vergleichend. Modular ist schon so eine eigene Kategorie.
Du gehst halt so durch und kriegst halt auch die ganze Zeit irgendwie Ideen. Also da gibt es halt so absurde Sachen, wie so Stahlkugeln oder so Halbkugeln in Transparent oder Styroporkugeln, Kegel, Ringe, Ketten...
Ich sag nur diese kleinen Styroporkugelchen, von einem Sack, den irgendwo jemand in die Wohnung stellt und einen Schlitz reinzieht.
Von was?
Von diesen kleinen Styroporkugeln, die so filmen, diese ganz kleinen, die so einen Millimeter oder zwei Meter Durchmesser haben. Die haben so einen Spaß, überall hast du ja statische Elektrizität und diese Dinger kleben überall. Wenn du versuchst sie wegzusaugen, krabbeln die an deinem Staugsaugerrohr außen ran hoch. Da muss man ja wieder hingehen.
Ja, also das kann man wirklich nur empfehlen, sich da mal durchzustöbern. Und wie gesagt, wenn man mal so ein bisschen Holz braucht und sich ein Regal bauen will, was auch immer. Ja, es kostet ein bisschen mehr als vielleicht ein Baumarkt, aber du kannst es halt online klicken und dir dann nachher abholen, wenn du in Berlin wohnst oder dir das auch zuschicken lassen.
Du musst da nicht ewig rumstehen.
Genau, ich mag das.
Ich weiß auf jeden Fall schon, wo ich morgen hingehe.
Nimm hier eigentlich den Mikrofon mit Salatgeknobsel auf.
Du kannst dich auch abschalten.
Ich kann dich auch abschalten, wenn du möchtest.
Soll ich dich mal abschalten?
Ich war jetzt übrigens auch neben diesem Modulo, hatte jetzt ja auch ein neuer Megastore noch aufgemacht.
Bei den Gitarren-Klimper-Laden.
Nein, nicht nur. Sie haben ja auch Studio und Recording und andere Sektionen.
Wenn da in der Ecke jetzt noch ein Turmalen aufmachen würde, würdest du da hinziehen, ne?
Ja, ein Turmalen wird da nicht auch machen. Ich meine, Just Music ist halt schon immer noch Just Music. Aber es ist doch deutlich besser geworden, habe ich den Eindruck, als es da so diese Kulturbrauerei-Laden und so weiter war. Also irgendwie, erstens gibt es ja endlich mal Platz so. Es ist nicht dieses kleine, so dieses Abstellkammer-Feeling, wo quasi schon zwei Leute nicht nebeneinander laufen können und so. Und irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl, dieses Personal ist dadurch auch so ein bisschen gechillter. Allerdings war es relativ leer. Es war die zwei Mal, wo ich jetzt schon da war, sehr wenig los, sozusagen. Und dadurch umso angenehmer. Und sie haben schon echt viel da aufgebaut, das finde ich schon echt gut. Man kann sehr viel ausprobieren. Also für die Audio-Nerds, die können dann gleich noch eine Ecke weiter latschen neben Modulor. Und dann sich auch noch Audio-Gadgets ausprobieren.
Also erst kauft man sich sozusagen die Taschen und dann das entsprechende Audio-Equipment, was man da rein stopft.
Ja, oder das Material, um sich seinen Rack selber zu bauen oder irgendwie.
Guten Tag, haben Sie etwas, was in meine Taschen passt?
Naja, also zumindest in der Gitarren-Abteilung waren sie sehr zuvor gekommen. Und da hab ich mich dann auch dazu entschlossen, gleich was zu kaufen. Und wie das in der Recording-Abteilung aussieht, weiß ich nicht. Aber ich hab da schon ganz viele große Mischpulte rumstehen sehen.
Mein Bedarf an Gerätekauf ist erstmal abgedeckt.
Insgesamt aber beide Läden, ich würde behaupten, mehr exciting als der Apple Store in Berlin. Obwohl ich da noch nicht drin war. Nö, hat noch keinen Bedarf.
Ich muss da jetzt mal hin, meine Reparatur abholen. Aber das ist so weit weg.
Was hast du denn reparieren lassen?
Völlig absurd. Vorher bin ich mal quer durch die Republik gefahren.
Das ist um die Ecke und jetzt kommst du nicht.
Achso, ist da noch eins von?
Ja genau, lass mal Bier trinken, das ist eine gute Idee. Ja, ich möchte auch.
Es ist Zeit für ein Bier.
Genau, das ist eine gute Idee. Wobei ich mal nicht von meiner Marta ausgetrunken habe. Die Brownies sind immer noch sehr lecker. Nein, das haben wir ja.
Es macht ja jetzt ein neuer Laden in Berlin auf.
Neuer Laden, was?
Microsoft macht jetzt auch einen Laden auf unter den Linden. Unter den Linden, Ecke Charlottenstraße. Also noch nicht mehr in der Friedrichstraße. Ja, die meinen angeblich, bei Heise war gestern so ein Artikel, dass da am Tag 140.000 Leute lang laufen. Das ist aber nur auch, wenn da gesperrt ist und die den Umweg da gehen müssen. Nee, 140.000 kann ich echt nicht glauben. Da geht doch kein Schwein lang, oder?
Unter den Linden.
Ja, aber die gehen alle von Friedrichstraße in Richtung Brandenburger Tor, aber die andere Richtung latschen auch wieder Leute. Ja klar, da rennt schon ein paar lang, aber 140.000?
Touristen.
C minus Touristen.
Ja, also da laufen Touristen lang. Ja, ja, was soll man dazu noch sagen? Apple geht natürlich da hin, wo gekauft wird. Microsoft wird da hin, wo geglotzt wird, weil die ja nicht ernsthaft davon ausgehen können.
Ja, die wollen ja auch nicht verkaufen, stand ja da, sie wollen neue Technik vorführen.
Ja, genau, so Showroom mit hier.
Hier ist der neue Daimler-Benz, die sind auch gleich ihre Lobby-Buden, weil es ist schön am Regierungsviertel, da macht man abends mal eine schöne Party.
Genau, näher an der Politik sein und so, damit die Beamten schneller mal zum Reistag rüber latschen können, mit einem dicken Koffer.
Nee, die machen da abends Party, die ganzen Dinge dort, alle wie sie da sind.
Ah, verstehe.
Ich war gerade neulich auch in so einem Laden, ich sag jetzt nicht von wem, war ein bisschen peinlich da, aber die machen das genau dazu, da haben die ihre Hauptstadt-Repräsentanz.
Naja, so wie man früher ne Webpräsenz hatte, ne?
Hast du in der Hauptstadt wat und da machst du gelegentlich deine Party und dann...
Andox-Stelle zum Politiker und dann Tisch trinken.
Die ganzen Auto-Gruf sitzen da, die Banken sitzen da, Mobilfunker sitzen da, die Microsoft sitzen da.
Ich werd jetzt erstmal Bier.
Ich isst erstmal ein Bier.
Ich würd auch kein Bier essen, aber mein Bier ist noch ungeöffnet. Wo hab ich denn den?
Kannst du das mit dieser Flasche öffnen?
Geh mal her.
Ich bin heute ganz zart.
Nie aufm Bau gearbeitet.
Ich auch nicht, aber ich kenne trotzdem mit auch alle möglichen... Bei uns in der Firma ist das die erste Lektion für zugezogene... Als Integrationsaufgabe, also wenn da irgendjemand kommt und die dann immer so... Wie? Was? Ohne Flasche öffnen, die Flasche öffnen und dann ist das die erste Lektion. Das ist der Integrationstest quasi.
Du bist Integrationsbeauftragter.
Ja. Ich bringe ihnen auch sehr sinnvolle Sachen bei. Letztens habe ich, also die gehen ja auch zum Deutschunterricht, das ist ein Schrank aus meiner Jugend sozusagen. Aber da lernen sie ja nur so formal Deutsch. Ich habe ihnen jetzt halt so Sachen beigebracht, wie man so einen Smalltalk startet, wie man fragt, ob jemand was zu kiffen hat und so weiter. Und dann letztens kam einer zu mir und meinte, ey gestern war ich auf einer Party und irgendwie habe ich den einfach gefragt, hast du was zu kiffen? Und er hat gesagt, ja lass mal einen bauen. Das hat perfekt funktioniert. Und dann dachte ich, ja so muss das auch mit dem Deutschunterricht laufen. Das hat mich ganz stolz gefühlt. Die Integration doch.
Ihr habt wieder was gelernt.
So, nun jetzt haben wir das Bier aufgemacht. Welche schwungvollen Themen greifen uns denn jetzt aus der nicht vorhandenen Themenkiste?
Wir haben jetzt mal mit Apple, WWDC, IOS, 7, Mavericks alle durch. Neue Hardware, MacBook Air, Mac Pro.
Nein, US-only. Genau, da können wir mal kurz drüber sprechen. Da dachte ich mir so, hä?
Verkaufsmusik. Jetzt zerreißen mich wieder die Leute. So was wie Spotify oder Dings in FM. Ne, eben nicht.
Weil da kannst du ja nicht sagen, ich will jetzt mal alles von David Bowie hören, sondern dann kannst du nur nach Stations suchen.
Der hat es zwar geschickt gesagt, er will eine Led Zeppelin Station machen, aber da kam ja kein Led Zeppelin. Aber danach nicht mehr.
Bei Spotify kannst du ja den Artist einfach...
Bei Last FM.
Last FM macht das halt, weil die das mit den Rechten nicht hinbekommen haben. Die hatten ja früher mal ein ordentliches Radio, wo du den Artist auch hören konntest.
Das Konzept ist, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, ist es so, du sagst was du gerne hörst. Und dann spielen wir die anderen Sachen, die du auch noch kaufen kannst.
Also das ist ja so ein Schrott. Ich meine, das geht doch nicht.
Leute werden das benutzen und kaufen.
Aber das Lied jetzt nicht immer drunter. Das streamt doch nur, oder?
Ich hab mir jetzt mal kürzlich so ein bisschen reingefahren, wie das mit dieser Musikindustrie eigentlich funktioniert. Ich hab's schon in meinem anderen Podcast erwähnt, aber da hören ja noch nicht so viele zu.
Apropos bist du eigentlich schon GEMA-Mitglied?
Nee, werde ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht werden. Aber wen mal interessiert, wie schlimm das eigentlich mit der Musikindustrie ist, und wer mal so ein bisschen die Entwicklungen so wissen will, wie das alles so abgelaufen ist, da gibt's ein Buch, das heißt Appetite for Self Destruction. Kann ich mal den Link hier kurz in den Chat werfen, weil das ist wirklich unfassbar. Ich pack's euch mal hier rein, weil bei Appetite for Self Destruction da gibt's auch eine Episode Steve Jobs. Und die ist halt echt interessant auch, weil es geht ja erstmal kapitelweise darum, was die Musikindustrie in ihrer Geschichte alles so verkackt hat. Und im Prinzip ist das so eine Welle, also es geht so ein bisschen auf, dann kommt wieder der Absturz, neues Medium, was auch immer, sie haben es verkackt. Und dann geht die nächste Welle hoch, sie haben es endlich begriffen, wie es funktioniert, geht höher als vorher, Crash um so dolle. CD war jetzt sozusagen der größte Peak aller Zeiten ever, das war so das, wo eben Rockstars, Hotelzimmer, Cokes, Koffer, der ganze Kram, also wirklich, wo es absurd wurde und dementsprechend hart ist der Crash halt jetzt sozusagen. Und da gibt es halt so eine Episode in dem Buch, wo die Labels total am Ende sind. Sie haben es irgendwie mit dem Internet verpasst, Napster und so, da steht auch drin, wie zum Beispiel, sie versucht haben alle Napster noch so als in den legalen Bands zu ziehen und da ist auch sehr viel über Napster, wie das alles hinter den Kulissen lief drin. Und dann sind sie halt alle total verzweifelt, sie haben es alle nicht verstanden, dann kommt halt die Episode, Steve Jobs hat ein Meeting und die ganzen großen Bosse von den Plattenlabels sitzen in einem Raum und er zeigt ihnen so den iTunes Store. Aber vorher, den iTunes Store zeigt, rantet er sie eine halbe Stunde lang vor. Da steht halt wirklich so, der eine Executive schreibt halt so seine Erinnerungen an dieses Meeting und so, sie sitzen alle und dann kommt Steve Jobs und er kann sich nur dran erinnern, dass er eine halbe Stunde lang angeschrien wird von Steve Jobs, wie sie es alle nicht verstehen. Also, how we all not getting it, oder irgendwie so. Und irgendwie gucken die sich die ganze Zeit an, was ist das jetzt hier? Sind wir jetzt hierher gekommen uns mal eine halbe Stunde voll raten zu lassen? Und dann ist halt irgendwann fertig der Steve und dann meint halt einer, ich weiß nicht von welchem Label, meint er halt so, ja, ja, darum sitzt mehr. Wir brauchen Hilfe, wir können es nicht selber machen. Wir haben keine Ahnung, wie wir es machen. Wir haben keine Ahnung, wie wir Leute anstellen, die uns helfen können. Wir haben einfach keine Ahnung, hilf uns. Und dann gibt es halt diesen iTunes Store und dann sitzen die das erste Mal davor, das steht so richtig schön beschrieben, und dann so ein älterer Executive so, ah, so muss das sein. Das sieht ja aus wie ein Plattenladen und Covers und man kann suchen, man kann kaufen. Und sie einigen sich halt alle auf diesen einen Dollar pro Song-Dings und so weiter. Und dann steht halt auch so schön beschrieben, wie so erst nach und nach raffen, dass es für sie eigentlich ein schlechter Deal ist. Zum einen, weil Apple 30% davon abzweigt und zum anderen, weil Apple das eigentlich benutzt, um den... Was?
Im App-Store sind es 30%.
Nee, ich glaube nicht. Egal, sie kriegen was ab und dann benutzen sie das ja eigentlich, um mit ihren iPods Kohle zu machen, weil sie jetzt den Content haben und kriegen halt eine viel krassere Marge. Und dann ist so richtig schön so dieser Moment, wo sie so checken, ey, scheiße, ey, wir haben eigentlich voll den doofen Deal. Aber sie haben es halt selber auch nicht anders hinbekommen. Also Appetite for Self Destruction ist da echt aufschlussreich. Und das andere Buch, falls irgendjemand mal interessiert, wie schlimm es mit der Musikindustrie ist und wie scheiße man als Artist heutzutage dran ist, wenn man das an dir unterschreibt, da gibt es so ein Buch All you need to know about the music business. Und das ist auch wirklich ein extrem cool geschriebenes Buch.
Na du willst immer noch Musiker werden?
Also so nicht. Echt die Stimme der Jugend.
Ja, da gibt es auch immer diese Stelle, wo er sagt, ich wollte doch Musiker werden.
Bei diesem All you need to know about the music business da wird dann immer vorgerechnet, was du mit so einem Plattenvertrag verdienst. Und wie krass das eigentlich ist. So ein Plattenlabel, nur als kurze Anekdote, die verdiefert 85% von den Einnahmen. Und er kriegt 15%, aber er kriegt gar nicht die 15%, weil von den 15%, die er kriegen würde, muss er die ganzen Produktionskosten und den Vorschüsse selber sozusagen abbezahlen. Also ein ist dann so irgendwas mit unter 10% letztendlich. Da steht halt wirklich im kleinsten Detail alle komischen Knebel-Deals, die sie halt nach und nach so nachgeschraubt haben drin. Das ist wirklich furchtbar. Weil man vorher schon dachte, die verstehen das mit dem Internet nicht. Danach weiß man, dass es wirklich so ist.
Das ist jetzt aber auch eine Industrie, der ich jetzt nicht sonderlich nachweine. Aus besagten Gründen.
Man muss es halt auch so sehen, die haben ja so ein Business-Modell wie Venture-Kapitalisten. Also ein Artist von 10, spielt die Kohle von 9 gefailten Artists rein. Also 9 von 10 Artists bringen ihr Investment nicht mehr rein. Und einer von 10 bezahlt für alle anderen. Und das bedeutet im Umkehrschluss aber auch, dass zum Beispiel eine Lady Gaga oder was auch immer, die bezahlen auch für ganz viele kleine Bands, die du vielleicht als den Soundtrack deines Lebens schon aufgenommen hast, die nie kommerziellen Erfolg hatten, aber die halt sozusagen dieses eine Album machen durften.
Willkommen auf meinem Planeten, hier gibt es das Internet. Leider gibst du dem Internet auch noch eine GEMA, wenn man letztere oder wie auch immer sie heißen mag in dem jeweiligen Land.
Aber die Musik im Internet gibt es ja auch nur, weil die irgendjemand vorher produziert hat.
Du sagst ja nicht, dass die niemand produzieren soll, aber man kann durchaus ein paar Sachen da auch weglassen. Da gibt es schon, wie du ja selber sagst, auch massive Fehlentwicklung.
Jaja, also das ist nochmal eine ganz andere Thematik, aber die beiden Bücher kann ich mal empfehlen. So, kleiner Abschweifer ins musikalische Thema. So, seid ihr noch dabei?
Ja, ich konnte da jetzt gerade nicht so viel zu beitragen, aber...
So, jetzt willst du schnell Ayverk im Grunde im Boden reden?
Es gibt da ja nicht sehr viel zu berichten. Das ist ja genau das Furchtbare. Ich meine, jetzt dürften auch alle gerne auf mich auf dem Finger zeigen, weil irgendwie, was, du benutzt Ayverk? Ja, ich benutze Ayverk.
Das finde ich auch echt tatsächlich ein bisschen schockierend.
Wobei ich... Ja, also sagen wir mal so, ich weiß, das hat auch ein bisschen was mit meiner Faulheit zu tun, aber es hat auch ein bisschen was mit meiner Abneigung gegen Excel zu tun. Und abgesehen davon, dass es furchtbar langsam ist, finde ich ja Numbers an sich ganz gut. Aber es ist furchtbar langsam. Und es ist auch nicht schneller geworden durch den Zuwachs an Computing-Power, den wir in den letzten Jahren erlebt haben. Das heißt, diese 2009er-Variante, muss ich mal klar machen, die aktuelle Ayverk-Version heißt 09. Für 2009, das ist vier Jahre alt. Und alle Updates, die es seitdem gab, waren immer nur so meiner mit Jahr, jetzt ja auch mit iCloud. Und ich dachte schon, Leute, könnt ihr nicht endlich mal was vorstellen? Wie wär's denn mal mit was Besserem? Schneller, mehr Chores, irgendwie, hallo, ihr habt doch diese ganze Technologie.
Ja, aber mehr Chores, ey, für eine Tabellenkalkulation, das kann doch auch, also, ja, okay, erzähl weiter.
Also ich mein, da fragt man sich wirklich, why? Und alles, was sie vorstellen, ist, ja, jetzt gibt's das auch in iCloud. Surprise. Ja, und jetzt kannst du das in deinem scheiß Webbrowser, auf deinem scheiß Windows auch irgendwie editieren. Ja, so, genau, keine Ankündigung, was jetzt irgendwie neu ist, oder ob es überhaupt noch eine Version gibt, die man irgendwie auf dem Computer installieren kann. Vielleicht nur noch auf dem Browser arbeitet. Ich meine, ich finde das ja bemerkenswert, was sie da mittlerweile im Browser schaffen.
Aber, ja.
Also Keynote finde ich ja immer noch geil. Also Keynote könnte zwar auch mal wieder ein Major-Update gebrauchen. Ich finde es sehr schade, dass sie an Präsentationen nichts verbessert haben. Ich finde, es gibt eine Menge zu verbessern.
Da gibt es keinen mehr, der neue Features fordert.
Ich meine, habt ihr mal mit Keynote was gemacht? Habt ihr auch mal vorher mit Powerpoint oder sowas was gemacht? Und würdest du mir zustimmen, dass Keynote schon eine deutliche Verbesserung gegenüber Powerpoint ist? Und jetzt hätte ich gerne was, was eine deutliche Verbesserung gegenüber Keynote ist, weil einfach manche Sachen gehen da einfach noch viel zu schwer. Ich finde zum Beispiel auch so diese Art und Weise, wie du mit Mastern so umgehst, ist einfach schwierig. Man muss halt immer wieder applyen.
Also ähnlich wie das... Also bei Apple gibt es ja so ein paar Schwachpunkte. Apple und das Internet ist so ein Schwachpunkt. Und Apple und so Publishing-Work-Software. Also wir erinnern uns noch so an Classic Mac OS, Klares Works und wie das nicht alles hieß. Apple Works, iWorks, hat schon auch so Licht, aber auch ganz, ganz, ganz viel Schatten. Und jetzt ist es so, dass sie ihre beiden Schwachstellen Internet und Workgroup-Software kombinieren wollen. Und da wird es bei mir... Also da ist echt... Entweder das Universum implodiert oder sie schaffen es tatsächlich, irgendwas Sinnvolles zu machen.
Ich glaube, ich habe das noch gar nicht gesehen.
Aber ich habe echt ein echt schlechtes Gefühl dabei. Also für mich persönlich, als ich das gehört habe, dachte ich, ok, jetzt kann ich Keynote auch nicht mehr benutzen.
Vielleicht kriegst du sogar neue Ikels. Wer soll das benutzen?
Also ich meine, du willst ja auch...
Ok, du kannst jetzt auf eine Präsentation gehen, wo zu deiner völligen Überraschung vorne ein Windows-PC steht und sie dir deine Apple nicht anschließen lassen. Und dann kannst du deine Keynote-Präsentationen auch auf dem Windows-PC in einen Browser vorführen. Oder auch nicht, vermutlich. Weil dieser Browser im Speziellen wahrscheinlich wieder nicht supported sein wird. Aber, ähm, ich meine, da, wer braucht sowas?
Also ich will doch nicht, zum Beispiel bei Kino ist es halt auch so, du willst mal ein Video reinstecken oder willst man Sound reinstecken, dann musst du das uploaden oder wie soll das gehen? Und dann hast du auf der Conf irgendwie spontan kein Netz und dann kannst du die auch irgendwie exportieren oder so.
Ich frage mich, wie viele Leute iWork tatsächlich benutzen und vor allem auf dem iPad. Ich meine, diese Programme sind immer in der Top 10, was so Most Sold Apps laut Apple, natürlich. Also sind totale Best Seller. Ob sie auch gut benutzt werden, weiß ich nicht, aber es ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass es eine Alternative gäbe. In diesem ganzen iPad-Universum ist halt Microsoft de facto nicht da.
Ja, gibt es keine Offices für das iPad?
Nee, es wird zwar gemunkelt, dass es jetzt dann bald mal endlich mal eins gibt, aber eigentlich ist der Zug...
War da nicht was?...
schon längst abgefahren.
Gerade erst vor kurzem.
Ja, gerade erst vor kurzem ist wieder irgendwas in Aussicht gestellt worden, aber ich glaube, dass Vinz da ist. Und bisher ist, glaube ich, noch nichts da. Klaut als Irrweg. Naja, also ein paar Sachen finde ich ja ganz gut. Pages finde ich von seinen Abstraktionen her weitgehend gescheitert. Das macht viele Dinge nicht unbedingt sehr viel einfacher. Und ich würde immer noch gerne mal die Energie aufbringen, mal ein paar von diesen anderen Textprogrammen, die es so auf dem Mac gibt, mal richtig durchzutesten. Vor allem sowas wie Mellel oder so. Mellel. Mellel. Ja, Mellel ist so eine israelische Company, die sind schon ziemlich lange dabei. Die sind jetzt seit fünf, sechs Jahren, glaube ich, mit ihrem Produkt am Start und machen halt so einen Lean-Word-Processor und bauen da irgendwie eine Menge Features ein. Und ich hab's dann irgendwann mal gecheckt und zu dem Zeitpunkt hat es ein paar Sachen, die mir ganz wichtig waren, nicht gehabt und später kam das irgendwie, aber ich hab's seitdem nie wieder geschafft.
Wie schreibst du denn das Ding?
Mellel, also M-E-L-L-E-L. Und im Bereich Tabellenkalkulation ist mir schon klar, dass Excel eine gut abgehangene Software ist. Aber es ist auch so eine User-Interface-Katastrophe für mich immer gewesen. Ich wollte das nicht. Und bei Numbers gefiel mir so vom Start weg ein paar Sachen sehr gut. Also, dass zum Beispiel so Spreadsheets nicht unendlich sind. Ich hab jetzt ein Spreadsheet, das hat genau 10 Spalten und es hat irgendwie 15 Rows.
Dann kannst du auch mehrere Stücke Karo-Papier auf einem haben. Du kannst mehrere Tabellen auf einem Blatt drauf haben.
Ja, und Layout ist da gleich irgendwie mit drin und so. Also vieles fand ich da irgendwie sehr gut. Aber was halt einfach gar nicht geht bei diesen Numbers, ist, dass es einfach furchtbar langsam ist. Also lad da mal ein paar Daten rein und das Ding quält sich wie wirklich ein unter Drogen stehender, am Bein verwundeter Dinosaurier. Ja, es ist unfassbar.
Und ich muss sagen, ich hab jetzt ja in der Firma, neben unseren Data Analysts und Business Intelligence Guys, mal ein bisschen gesessen und geguckt, was die so mit diesem Excel anstellen. Und egal, ob Excel auf Windows oder sogar Excel auf Mac, was die aber nicht so geil finden, weil es nicht so schnell auch auf Mac ist wie auf Windows, aber immer noch tausendmal perfomantan... Also was so mit diesem Excel auch geht, da sieht auch Numbers einfach featuretechnisch, also Layout und so endliche Tabellen, das ist ja das letzte Feature, worauf die Number-Cruncher so richtig Wert legen. Also das zieht dem Numbers halt auch so richtig die Hosen aus, was so Features und Datenkorrelationen und so ein Kram hat.
Viele Leute, die Excel benutzen, also das, was ich so erlebe, benutzen das einfach nur als große Tabellenblatt für Text.
Ja, ne, die...
Für welche Daten, die sie da reinfüllen. Also die wenigsten Leute rechnen wirklich wie Tier da drin rum.
Ja, aber es gibt die Leute und die kannst du halt numbers überhaupt nicht anbieten.
Nein, das kann ja auch keine Visual-Basic-Marcos machen.
Wobei, ich finde ja Leute, die das wirklich richtig machen, die sollten eigentlich eher mit Mathematiker arbeiten.
Ja, das ist so der nächste Schritt, ja. Ach ja, Mathematiker ist auch immer wieder so ein Tool, da wünschte ich, ich wäre irgendwie...
Ich wünschte auch, ich würde was verstehen von Mathematik.
Ja, so manchmal hätte ich so echt Bock drauf, wenn ich jemanden damit rumhandchen sehe und der weiß, was er tut. Das ist irgendwie so, da kommt so der Magic Sparkle oder der Lead Sparkle, kommt so von oben runter geregnet. Also bei Artcom, da hat der eine ja für so eine kinetische Installation, hat der mit Mathematiker die Steppermotoren, Ansteuerung, Formeln... Das hat der so mit Mathematiker da so in so einem Dings ausgerechnet und konnte dann so an so einem Slider drehen und hat sich das 3D-Modell dann entsprechen. Oh, das war... Da hab ich null Ahnung, wie man das tut und wo man da anfängt.
Da steht man dann genauso daneben wie früher, die Leute immer neben uns standen, weil wir Computer benutzen konnten. Und jetzt sind wir so eigentlich ganz normaler digitaler Pöbel. Und man hätte schon längst auf Mathematiker oder andere abgefahrene Scheißumsatte müssen.
Aber es gibt halt auch so eine Problemnische, wo man da...
Ja, also ich wollte nie behaupten und werde das auch nicht tun, dass Numbers in irgendeiner Form mit Konkurrenz zu Excel stehen, aber weil ich das eben nicht so nutze, ich wollt einfach nur was tiny, was irgendwie gut funktioniert und was mit überschaubaren Datenmengen irgendwie klar kommt. Aber dieses Numbers, das kommt auch mit überschaubaren Datenmengen nicht klar. Das hätte ich jetzt auch lieber selbst ausgerechnet. Was sehr nett ist, sie haben dieses Kategorie-Feature. Du kannst halt so Tabellen nach bestimmten Wertegruppen zusammenklappen. Was weiß ich, wenn du da irgendwo so einen Datumsverlauf hast, kannst du sagen, sortier mir das mal nicht nur nach Datum, sondern klapp's mir auch zusammen. Und dann kannst du sagen, hier will ich ein Jahr irgendwie ausklappen. Dann benutzt du deine Tabelle wie eine Outline. Das benutze ich eigentlich am laufenden Meter. Das finde ich super, aber es ist einfach sagenhaft langsam. Also es ist wirklich so unfassbar langsam. Das kann man überhaupt nicht glauben, wie langsam das ist. Auf diesem heißen Mac Pro, wirklich ein Geschoss. Eine Liste, wo vielleicht so fünf Bildschirmsalten Text drinsteht oder Zahlen und Datum. Und dann sage ich, jetzt schalte mal um in diesen Kategorieview. Und dann braucht das Ding 20, 30 Sekunden. Sekunden! Aber Terra-Milliarden, Billionen Instruktionen, die da abgeführt werden. Und das Ding lutscht sich die ganze Zeit einfach nur irgendwie am Bit.
Ich weiß nicht, was er macht.
Ist mir vollkommen unklar.
Ist dir denn die CPU dabei am Anschlag? Noch nicht mehr, oder?
Ja klar, 100 Prozent.
Einen Kern, genau.
Einen Kern.
Der lutscht sich am Fließkomma. Es lockert die Ranschmuskulatur.
Und dann vergehen vier Jahre, und dann trauen die sich da auf die Bühne zu gehen und sagen so, jetzt bauen wir doch noch ein iCloud an.
Ja ich mein, ich hab jetzt grad nochmal auf die iWork-Seite geschaut und da steht zwar iWork for iCloud, aber ganz oben ist einmal iWork for Mac, iWork for iOS und iWork for Cloud. Und iWork for Cloud ist dann so ein PC mit Browser auf. Und sie reden dann zwar auf der ganzen Seite nur von dem Cloud-Ding, aber sie sagen jetzt auch nicht explizit, dass es iWork for Mac nicht mehr gibt.
Nein, das gibt's nach wie vor. Das haben sie ja auch gedemo'ed. Und irgendwie sah es auch so aus, als ob das eine oder andere neue Feature da dabei sein könnte. Aber sie haben halt nichts konkret angesprochen. Es steht halt immer noch Pages 09, Numbers 09, Keynote 09, was?
Was erlaube? Hallo? Also, ich bin auch echt gespannt. Also eigentlich das Tollste, was sie ja jemals gemacht haben mit diesem iWork ist, die Programme einzeln in den App Store zu stellen, dass man halt wirklich nur das Keynote dann sich besorgen konnte, wenn man eine Präsentation machen wollte und von den Pages und dem Numbers nie was sehen musste. Insofern, von mir aus könnten sie auch Numbers und Pages weglassen und sich nur noch auf das Keynote berufen haben.
Nein, das ist schon total sinnvoll. Das ist wirklich total sinnvoll. Und es wäre auch schön, wenn sie mal das mit der Textverarbeitung richtig hinbekommen hätten. Aber haben sie leider mit Pages nicht hinbekommen.
Ja, und das ist halt, wie ich schon sagte, seit ich einen Mac hab, gibt es von Apple oder von so, ich weiß nicht, Clarice war ja irgendwie so an Apple angedockt. Ja, er hatte Apple. Gab es irgendwie immer so eine komische Office-Alternativ-Suite. Und seitdem ich Apple benutze, und das ist seit 1995, ist diese Software Schrott. Also ja, es ist vielleicht irgendwie ein bisschen ansehnlicher als Microsoft Office, aber im Wesentlichen unbrauchbar. Also mit Keynote haben sie eine Ausnahme geschaffen, aber ansonsten, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Also das ist halt kein Pro-Tool.
Genau, ich hätte das ganz gerne mal in Pro.
Genau das ist es eigentlich. Alles hätte ich gerne in Pro.
Aber wenn jetzt alles was Pro ist, endet wie der Mac Pro, weiß ich nicht. Ja, ich hätte auch gerne mal mit iTunes Pro schon eine Menge anfangen können.
Quicktime Pro, Mail Pro, iPhone Pro. Ja, da gibt es schon so einiges, was da Pro sein könnte und nicht Pro ist. Das stimmt.
Thunderbolt Kabel Pro. So, was noch?
Ich weiß nicht, haben wir noch Themen?
Clemens, du warst so still beim World of Warcraft spielen. Was hast du denn in der Zwischenzeit noch für?
Ich hab jetzt in den letzten 14 Tagen zwischendurch einfach nochmal hier gearbeitet und so Zeug gemacht und mich rumgeärgert, wieder mit Telekomikern und so.
Ich hab heute was getwittert, besser gesagt.
Dann schalt mal gleich den Link zum Tweet, dann faithen wir den alle und retweeten um die Wette.
Ich hab ja nur was retweeted. Und da hat da einer recherchiert, ich weiß auch gar nicht, wie echt das ist, aber ich denke schon, über dieses Tool AdBlock Plus, das hast du auch gelesen. Dieses Werbenetzwerk, was irgendwie dahintersteht und was das alles für eine große Abzocke ist und so. Und ich will jetzt gar nicht so eine lange Rede halten, ihr könnt ja meinen letzten Tweet oder diesen Blogartikel von, wie hieß der Laden?
Mobilegeeks Sascha Pallenberg hat den zusammen recherchiert, den Artikel.
Genau, den sollte man mal direkt selber lesen und sich dann sein eigenes Bild machen und dementsprechend entscheiden.
Ja gut, aber die Story kann man ja schon mal zusammenfassen, also es gibt halt diesen Adblock, Adblock Plus, nicht zu verwechseln mit Adblock.
Haben überhaupt gar nichts miteinander zu tun, richtig? Okay, das ist schon mal wichtig.
Es gibt Adblock und es gibt Adblock Plus und der ist aber auch recht populär bei Chrome und wohl auch den noch Firefox. Den gibt's gar nicht für Safari, ne?
Ich glaub nicht.
Und naja, das ist halt nach vorne, ist das irgendwie ein Adblocker und tut sozusagen das und hat aber so merkwürdige Ja, es gibt so faire Werbung. Und die zeigen wir dann trotzdem an. Und dahinter steckt irgendwie hier eine deutsche GmbH, die offensichtlich Deals haben, wiederum mit anderen Firmen. Da steckt irgendwie United Internet da irgendwie drin mit irgendwie 1&1 und GMX und so. Und deren Server stehen dann halt auch da in den Whitelists drin. Und kurzum, das sieht einfach alles nicht fein aus. Das zieht da auch weite Kreise, auch mit so anderen Diensten, die so auch so Affiliate Link Geschichten machen. Also das ist wirklich krass. Und ja, sollte man irgendwie nicht nehmen. Also wenn ihr Adblock Plus habt, dann geht doch lieber auf Adblock. Das kann ich nur empfehlen. Funktioniert eigentlich auch vollkommen ausreichend. Es war wohl auch mal nur so eine Person, die Adblock Plus geschrieben hat. Und dann hat er das irgendwie so hintenrum an diese Bude da verscheuert. Haarsträumt. Sonst ist eigentlich nichts passiert, oder? Haben wir uns das verpasst?
Nö.
Gab noch viel Diskussion, irgendwie...
Prison gab's. Temporal gab's.
Ja, hast du dich da irgendwie mit beschäftigt?
Nee, ich hab mich damit nicht so beschäftigt, ich tue nicht genügend andere Leute, sondern beschäftige mich halt mit dem...
Haben sie dich auch gefragt?
Mit dem Ausfall, nee, bisher nicht. Hab ich meinen Usern auch geschrieben, die bei mir da Mail haben und so. Aber es gibt natürlich sehr viele Reaktionen wieder und sehr viel Blödsinn, was sich wieder im Netz rumtreibt. Wieder, da sind wir da, hat jemand gerufen, können wir bitte alle Affen hochspringen und mal Ja schreien, hier schreien? Und das haben natürlich auch wieder viele gemacht. Aber da gibt's jetzt kleine Details zu, aber damit hab ich mich so ein bisschen befasst und natürlich auch noch mal geguckt, wie ich jetzt meinen normalen Usern nochmal die Krypto nochmal sozusagen ein bisschen näher bringe. Das ist ja eigentlich relativ easy. Das Problem ist, dass das halt, also die Tools, gerade auf dem Mac, die Tools sind alle da. Du musst nicht irgendwas installieren. Du kannst mit dem normalen, mit einem frisch installierten OS X, sind alle drauf, um dir selber ein Zertifikat zu generieren und du musst dir das für S-Mime auch nicht mal unterschreiben lassen. Du kannst das einfach, das funktioniert ja so, wenn du das normale Apple Mail benutzt und der selber ein Zertifikat mit benutzt. Jeder, dem du schickst, der nimmt das erstmal auf, übrigens in seinem normalen Adressbuch auch drin. Das siehst du denn, da ist so ein Häkchen damit drin. Dein eigener Private Key, ja, aber die anderen Zertifikate von anderen Leuten, die du einsammelst, schreibt das sich glanlos ins Adressbuch rein.
Nee, die sind auch in der Keychain, deswegen werden sie an der Keychain auch immer mehr, weil jeder Zert, was über eine Mail ankommt, wächst da. Musst du mal reingucken.
Ja, nicht Zert, das von anderen Usern oder so, das sehe ich bisher bis im Adressbuch, das sehe ich nicht in der Keychain, aber vielleicht habe ich jetzt auch nicht danach hier so.
Du siehst es vielleicht nicht im Adressbuch, aber es ist in der Keychain.
Das braucht da nicht hin, das ist nämlich öffentlich. Der Public Key von anderen ist öffentlich, das muss ich nicht in der Keychain erklären. Ich kann ja mal gucken, ob ich die da finde, von Leuten, die...
Dass man Krypto und Zeug und so machen kann, ist schon alles klar, aber ist nicht die Frage, ob nicht Apple zum Beispiel sowieso der NSA ein Hintertürchen in meinen Rechner rein hat und wenn sie gucken wollen, sie sowieso kommen und sich meine Keys von meinem Rechner holen?
Ja, da musst du jetzt mal Apple fragen, wie gut die Keychain ist.
Ja, Apple hat ja da so ein Statement rausgegeben und die haben gesagt, sie haben da Würsten von nichts und so.
Ja, das ist auch so ein Thema, wo es jetzt darum ging, wegen iMessage. Da macht ja auch so die Runde mit dem iMessage.
Hat ja Apple gesagt, sie machen da End-to-End. Das heißt, sie hätten gar keine Möglichkeit, da unterwegs zu gucken.
Aber angesichts der Tatsache für Blödsinnhalte, weil du kannst ja einfach ein neues Gerät dir installieren und gibst dann dort deine Apple ID ein mit dem Password, was Apple weiß und zurücksetzen kann, zumindestens auch. Und dann hat dieses Gerät Zugriff auf deine iMessages. Das heißt, es geht einmal durch Apple durch.
Das kann man aber technisch erklären. Das ist ein neues Device, er stellt ein neues Public-Private-Pärchen, schickt den Public-Anteil hoch, der wird zu den anderen Geräten weitervermittelt und ab dann wird dieses Gerät auch mit verschlüsselt. So könnte ich es mir erklären.
Und deswegen siehst du auch die alten Nachrichten? Du siehst nämlich die alten Nachrichten.
Erst ab dann, oder?
Nee, du siehst doch die alten.
Was? Nee, bei mir kam man nur...
Was sich so rumtreibt, mir ist auch nicht dieser Zeitraum ganz klar. Also manchmal, du siehst es... Zum Beispiel, ich hab ein altes iPad, ich hab ein iPad 1 noch. Dann hab ich neulich nach einem Monat da wieder in Betrieb genommen. Und mach das an. Und da kullern jede Menge iMessages rein.
iMessage ist richtig... iMessage von iPhone, iMessage...
Ja, oder von Rechner nach iPhone. Diverse Conversationen, diverse alte iMessage-Conversationen hängen ja da drin rum im System noch. Ja, das mag vielleicht durchaus sein, dass du dir jetzt nicht die iMessages von vor einem Jahr oder so was da noch reindrückst, aber jedenfalls tummeln die sich ja da noch rum im System. Das heißt, du müsstest jetzt wirklich mal probieren. Ihr könnt ja mal hingehen, ihr wolltet das iPad jetzt eh mal löschen, ich lösche komplett neu, richtig mal wieder neu ein und gucke mal, dass ich mich da dann wieder neu anmelde, aber wenn da wieder die alten Nachrichten rauskulern, dann soll mir Apple nicht erzählen, dass er das alles super toll verschlüsselt hat, dass das keiner wissen kann. Ich glaube schon, dass sie das Ende zu Ende vielleicht machen. Da spricht ja nichts dagegen, aber sie haben halt den Key. Und du kannst halt jeder, der sozusagen an die Apple-ID dran kann, und Apple kann an die Apple-ID dran, kann auch auf diese Nachrichten dazugreifen. Ja, doch.
Wir haben einfach keine Ahnung. Nur mal so zur Begriffsklärung. Wir reden jetzt nur und ausschließlich von iMessage, der SMS-Replacement-Dienst, den sie mit iOS eingeführt haben und der jetzt in der Messages-App auch unterstützt wird seit Mountain Line.
Genau.
So, und du meinst, sie speichern diese Nachrichten längere Zeit auf Servern? Wenn ich da was verschicke und das wird als zugestellt markiert, dann verweilt das da noch auf Servern?
Im Vergleich zu Skype ist es ja so, dass der Peer-to-Peer. Wenn sich zwei Leute Nachrichten zuschreiben und immer nur einer von beiden ist online, der andere in dem Moment gerade nicht, kann das monatelang so gehen und die sehen ihre Nachrichten nicht. Bei iMessage ist es so, ich hab's jetzt nicht verifiziert, indem ich jetzt gegenseitig Geräte ausgeschaltet habe oder so. Aber du kannst durchaus Nachrichten an jemanden schreiben, der gerade nicht online ist und selber offline gehen. Und wenn der online geht, dann kriegt er die Nachrichten. Wir können das ausprobieren.
Also ich hab gerade bei iMessage geguckt und da sind nur die drin, als wo ich das gestartet hab.
Was soll ich machen?
Geh mal offline mit deinem Telefon, geh mal in Flugmodus.
Meinem Telefon?
Achso, du hast ja natürlich wieder 50 iMessages, wie weißt du es?
Ich kann es mir jetzt gerade nicht so richtig überblicken.
Ist hier jemand, der bloß einen iMessage-Think hat?
Was heißt eins?
Also ich hab's da und da, aber da ist aus. Da ist aus? Also nur iPhone ist doch toll. Dann kannst du mal bei deinem iPhone in Flugmodus gehen.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall so, dass du ja noch nachträgliche Konversationen, die schon gelaufen sind, noch reingesyncht kriegst.
Das ist ja kein Problem. Also Apple, ich verspiel mal jetzt hier Devil's Advocate. Ich tu mal so machen, als wenn es auch normalen Grund hätte. Kann ja schon sein, dass Apple das verschlüsselte Zeug noch zwischenspeichert. Dagegen ist ja nichts zu sagen. So, Flugmodus ist an jetzt hier.
So, jetzt schick ich dir ne iMessage. Die wird erwartungsgemäß hoffentlich nicht ausgeliefert. Ja, wird sie auch nicht. So, hängt jetzt irgendwo rum.
Ja, die liegt jetzt verschlüsselt bei Apple, sag ich.
Okay, so, jetzt geh ich offline mit meinem Telefon.
Also...
Um Peer-to-Peer auszuschließen. Ja, ich geh jetzt Airplane-Modus. So, bin jetzt weg vom Fenster. Jetzt geh du wieder online, guck, ob die Nachricht dann kommt.
Naja, jetzt wird Apple die Nachricht weiterleiten.
Ja, es ist halt ein Store-and-Forward-System. Es ist kein Peer-to-Peer-System wie Skype, sondern es ist halt Store-and-Forward.
Ja, ist aber auch nicht...
Probier doch mal aus.
Also geht ja bei end-to-end.
Hast du sie jetzt bekommen oder nicht?
Also, das heißt, die Lunge teilt auf einen Jabber-Server oder so was bei Apple rum.
Okay, aber die Behauptung von Apple ist jetzt, dass diese Nachricht verschlüsselt ist.
End-to-end.
Und dazu müsste ja dein Telefon den Schlüssel von Dennis in dem Moment auch bekommen haben. Das tut er wahrscheinlich in dem Moment, wo...
Das Ding blau wird.
Das Ding blau wird und er sieht, okay, ist iMessage, und dann kriegt er quasi den Public Key, verschlüsselt das, schiebt es hin, und dann liegt es da rum, und dieser Key bezieht sich auf was?
Auf den Account oder auf das Gerät? Auf den Account. Die spannende Frage wäre jetzt gewesen, wenn Dennis sein Telefon ausgelassen hätte und ein neues Gerät mit iMessage registriert. Also sich ein neues Gerät irgendwo schnappt und sagt, hier ist meine iCloud-ID oder sowas, wenn da meine Nachricht angekommen wäre.
Das würde bedeuten, dass es nichts mit dem Geräte-Key zu tun hat. Oder mit einem auf dem Gerät erzeugten Key.
Ja, logisch.
Aber wenn es halt an dem Account hängt, dann wäre das ja...
Wie gesagt, wir können jetzt ein bisschen hin und her spekulieren. Man muss es wirklich einfach mal ausprobieren.
Ich finde es interessant, mal auszuloten, was man jetzt eigentlich mal überprüfen müsste. Da können sich ja auch mal ein paar andere Leute noch mit einbringen bei dem Spiel, um ein bisschen besser zu verstehen, was da ist.
Also nochmal Aufgabe ist, du schickst eine ab.
Aber an Apple wollte jetzt an diese Nachricht rankommen. Denn es hätte sein Gerät nie eingeschaltet. Wir können jetzt davon ausgehen, dass die Nachricht vielleicht schon wieder gelöscht ist.
Bei Apple.
Nee, die ist nicht gelöscht. Die kriegst du noch auf andere Geräte. Genau. Wenn er seinen Messages auf dem Mac auch noch anmacht, dann kriegt er es ja auch noch.
Dann mach ich jetzt mal hier den Flugmodus an. Das heißt, von hier kann er das schon mal nicht mehr anfordern.
Und du meldest jetzt mal deinen Mac an.
Du musstest das aber theoretisch auch machen, falls sie bei dir auch nicht.
Genau, ich bin noch im Flugmodus. Also bei mir ist auch...
Also so richtiges Erinnerung habe, dann kommt hier die gar nicht, weil das...
weil die schon abgeholt ist oder was?
Nee, nee, nee, du siehst ja die Alten. Sie sieht mich nicht mehr als neu da. Sie wird nicht mehr als neu gefleckt, aber du siehst ja die Alten immer noch.
Noch nicht.
Das hab ich auch nicht so in Erinnerung, dass du die Alten siehst. Das sehe ich nicht nach. Der zeigt mir auf iMessages...
Ich krieg die Alten auch.
Ist da irgendwie ein Settings was machen?
Aber es ist halt so ein bisschen eratisch. Also es ist auch irgendwie nicht immer so. Das ist ja auch so dieses Problem, was ich zum Beispiel habe. Ich hätt's halt total gerne in Sync auf allen Geräten. Und dann ist es halt manchmal, machst du es aus, machst es nochmal an, machst es aus, machst es nochmal an und dann irgendwann irgendwie kommt es dann oder so.
Dass sie nicht kommen, hab ich nicht. Aber bei mir auf dem Rechner verwuselt der die in der Reihenfolge.
Ja, auch das, genau.
Du findest die dann manchmal ganz oben. Wenn du nach oben scrollst, findest du die letzten Nachrichten und dann die neuen kommen wieder ganz unten. Oder das ist ein bisschen, das funktioniert kaputt. Du hast dich jetzt gerade neu eingemeldet, Dennis.
Man sieht ja auch nicht, was jetzt von welchem Dienst kommt.
Ich meine, man kann das im Üben auch dresen. Also man kann noch mal gucken, ob... Also man sieht zwar nicht, was drin ist, aber du siehst ja, dass Verkehr stattfindet. Und dann kann man ja gucken. Aber wie gesagt, meine Argumentation ist, es steht und fällt mit der Apple-ID. Und auf der Apple-ID hat Apple die Hand drauf. Und die wird sogar offiziell rausgegeben. Auch in Deutschland Bestandsdaten-Auskunft. Da geht halt der Dorfpolizist hin und sagt, hallo, liebe Apple, ich brauch mal das Passwort für die Apple-ID so und so. Und dann meldet er halt einfach sein scheiß iPad oder was auch immer er da hat, meldet er einfach an. Und dann kullern da meine Nachrichten raus. So, deswegen können sie gerne den Transportweg verschlüsseln. Da freut sich dann Tempora drüber, dass sie mehr zu rechnen haben. Aber die Leute, die jetzt sozusagen den Finger auf der Apple-ID haben, haben auch den Finger auf den Nachrichten.
Also Prism kriegt's raus, Tempora nicht.
Ja, aber die sind ja eh verbunden.
Genau, jeder kümmert sich sozusagen um den einen Aspekt. Die Briten machen das wahrscheinlich auch nur deshalb, weil sie so schön an diesen Glasfaserkabeln dran sitzen.
Kappelwins, auch wo wir schon gerade im Politikmodus sind, auch die Mutmaßung, warum aus deutscher Sicht da gar nicht so viel gegen gesagt wird. Weil diese ganzen Systeme, ich meine, das ist ja bekannt, dass die Deutschen, wenn sie immer gerne mal wird abgehört oder durchsucht haben wollen, was sie selber nicht dürfen, dann fragen sie halt ihre französischen Kollegen und andersrum, warum soll das nicht auch mit den Briten oder mit den Amis so gehen? Guck mal, jedes Land sagt ja immer, ja, wir, unsere Bürger sind nach unserer jeweiligen Verfassung immer geschützt vor Abhörn, lalalalapipapo und alle Ausländer sind free game. Ja, wenn das jedes Land sagt, dann sagst du halt eben, bitte, ich müsste jetzt mal diesen Typen da in Berlin abhören, den darf ich aber gar nicht abhören, bitte französische Kollegen, mach doch das mal für mich. Und im Gegenzug höre ich dir einen in Paris, den du nicht abhören darfst. Und steck dich mal an mein Rechner wieder rein. So, du kriegst da nichts bei dir? Kommt da nichts?
Nein, nicht auf dem iMessage.
Mach mal das Messages nochmal aus und nochmal an.
Nee, nee, nee, pass auf, jetzt mach ich mal meinen Flugmodus wieder an.
Jetzt könntest du dein Telefon theoretisch nochmal verschicken, das wird es aber bestimmt auch nicht machen.
Aber mach mal dein Messages-App auch nochmal aus und mal an, das braucht auch manchmal so 2-3 Gänge, bis es sich so eingeruckelt hat.
Durchsynchronisiert.
Was machen wir hier?
Achso, der hat ja auch nur meine E-Mail als iMessage auf dem Rechner.
Hab ich auch nur benutzt, das andere hab ich nicht genommen.
Mach das nochmal aus richtig und nochmal an.
Hab ich doch gerade wieder eingeschaltet.
Übrigens gelesen. Die Testnachricht, die ich dir geschickt habe, steht als gelesen bei mir.
Ja, dann ist die die erste raus.
Nee, ich hab ja eben bloß eine eingeschickt.
Ja, die hab ich ja mit dem gelesen.
Die Frage war jetzt, ob die nochmal bei dir hinterherklötert, wenn du da deinen Rechner da einbuchst. Ach, ich liebe solche Experimente.
Nochmal?
Ja, so richtig hart.
Alter, das ist jetzt schon das fünfte, tausendste Mal hier.
Ein bisschen dran rumruckeln.
Aber irgendwie hab ich auch das Gefühl, dass es in den letzten Tagen auch wieder seit der iOS 7 Beta ist das mit den Messages und dem Synchronisieren auch wieder ein bisschen schwieriger geworden.
Hier bin ich immer noch im Flugmodus.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, ich will das Synchronisierungsfeature eigentlich schon haben.
Na, das geht ja. Wie gesagt, Public Keys von allen iMessage-Instanzen. So jetzt ist es angekommen, weil es ist offenbar.
Das klick mal an. Ist da auch die alte mit drin?
Mache ich hier mal meinen Flugmodus aus?
Ja, wollen wir noch mal ein anderes Themenkapitelchen aufmachen?
Hast du denn noch eins?
Eine Kleinigkeit. Wobei mir noch nicht so ganz klar ist, wie viel News hier eigentlich wirklich dran ist, aber ihr habt euch sicherlich total dafür interessiert. Sony hat ja jetzt endlich mal bekannt gegeben, wie ihre neue PlayStation aussieht.
FreeBSD!
Genau.
Wobei ich aber dann mal so ein bisschen hinterhergeklickt habe und laut Wikipedia schon bei der alten PlayStation FreeBSD zur Anwendung kam, in irgendeiner Form. Ich weiß aber nicht in welcher Form, auf jeden Fall war das so in den Credits wohl schon immer enthalten, aber jetzt geht so die News, jetzt sei das halt tatsächlich die Plattform, auf der sie aufsetzen und jetzt ist das Ding ja auch x86 basiert. Überhaupt scheinen sie da ein paar interessante Pfade eingeschlagen zu haben, wo sie so ein bisschen mit den alten Wegen brechen. Vielleicht machen sie es einfach nur einfacher, aber irgendwie weiß ich auch nicht so richtig. Zukunft haben diese Geräte nicht, oder?
War nicht bei der Playstation jetzt zumindest so. Microsoft hat das totale Vendor-Lock-In-Gerät mit nicht mal gebrauchte Spiele und Sony haben nie gesagt, dass jetzt sogar Indie-Publisher ihre Spiele sozusagen da einfach publishen können, ohne durch diesen Sony-Gateway durchzumüssen.
Das weiß ich nicht, ich weiß nur, dass sie nicht so einen Online-Zwang hatten und den hat ja Microsoft mittlerweile auch wieder gecancelt, nachdem der Schutzraum wohl zu groß war.
Also wenn sie wirklich so ein bisschen hier auf jeder kann sein Spiel da so publishen, so ein bisschen wie App-Store halt machen, das könnte halt schon noch mal was bringen, würde ich sagen. Also dann könnte das vielleicht noch mal eine Weile funktionieren. Es gibt schon viele Konsolen-Fans immer noch, aber ist halt auch nicht so mein Metier mehr, schon lange nicht.
Tja, vielleicht ist das die nächste Freenas-Konsole. Übrigens ist der Jordan Hubbard, der jetzt von FreeBSD kam und lange Zeit bei Apple war.
Ist das bei Sony? Ist der noch bei Apple?
Nee, der ist jetzt bei irgendeiner Glitcher, die aber Freenas-Development macht.
Echt, der ist von Apple weg?
Ja.
Hat aber eine fette Position bekommen, oder?
X-Systems heißt der Laden.
Das ist seine eigene Bude komplett.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Waren nicht letztens erst 20 Jahre FreeBSD oder sowas? Vor 20 Jahren hat der Hubbard das gegründet. Mit? Ich glaube schon, der war mitgründet, oder? Irgendwas war da.
Ich hab mal den Link hier in den Chat geworfen.
Das heißt, bei Apple...
Der ist also auf jeden Fall nicht mehr bei Apple. Sagen wir's mal so.
Das heißt, bei Apple gehen wir bald auf Linux jetzt.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall hat Apple da sozusagen ein Lied verloren. Warum? Auch immer. Aber hier heißt es halt, dass er irgendwie Freenas und Trunas und Tralala, was alles noch so ist, da irgendwie nach vorne bringen will. Der weiß auf jeden Fall ein bisschen Bescheid von dem ganzen Kram. Also ich frage mich, was man da irgendwie für die Motivation auf der einen Seite haben muss, bei Apple wegzugehen? Oder was für eine Motivation auf der anderen Seite? Wahrscheinlich wollte er einfach nur mal wieder ein bisschen nerdiger weiterhaken und hat keinen Bock mehr auf diesen großen...
Security-Scheiß und so. Also ernsthaft, bei Apple...
Was?
Nee, diese... Da darfst du ja auch nicht mal Piep sagen.
Ach so, den Security.
Die Apple-Hausinterne-Security. Da darfst du niemanden über nirgendwas nicht reden und so.
Ja, Apple kommt glaube ich so gleich nach beim Geheimdienst arbeiten.
Ich würde sagen noch davor, wie wir gesehen haben.
Nee, bei Apple darfst du zumindest sagen, dass du für Apple arbeitest.
Von Apple ist noch kein Wesselblower nach Hongkong abgehauen. Also von daher.
Vielleicht staunen die sich auch alle in Moskau. Wir haben bloß noch nichts davon gehört.
Ja, deswegen sagen wir, wir sind besser als der Geheimdienst.
Wir haben nichts mehr, oder?
Nicht wirklich.
Wir sind nicht so richtig im Flow.
Ja, wir waren heute schon ein bisschen im Flow.
Achso, ich wollte ja nochmal ein Produkt empfehlen.
Ich musste heute nochmal kurz ein per Tweet nochmal die Telekom-Hilft-Hotline nochmal richtig anfurzen. Warum? Die haben sich mal wieder unglaublich inkompetent gestellt. Da hat jemand versucht, okay, da hat auch versucht sie zu trollen. Da hat sie gefragt, wie das denn so ist jetzt mit Drossel und hin und her mit der Geschwindigkeit des Internetzugangs bei ISDN-Anschlüssen. Und die Hotline so, ja, das variiert halt. Er sagt, nee, gibt es da so eine Mindestgeschwindigkeit? Naja, die Geschwindigkeit von ISDN-Anschlüssen würde halt variieren. Ach. Wobei ich vor Wochen schon mal geschrieben habe, ich soll es sich mal hinter die Ohren schreiben und auf dem Poster, da hängt, dass jeder B-Kanal im ISDN immer 64.000 Bits pro Sekunde hat. Und zwar genau. Und wenn dem nicht so wäre, würde ihr Netz zusammenbrechen. Aber nein, das variiert halt mal. Es ist mehr, mal weniger. Das hängt halt von den Anschlussgegebenheiten ab. Nee, ich hab nicht versucht, sie zu trollen. Das war jemand anders. Aber die Antworten darauf finde ich echt immer wieder klasse. Ich wünschte wirklich, sie würden sich irgendwann mal ein Oh, das wissen wir nicht rausquälen, anstatt immer irgendeine Scheiße auszuspucken. Das könnte mich jedes Mal über aufregen.
Aber noch schlimmer ist die Nachricht eigentlich, dass Kabel Deutschland von Vodafone gekauft wird und auch noch der letzte gute Kundendienst bei einem Internetprovider jetzt wahrscheinlich aussterben wird. Das ist alles ganz schrecklich, weil man kann sagen, Kabel Deutschland ist jetzt vielleicht nicht das schnellste Netz, aber der Kundendienst war bisher so, wie es bei Alice mal früher war. Da rufst du an, kommst sofort durch, gucken sofort nach, helfen, schicken. Also das war immer so toll. Und jetzt Vodafone, of all the evils, one of the biggest.
Das ist eine nach unten offene Skala. Letzte Woche hatte ich mit der super tollen Firma Versatel zu tun, die kann man jetzt auch mal gerade ein bisschen bashen. Ich wollte eine Telefonnummer wegportieren von einem Kunden, das ist natürlich geplatzt, weil sie dessen Anschlussadresse falsch schreiben. Der Straßenname hat sich nämlich vor 10 Jahren geändert. Und Versatel schickt auch die Rechnung an die neue Adresse, behauptet aber steif und fest, dass der Anschluss immer noch an der alten Straße ist. Und sie lassen sich auch nicht belehren, wo kommen wir denn dahin? Ja, und ich soll dir das doch nachweisen. Und ich dann so, hallo, bin ich die Stadt Potsdam? Ihr habt doch das Straßenverzeichnis. Nein, aber es ist sehr lustig mal wieder. Also sie haben sich mal wieder von ihrer arschigsten Seite gezeigt. Aber das ist, das könnten wir jetzt auch so runterferner liefen abwogen. Aber wie gesagt, Telekom Arsch der Woche, Versatel. Können wir so eine kleine Rubrik machen?
Kauft denn jetzt, also ist das durch, dass Kabel Deutschland gekauft wird?
Also Kabel Deutschland jubelt ja auch, da gehen ja ein paar Leute mit entweder Geld oder goldenen Handschellen aus diesem Deal raus.
Und das aber für die Mitarbeiter, also solche Merger sind nie lustig für die Leute unterhalb der Oberfläche.
Ja.
Selbst für die Leute, die an der Oberfläche schwimmen, ist das nicht lustig. Aber die sagen sich halt, okay, für das Gehalt, was ich denn da kriege, gebe ich mir noch die zwei Jahre und dann danach immer gib ihm. Und ja, das ist eigentlich eher bedauerlich. Egal, ob man nur Kabel Deutschland mag oder nicht, aber so eine Dinge sind immer irgendwie bitter.
Ja, weil vor allem damit fällt halt die Möglichkeit, dass Kabel Deutschland, also haben sie ja bisher schon gezeigt, dass sie quasi so eine eigene Strategie hatten, die unabhängig ist eben von den großen Playern, das fällt halt jetzt wieder weg.
Was mich mal interessieren würde, langsam werden die ja nun wirklich richtig fett. Irgendwann mittelfristig wäre mal lustig, wenn die Regulierungsbehörde draufspringen würde und sagen so, oh, ein neues marktbeherrschendes Unternehmen. Hier habt ihr mal unser Regelbuch für marktbeherrschende Unternehmen.
Bevor davon.
Ja, das fände ich mal lustig. Guck mal, das ist jetzt nur ein kleines Detail, aber momentan ist ja immer noch der einzige Carrier, den es gibt, der diese Call-by-Call-Gespräche erlauben muss. Also 010 quietscht mich tot. Telekom. Übrigens geht auch über Voice-over-IP-Anschlüsse von Telekom. Manche Leute glauben das nicht, aber es funktioniert super, nutze ich täglich. Weil da gibt es dann so einen 01047, für den man z.B. für 2,2 Cent ins Mobilfunknetz telefonieren kann, statt für die üblichen 19, 15, 29 Cent, was denen nicht einfallen würde. Wie dem auch sei, das ist aber eine Sache, die ist bloß dem marktbeherrschenden Unternehmen aufgegeben. Und was jetzt mal lustig wäre, ist, wenn sich irgendeiner von denen mal so fett und voll frisst, und Vodafone ist gerade dabei, dass die Bundesnetzagentur dann sagt so, herzlichen Glückwunsch, You made it! Achievement unlocked! Hier ist unser Regelbuch für marktbeherrschende Unternehmen. Das wäre schon irgendwie, das würde mich mal freuen. Aber sonst gibt es da wenig dran zu......denen an positiven Dingen.
Nee, das geht bergab mit dem Internet in Deutschland. Stetig. Also es geht definitiv nicht bergauf mit dem Internet. Das ist wirklich haarig. Man hat irgendwie den ganzen Zeit das Gefühl, es ändert sich nichts. Oder?
Es ändert sich so Kleinigkeiten.
War das nicht schon vor 10 Jahren, dass sich die letzte Kleinigkeit geändert hat?
Ja, aber oft... Immer, wo wieder was Neues passiert, wenn man denken könnte, jo, reißen sie mit dem Arsch wieder ein. Also, wir haben uns vor ein paar Sendungen aber wegdringen, unterhalten, da gibt es jetzt irgendwelche Experimente, die da wirklich durchgeführt werden. Das ist ja mal ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung, rein technisch gesehen. Aber es wird halt wieder politisch, preispolitisch, tariflich wieder kaputt gemacht. Übendens genauso wie LTE. LTE ist eigentlich eine sehr brauchbare Technologie, gerade für die Fuzis auf dem Land. Aber es ist tariflich so kaputt, dass du es auch einfach sein lassen kannst. Auch in der Ausgestaltung. Es liegt nicht daran, wie man es baut. Man kann sich an Nachbarländern angucken, wie man das richtig bauen kann. Aber in Deutschland wird halt immer tolle neue Technik. Ich glaube, das machen sie auch nur, damit sie Frau Merkel beeindrucken können, damit sie wieder mal sagen kann, jo, wir haben jetzt hier Breitbandinitiative, super, macht mal. Aber alles, was sie dort technisch aufbauen, reißen sie mit dem Arsch, mit irgendwelchen kaputten Tarifen wieder ein. Deswegen kommen wir nicht voran. One step forward, two steps back.
Naja, wobei dieses Vectoring, das mag ja technisch ganz interessant sein, um mehr aus diesem Kupfer rauszubekommen. Aber ich hab auch so das Gefühl, solange wir immer nur über diese Kupfer reden, geht es irgendwie sowieso nicht vorwärts. Meine, wenn du jetzt Bundesminister für besondere Maßnahmen, Infrastruktur, Internetbeglückung und Zukunft wärst...
Ich würde mir erstmal einen Karton Kloppe bei Ikea bestellen. Auch nicht?
Diskutierst du noch oder überzeugst du schon? Hast du aber jetzt noch nicht gepostet, ne?
Findest du durch googeln IKEA-Kloppe. Also es gibt da durchaus relativ einfache Maßnahmen, die man da treffen kann, aber es gibt kein Interesse seitens der Politik bei uns. Nochmal, die Politik versteht sie immer noch nicht. Ich hatte es ja bei der letzten Blockblog bei Netzpolitik schon gesagt. Die Leute, die dort was verändern könnten, glauben immer noch, dass das was ist, wo irgendwelche Nerds dauernd YouPorn anklicken und der Rest sind Terroristen. Solange sie das nicht verstanden haben, dass das eine ganz andere Bedeutung hat, dass das eine fundamentale Bedeutung hat und nein, das ist kein Schnupfen, der morgen wieder weggeht und so weiter und so fort. Solange sie das nicht ins Hürn gekriegt haben, passiert da nichts.
Ja gut, das ist mir ja klar, aber das war jetzt nicht meine Prämisse. Meine Prämisse war, du bist jetzt einfach der, also die Revolution hat stattgefunden, ja, du wirst sozusagen direkt von deinem Landsitz ins Ministerium, also in dein eigenes Ministerium.
Verlege mein Ministerium.
Du kriegst ein Ministerium, was so aufgestellt ist wie das Finanzministerium. Das heißt, du kannst sozusagen allen anderen Ministerien reinreden.
Ich schalte dir die Fax-Leitung ab, wenn sie nicht spuren.
Genau, mindestens. Jetzt fährst du aber harte Bandagen auf hier.
Nehmen wir das Druckerpapier weg.
Die eigentliche Frage ist, was macht man? Wer nicht sowas wie die Bundesrepublik Deutschland baut jetzt mal richtig die Datenautobahnen und wir legen mal Glasfaser und überall wo verlegtes Glasfaser schon ist, was nicht benutzt wird, das wird dann einfach mal verstaatlicht. Und dann baut man da so seine Netzinfrastruktur auf und jeder Provider kann sich da einkaufen zu einem festgelegten Tarif?
Das wäre zum Beispiel eine Maßnahme. Also ich würde zum Beispiel mal hingehen und sagen, jeder der eine Infrastrukturmaßnahme macht, eine Straße baut, eine Brücke baut, einen Kanal oder sonst irgendwas baut, mit öffentlichem Geld, darf auf jeden Fall erstmal ein Leerrohr mit reinlegen. Und in dem Leerrohr liegt er bitte schön gleich, wenn er eh schon gerade die Schippe in der Hand hat oder so, liegt da gleich noch mal ein paar Glasfasern rein. So, die gehören dem Staat. So wie die Luft. Wie die Bundesnetzagentur ja auch die Luft immer regelmäßig vermietet und so weiter und fort. Da kann man jetzt staatlicherseits einen Backbone aufbauen, der sozusagen erstmal überall hinreicht. Das kann man durchaus machen, vor allen Dingen, wenn man eh die Schippe in der Hand hat, ist das gar nicht so teuer. Übrigens nur so nebenbei, so eine Glasfaser ist selber unglaublich billig. Was teuer ist, sind die Stecker an beiden Enden und was teuer ist, ist sie einzubuddeln. Die Glasfaser selber kostet nichts. Also jedenfalls nicht zu dem ganzen Dreck, den du oben auf eine Straße drauf gibst mit der Dampfwalze Blattwalzen. Auch nicht. Du brauchst übrigens auch viel weniger dafür. Du kannst halt einfach die Kapazität auf einer Glasfaser, das ist einfach so unendlich viel höher als auf ein Stück Kupfer. Und das können wir hier herstellen, das können wir mit Ressourcen herstellen, die wir hier in Deutschland haben. Dazu müssen wir nicht irgendwo in irgendwelchen fremden Ländern teuer Kupfer kaufen und so weiter und so fort. Also das kann man machen. Und wie gesagt, das wird genug gebuddelt in Deutschland. Ich würde einfach sagen, jede Ding, wo ein öffentlicher Euro reinfließt, da kommt ein Lehrer rein und dem Lehrer liegt schon mal eine Faser drin. So. Egal, ob man die jetzt an dieser Stelle schon mal braucht oder nicht, das wird ja in Deutschland auch mal eine Brücke mitten im Wald gebaut oder so nennen, machen sie halt da ein Ding mit rein. Irgendwann kommt rechts und links mal eine Straße und dann dockt man das da an. So. Und diese Ding, das muss wirklich in einer Form, da kann man jetzt lange drüber diskutieren, ob das jetzt eine Genossenschaft, wahrscheinlich nicht, wird ja schon an sich gegründet, aber in öffentlich-rechtlich-gesellschaft, in einer Stiftung oder wie auch immer dem gehört da Zeugs. Und da können sich dann Leute andocken. Da muss man sich jetzt überlegen, bis zu welchem Level man da jetzt die aktiven Komponenten draufmacht, was im übrigen Sinn macht, weil nur nackte Glasfaser anzuverleihen, das ist immer blöde, weil dann kannst du die Kapazität nicht ausnutzen. Also ausnutzen, das heißt, also wenigstens so ein Wavelength-Multiplexer rechts und links, der sollte halt mit dazugehören. Nö, dass du halt über eine Faser mehrere Lichtfarben sozusagen abbildest. Das ist halt nur schwer zu machen, wenn jetzt fremde Leute, oder es ist halt nur schwer zu bauen, wenn fremde Leute sich eine Faser teilen sollen. Nur ist natürlich in so einem Kabel immer mehr als eine Faser drin. Kannste auch machen, wenn du genügend von den Dingern hast, kannst du jedem seine eigene Faser geben und Spaß haben. Aber wie gesagt, darüber könnte man auch diskutieren. Aber das wäre jetzt ein bisschen mal so eine Sache, die kostet ungefähr nichts. Oder fast nichts. Damit könnte man erstmal was bauen. Und wenn du denn so ein Backbone hast, dann können sich dann da Leute dranhängen. Da können sich zum Beispiel auch durchaus kleinere Provider oder Dorfprovider bilden. Ich hab ja jetzt durch diese Aktivitäten, durch diesen Podcast oder die anderen CREs, kriege ich sehr häufig Anfragen von irgendwelchen Leuten, die sagen, wir machen hier in unserem Dorf was eigenes, hast du nicht mal einen Tipp, wie man das und das macht, oder wie man da Wireless oder sonst irgendwas macht. Es gibt da durchaus Interesse und das könnten durchaus auch mehr Leute machen. Dadurch würde auch mehr Konkurrenz entstehen. Oder eben auch die Dörfler können sich dann selber aussuchen, wie ihr Netz gestaltet wird, wie sie das tarifieren oder so weiter und so fort. Aber momentan hängen sie halt alle an dem Topf der Telekom.
Unser Dorf soll schneller werden.
Unser Dorf soll schneller werden. Ja, und das ist gar nicht so schwer. Du musst halt nur irgendwo die Bits herkriegen. Es gibt wirklich echt Initiativen, wo die Leute sagen, wir buddeln. Wir haben jetzt hier so ein Teilnehmer zusammen. Wir fassen jetzt mal alle die Schippe an und buddeln jetzt mal ein Stück Glas ein. Aber am Ende des Tages musst du dich halt auch wieder an den Rest der Welt stöpseln. Und das wäre zum Beispiel so eine Maßnahme. Aber da können wir jetzt stundenlang drüber das bisschen. Komm, erzähl mal was über Bitcoins, damit du wieder wach wirst.
Preis fällt.
Preis fällt?
Wo sind wir aktuell? Das ist relativ stabil. Bei UDI 80 rum.
Ja, zu wenig. Ich warte. Ich wollte noch hier so ein kleines Produkt, das wollte ich vorhin eigentlich erwähnen, als wir über diesen MagSafe Adapter gesprochen haben. Da gibt es hier diese kleine Bude Hardbrk. Das soll man wohl Work aussprechen, aber da fehlt das O. Also heißt es Hardbrk. Und Hardbrk bringt immer ganz pfiffige Sachen raus. Jetzt haben sie sozusagen dieses Problem mit diesem MagSafe Adapter erkannt. Einerseits gibt es halt diesen Adapter, wir sprachen ja schon darüber, aber wenn man einen hat, ist natürlich das Problem, das man wahrscheinlich nie zur Hand hat, wenn man ihn wirklich braucht. Für die Leute, die selektiv mal ein MagSafe 1 mal MagSafe 2 Gerät Strom zu führen wollen, kann man mit diesem kleinen MagSafe-Keeper einfach so ein bisschen Gummi, was diesen Adapter hält, mit einer Schlaufe und dann bindet man das ans Kabel. Wenn du den Adapter halt abmachst, dann baumelt der so direkt am Kabel und geht nicht verloren. Und wenn du ihn wieder dran machst, dann ist er dran.
Ist er doch eh schon voll fettmagnetisch und sollte da eigentlich eh schon nicht wirklich abfallen, oder?
Ja, aber wenn du ihn abnehmen musst, weil du ihn halt im Einser-Modus betreibst, wo tust du dann den Adapter hin? Das ist ja die Frage. Also es ist nicht so, dass er abfallen... Ja, gut, da liegt es dann halt auch. Also wenn man sozusagen seine ganzen alten Einser-Netzteile weiter verwenden will, dann...
Und noch Einser-Geräte hat.
Ja, oder auch nicht, weil es kann auch so... Ich meine, wenn du immer kräftig dagegen kommst, wenn du uns irgendwo in eine Tasche reinsteckst oder so was, dann fällt es auch schon ab.
Wenn du nur noch zwei Geräte hast, dann drauf ein Superglue und danke.
Na ja, ist ja so eine Kleinigkeit irgendwie. Machen wir Schluss? Was soll ich denn jetzt abspielen? Mal gucken, demnächst haben wir glaube ich noch ein bisschen schönere Outros, aber bis dahin muss das jetzt mal......nochmal Creepy Steve wieder herhalten. Ja genau, wir können ja auch mal ein bisschen euphorischer enden, oder?